hi everyone welcome to day three of
digital marketing week by simply log on
day 2 we looked at seo in detail today
we are going to focus on social media
marketing social media marketing allows
you to use social media channels to
market a company's products and services
it provides companies with a way to
engage with existing customers and reach
new customers social media marketing
also helps to promote the desired
culture and mission as well it allows
organizations to
improve customer satisfaction so in this
video you will get an introduction to
social media marketing and look at
facebook advertising you will understand
how to rank youtube videos increase
twitter and instagram followers and
finally learn about the top social media
marketing tools so let's get started
with learning how social media marketing
works
imagine it's the year 2004.
this is phil
phil's looking to release a book and set
up a blog he's sure that he'd be
successful but he's only worried about
one thing he doesn't know how to ensure
that his book reaches the right target
audience who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads billboards
radio direct mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved
now let's have a look at the same
scenario in the present day alongside
traditional forms of advertising phil
would have access to digital marketing a
form of marketing that's a lot more
lucrative inexpensive and configurable
marketing that would enable marketers to
advertise their audience digitally using
channels like search engines websites
social media platforms emails etc
among these types social media marketing
cop fields eye
social media marketing would give phil
the opportunity to take advantage of
social media platforms to advertise his
content to a highly targeted audience it
would help more people learn about his
book increase the interaction with his
audience it's relatively inexpensive
unless he goes into advertising and will
help him get marketplace insights that
might help in understanding his audience
preferences better
phil started by taking up a
certification to learn about social
media marketing
since he was already familiar with the
concept of social media marketing his
next step was to learn about the
different types of content he could post
on social media
some of the most common forms of content
that phil could post would be images
text posts polls and videos
but over time he'll begin to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content
phil needed to advertise his content for
that he would need to use the
advertising options provided by the
social media platforms like facebook
instagram youtube linkedin and twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text they also have a call to action
that encourages user interaction
phil could use images from his book
advertise websites that sell his book
and more
then there are text and post ads
these ads could advertise posts or
excerpts from phil's blog or his book
further garnering interest from an
interesting audience
he could also use video ads phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertise his books
phil could also use lead ads through
which he could collect information from
users who are interested in a weekly
newsletter or regular updates from his
blog
but that wasn't the only thing phil
could do with social media platforms he
could create a brand for himself and
drive audience interest to it engage
with them create an identity engage with
content finding content that works for
him
social media platforms also allowed him
the opportunity to target audiences
based on demographics like their age
location gender and much more
and in time phil began to see an
increase in the number of viewers coming
to his social media page and by
extension his blog
he also saw an increase in the number of
people who bought his book
greatly increasing his audience
here are some things he learned
one to set goals that were quantitative
smart and follow a constant deadline two
to understand his audience by engaging
and connecting with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
four
using tools like buzzsumo ifttt
buffer and more for lead generation
creating email lists setting buyer
personas and more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos
but how did phil get so good at social
media marketing phil taken up simply
learns digital marketing course it was
thanks to this course that phil had the
skills and training to get good at
social media marketing and now you can
too
by clicking on the top right corner and
with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing the world we
live in now it's highly digital place
but that wasn't always the case until
four years ago so if we rewind letting
people know about your products was a
little harder then so even if you go
back say five or ten years promoting
your products wasn't as easy as it is
today i mean people had to resort to you
know good old-fashioned newspapers
putting in an ad or those big thick
books called the yellow pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton i mean those were the ways to get
your product and message out there a lot
of advertising in those yellow pages
then you have billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise vfx just a few
decades ago so these were all the ways
in which people had to get their product
and service out there it seems like so
archaic looking at it now but back then
that was legitimate that was the way to
do it and then one thing made our lives
a lot easier so if you're a marketer
you're thinking yourself man i'm glad
i'm a marketer in today's day and age
because it's social media marketing
social media marketing has made
everyone's lives better from the company
that's selling the product or service to
the marketer promoting the product and
service to the end user who wants to see
that product or service and engage with
that product or service so social media
is a good source of getting your product
and service out there and it just makes
everybody's lives a heck of a lot easier
so we're going to answer that million
dollar question and what's that million
dollar question it's how can you rise
above the rest and so today's session is
going to be how to start with social
media marketing so you can rise above
the rest leveraging this great platform
that we all take advantage of today so
let's start by asking the question what
is social media marketing social media
marketing involves increasing website
traffic it centers around engagement it
offers you the ability to increase your
brand awareness and it has other
marketing goals you know so you can
create various forms of content for
different social media platforms so
that's really in a nutshell with social
media marketing so again if we want to
increase our traffic or we want to
increase our engagement like likes or
comments then look no further than
social media marketing if we want to
engage with our users our customers our
potential and prospective customers we
can really put a personalized experience
in place using social media marketing we
want to create different forms of
content like videos and blogs and
infographics
and other types of graphics with the
potential to actually go viral
by viral is spreading like wildfire one
user sending it to another as rapidly as
can be and before you know it you get
you know millions of views and millions
of likes i mean that's the power of
social media marketing so why do we want
to do social media marketing and i think
we just answered some of those questions
but let's dig a little bit deeper we
mentioned in our definition of social
media marketing that we have the
opportunity to
really build our brand awareness and
that is no more truthful than with
social media marketing more so than any
other digital marketing channel social
media marketing allows us to really put
our brand in a good light in a good
position in front of the right eyeballs
so it allows us to really improve our
brand by pushing out the appropriate
content in front of the appropriate
people social media is a great channel
for that we can look to conversion rates
so if we are pushing a product and
service in front of the right eyeballs
and we are building up a funnel of
prospective customers who then turn into
customers who then turn into loyal
customers who then turn into lifetime
customers we could see at every step in
the process that our conversion rates
may increase
we can certainly leverage social media
marketing for seo for search engine
rankings it's about off-page seo it's
about posting content on social media
platforms to build up some link juice
okay so there is some inherent benefits
to working seo and social media side by
side it's cost effective well if you're
posting content on twitter or facebook
it doesn't cost you anything it just
takes a little bit of time and
creativity now if you want to go ahead
and do some advertising on these
platforms yes it's going to cost you but
you'd be surprised not going to be as
costly as say other search platforms
like say google or bing where you're
actually paying for keywords and paying
per click for those keywords so social
media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from seeing
your brand for the first time to
getting to know your brand a little bit
more to maybe buying a product or
service from your brand then returning
to buy another product and service and
then continuing to buy that product or
service i mean that's increasing the top
funnel traffic and not just the traffic
but the conversions so at every step in
the process social media allows you to
build that funnel depending on where
somebody is whether they're seeing your
brand for the first time or actually
returning to purchase the product or
service again so that's the inherent
benefit these are the inherent benefits
of social media marketing now we talk
about social media marketing what are
the channels used for social media
marketing how can we use them it's
really social media marketing is a
channel in itself so let's take a look
at the platforms involved with social
media marketing now there are some
really popular platforms so if you can't
tell just buy these logos then you
probably have not used social media
marketing or social media platforms
before or taking part in social media at
all but you know one would like to think
that the majority of your users out
there today know what facebook is what
the logo looks like what it does same
with instagram which is owned by
facebook linkedin b2b platform it's
youtube great very popular
video sharing platform and then twitter
which is considered microblogging but
still social media so these are the most
popular popular platforms out there but
there are hundreds of social media
platforms in fact when we talk about
social media marketing it can be
anything from micro blogging to video
sharing like youtube to b2b networks
like linkedin to say
bookmarking sites like stumbled upon
content sharing sites like reddit q and
a sites like cora so there's plenty of
different types of social media
platforms
out there in fact if you folks have any
popular or you think
valid social media platforms that these
listeners here should really get to know
and understand and use then go ahead and
put that in the comments section
underneath this video i'm always
interested in knowing what social media
platforms are out there and what people
are using how platforms are trending
what's popular what's not and ideally as
a digital marketer where my target
audience is so these are the most common
but there are hundreds out there
hundreds so let's talk about the most
popular social media platform and that's
facebook so
facebook has an average of
2.27 billion monthly active users now
that number is fluctuating because we're
talking about billions billions billions
of monthly active users and that number
is probably trending up 88 of all users
are on mobile so what does that tell you
that tells you that facebook has an app
and the app is very popular in fact i
tend to use the app more than i use the
web page for facebook okay so i don't
necessarily log on via the internet on
my laptop i go right to the app it's
just easier easier to disseminate
information easier to add friends
comment respond etc so it's no surprise
that 88 of all users use mobile now 66
percent of mobile monthly users use
facebook daily so a lot of recurring
users going back on a day-to-day basis
two-thirds so it's an addiction more
than it is anything else because what
facebook is is really you're getting
information from the people you trust
care about like work with share a group
wish or common interest with partake in
the same organization maybe have the
same running group same passions i mean
that's what facebook is it's a
commonality amongst people and if you
build up a network of that commonality
it's going to be addicting to take part
in that you know the closest network you
can ever get to is your family so if
your family's on facebook then likely
you're going to be on facebook
communicating with your family via this
platform especially if you don't live
close to your family or especially if
you don't live close to your friends i
know in the united states you know
people move a lot for work or people
travel a lot for work and so facebook
bridges that gap between distance and
you you know you do feel like you're
part of somebody's life on a daily basis
being on facebook so that's what makes
it the addictive part so if you think
about it from an end user's perspective
it makes total sense now if you wear
your digital marketing hat and you're
thinking hey two-thirds of monthly users
are using it daily and there's billions
of active users then whoever i'm
targeting has to be on facebook now if
we look closer at the demographics we
could see that a lot more seniors age 65
plus are using facebook so 60 plus
percent of seniors are using facebook so
facebook is trending older however 35 of
the audience is below the age of 25 so
it's not just trending up it's also
trending down so a lot of young people
are still using facebook and then
facebook you know is pretty evenly
matched between males and females now if
i'm either slewing old feeling older or
skewing younger on my target audience
and half female half as male then i know
somewhere in there whoever i'm targeting
is going to be on facebook just based on
these numbers here so your demographic
is likely going to be on facebook again
depending on your industry depending on
your product or service but considering
the number of people and how it's
skewing older and younger and everybody
in between facebook has something for
everyone now facebook allows for video
content so you could post videos all day
long so if you have youtube videos you
can share those youtube videos on
facebook in fact video just like on most
platforms tends to provide better
engagement and the industries that can
really capitalize on facebook tend to be
food and beverage news and media and
e-commerce meaning you're selling a
product facebook has you know plugins
and that allow you to really accentuate
what you're trying to sell and when i
say that accentuate i mean really
incorporate an opportunity for people to
use the facebook platform to not only
just engage not only to share but to buy
taking that process a step further so if
you're selling a product you can more or
less set up a facebook shop if you will
and sell your product there so that's
why it benefits those that are are in
the e-commerce industry selling a
particular product or in the food and
beverage industry now some of the most
liked pages on facebook spans across
many many brands but let's just take a
look at coca-cola for example and
coca-cola just pretty much pinpoints
everything great about what you could do
on facebook i mean you could see here
they have their opening page is a video
and so you can see they're posting
different content about you know this is
about a grant how they're helping the
city of atlanta you know they're talking
about recycling so to me these are
community-based posts so they're not
necessarily just pushing out their
product per se they're trying to use
facebook to build up brand awareness so
a huge fortune 500 company like
coca-cola is not necessarily just using
facebook just to push e-commerce to push
a product they're out there you know
pushing what they're doing for the
community so this is a good example of
you know how you can really leverage
facebook taking advantage of everything
facebook has to offer and that means
brand awareness community building
you're sharing you know updated
information not only about the company
but in this case coca-cola is situated
in atlanta georgia in the united states
so you know what are they doing with the
community okay so this is a good example
of course it's a big example because
coca-cola is a big company they're
worldwide but the great thing about
facebook is you can always take a peek
at what other companies are doing
whether you have a million plus people
liking your page or a hundred plus
people liking your page you can always
get ideas as to how they're leveraging
facebook now if you do have a company
you can create a facebook page for your
business just like coca-cola so you want
to be able to separate out your business
from your personal pitch and like
everything you do whether that's writing
a blog or creating a video you want to
have original content that's relevant to
your audience you want to use facebook
for
some promotion but every post doesn't
necessarily need to be promoting your
product or service you saw what we just
witnessed on the coca-cola page it was
about what they were doing to
you know benefit the earth with
recycling or what they're doing in
conjunction with the with the city of
atlanta so they're more community-based
post and so to me that's original
content positive content that isn't
necessarily pushing their product per se
now you could argue hey it's coca-cola
they have the biggest brand in the world
and that's true but just think about
your product and service think about
your brand if you're trying to build
brand awareness what does your brand
stand for and if your brand stands for
say
the the globe the ecosystem the
environment then you probably want to be
pushing out post in that direction if
that's what you stand for as a brand
then you want people to know that
because like-minded people are on
facebook and those like-minded people
are going to be the ones who like your
page who engage with your content and
tell other people about it so you always
want to go original you always want to
be true to yourself and true to your
brand and then you could take advantage
of user-generated content like sharing a
user's experience of using your product
so in other words if somebody's engaging
with you or they've posted something
about your brand and product you can
reciprocate you can certainly post
something that is similar to what
somebody's doing with your product or
brand so that's a good way to create
some original content by taking
advantage of what the users have
generated so these are just some
examples of how to take advantage of
facebook i mean there's lots of things
you can do on facebook plenty of things
if we float back to coca-cola page you
know you can see they have you know
careers they have different videos they
have reviews they have community so
nowhere in here do i see an e-commerce
platform now if you are selling t-shirts
then hey you can put something in there
to help you sell that t-shirt but
coca-cola's strategy is hey what can we
do to help build up our community what
can we do to fundraise so if we click on
fundraise you can see they have you know
an n aids campaign here if you look at
simply learn just as another example you
can see what simply learns done as well
you can see they have information
about us they have different events they
have a community link as well and so you
can see what they're posting as well and
there you can see they're posting
visitor photos so there's lots you can
do on facebook you can post polls you
can put your instagram feed in there you
can add testimonials so there's a lot
you can do on your page you just gotta
get creative and take advantage of
everything facebook has to offer be true
to yourself and before you know it i
mean you're going to have you know a
number of likes on your business page as
well so some other tips about facebook
when it comes to content you want to
schedule your content okay you don't
want to just continue to to post back to
back to back to back you want to space
your content out and
another great advantage to facebook as i
already mentioned about social media
marketing that's advertising so facebook
owns instagram they have a great tool
for communicating called facebook
messenger and so you can advertise
leveraging facebook messenger you can
leverage instagram and what you need to
do is if you go to facebook's ad manager
and you create a campaign when you go to
create a campaign you're going to click
on placements and depending on what
you're trying to do let's just say
you're trying to build brand awareness
you can actually hone in on you know
facebook you can hone in on instagram
you can do a number of different things
within facebook you have different ads
available to you from single image ads
to video ads to carousel so you have a
lot of options and the biggest option on
facebook when it comes to advertising is
your audience who are you targeting so
remember facebook has old young and
everybody in between between men and
women and so you can specifically target
interest you could specifically target
gender an age a location so facebook
really allows you to hone in on who your
audience is if you're advertising and so
that's the great thing about facebook
they have a lot of users and
you're you have an opportunity to hone
in on a segment of that user base now
facebook also has metrics that you can
look at to really understand how people
are interacting with your ads how inner
people are interacting with your post so
let's take a look at that so if we go to
facebook when you go to your page you
can click on insights and you can
actually see some insights on posts that
have been posted on your page you can
get insights into how many people viewed
it how many people liked it how many
people engaged how many people you
reached with your post okay you have
information about videos followers
facebook provides recommendations so
this is all part of facebook insights so
if you're posting on facebook facebook
will give you feedback as to how your
posts are performing now if you're
running ads on facebook you can simply
just view metrics related to how your
ads are performing so you can see how
many people clicked on an ad how many
people the ad reached how much you've
spent okay you can look at it by
demographic you can even see cost per
result so you can get a lot of good
insight into how your ads are performing
as well so if you're running a campaign
targeting a specific audience on
facebook you can look at the you know
stats and metrics surrounding that
campaign and again for your facebook
page you have facebook insights so if
you have any questions
you know feel free we have a video
called uh facebook advertising uh tips
and tricks so feel free to you know take
a look at this video on simply learn's
youtube channel for more information
about facebook and if again if you have
any comments to share about facebook
feel free to put them under the comment
section okay let's turn our attention to
one of the platforms facebook actually
owns instagram so instagram is a place
where you can actually promote your
brand product or service through the
power of imagery or video and so the
average number of monthly users on
instagram reaches 1 billion and 32 of
all internet users are on instagram so a
lot of users using it it's very easy
platform to use you just the only
prerequisite you need your mobile phone
so you open up that app it's as simple
as just uploading uploading an image
that's why instagram is so popular
because it's just a simple tool to use
to go ahead and just post an image with
some hashtags so 68 of all instagram
users are women so unlike facebook it
does tend to slant more on the female
side and 59 percent of the audience is a
bit younger between age 18 to 29 so
slants more women and slams more younger
and so if these particular demographic
and age groups tend to
fit your target audience then instagram
is a place you probably want to be for
social media marketing so as i mentioned
content that works best are photos or
videos i would always slant towards
videos if you have them available with
photos you know the rule of thumb is
photos always tell a thousand words a
thousand stories a thousand
interpretations images are just always
the best way to go as well i mean if you
don't have the videos hey nothing to be
sad about if you fall back on imagery so
you can really put your brand in a good
perspective and a good light by posting
images and as you can imagine if 18 to
29 year old women are on
instagram you know that's skewing
towards a certain demographic but in
terms of industry it is open to most
industries but the ones that tend to be
most successful are
beauty food and beverage and e-commerce
now food beverage always tends to work
well when you have video and imagery
likewise beauty but e-commerce if you're
selling that t-shirt or shoe you know
instagram allows the platform to
work in a way where people can purchase
that product right within the platform
so that's why it tends to work well with
e-commerce okay there are lots of
channels just like on facebook lots of
channels on instagram i mean some of the
most followed brands are chanel
starbucks nike i mean if you have a
product or service that you want to push
out there then instagram is the way to
go just for brand awareness if you're
selling shoes then why not take images
of and photos of those shoes and get
them posted on instagram like i said
it's very simple to use all you need is
some hashtags to go along with that
photo of a shoe or photo of that cup of
coffee and instagram kind of takes care
of itself i mean photos do
accentuate the product if you have them
so leverage instagram if you're really
trying to build up some brand awareness
for a particular product some best
practices here on instagram is you know
have a compelling bio a good profile
picture you know add a link to a landing
page and you know leverage emojis if you
have to so set yourself up nicely on
instagram you know if you're in a
particular industry like food and
beverage follow other food and beverage
brands like coca-cola like starbucks
depends on what it is you really want to
be related to so just make sure they're
relevant get hashtags can't stress that
enough you know when you post a photo
there's some hashtags in there you can
see what other people are hashtagging on
instagram and you can ride that wave of
what's trending or you can create your
own unique hashtag i'd probably have two
to three hashtags per photo and don't be
afraid to use both photos and videos
videos do tend to work well on pretty
much any platform they tend to work well
on websites and blogs so why not use
them on social media where people can
engage okay so videos and imageries both
work well on instagram okay you can also
get shout outs from other influencers
plenty of influencers on instagram
especially in beauty especially in food
and beverage fashion tends to be another
industry that has a lot of influencers
so feel free to reach out to them
reciprocate see how you can work
together where they can actually you
know give you a shout out on your
particular product you want to keep your
instagram account updated and you can
update those with instagram stories it's
basically you showing off a particular
product you know over a span of a few
seconds or even a minute that's an
instagram story they're very popular uh
easy to use you can even run contests to
boost engagement so
for example if your particular product
is a particular food like a hamburger
you know hey post a contest about you
know allowing your followers to post the
best good looking tasty you know
hamburger as an example or it could be
something else in terms of fashion hey
what's your best outfit on a friday
night before you go out for the evening
you know there's always things you can
do to spur engagement especially on a
platform like instagram where people
like to post photos and then i mentioned
this earlier with facebook ads you can
run instagram ads to give a particular
post a boost so we take a little
snapshot of what we have available in
facebook ads manager you can choose
instagram as the particular platform so
if you just want to
advertise on instagram when you go to
your placements you can choose just
instagram either the feed or the stories
okay so you can choose one of these two
options if you want to want to boost
your posts get some more eyeballs on
that it's a cost per click platform so
anytime somebody clicks it's going to
cost you but you know just like facebook
you know the cost per click tends to
slant a little bit lower it really
depends on what you're trying to post
when you're trying to post it and who
else is posting but hey the instagram
feed and the stories could be a good
option if you're really trying to draw
attention to a particular product okay
let's turn our attention now to the b2b
platform called linkedin linkedin is a
very powerful popular business to
business platform okay it has 260
million active users monthly and
unlike instagram where instagram slants
more towards women linkedin slants more
towards men 57
so a majority of the users are men but
still you have a lot of women involved
in on linkedin so a nice you know nice
mix between both genders 38 of the user
base are millennials you know a lot of
young people older people a nice mix
from a business lots of different
different business segments different
levels of business different business
industries and verticals are on linkedin
so don't be you know shying away from
linkedin if your demographic or target
audience tends to be older just because
are millennials doesn't mean anything it
means that everybody's using it just
that means that hey you know more than
one-third of the users are millennials
are younger now linkedin is a b to b
platform so if you're in
the business of generating business
leads then linkedin is the place for you
to go there's opportunities for you to
advertise on linkedin okay there's also
opportunities for you to post lots of
different content on linkedin so content
that works on linkedin could be a blog
it could be you know particular news
article you know tips and best practices
i've posted videos on linkedin you know
it's good for jobs there's a lot of
content on linkedin so if we take a
sneak peek at linkedin if i just go to
linkedin here you know and i just go to
my home uh the start news page you know
i could see the types of content that's
been posted so somebody just posted
something with an image you know then
you got an article down here okay you
got you know an influencer like richard
branson posting so you got a lot of
different types of posts that you'll be
able to see and
you know leverage if you want to meaning
when i say leverage if you see somebody
like richard branson posting something
hey stay fit and healthy you know that's
an image that's something about not
about business per se but you know
something interesting and unique so you
can see all sorts of different types of
content based on who you're following on
linkedin and who you're connected to
some things about linkedin you always
want to create an engaging profile when
i say engaging first things first make
sure it's complete i mean there's lots
of opportunities so if you sneak over to
my profile here you want to be able to
post a lot of information about yourself
so about what you're affiliated with
what jobs you've held what groups you're
associated with what your interests are
what certifications you have so you want
to be able to
you know complete your total profile you
can create a company page for your
business so if we go back to linkedin we
can just do a search for say simply
learn and let's take a look at you know
their business page so if i just do a
search for simply learn here so i select
their page you can see just like your
profile page if you have a business page
set up on linkedin you want to make sure
it's complete you want to put
information about the company what jobs
are available and you want your company
to
associate with that business page
anybody who does you know follow that
particular business page part of the
organization is going to be listed under
people so and you want to be able to
post just like on your personal profile
if you have a business page you want to
be able to post unique content i mean
you can see here simply learn is posting
you know some of the accolades that they
have but they're taking that a step
further they're also posting you know
information about you know upcoming
events and webinars so they're posting a
mix of different content and that's
ideally what you want to do on any
social media platform is mix it up and
just like you can on facebook just like
you can on instagram you can you know
boost a post per se okay so you can get
that post in front of some additional
eyeballs now of course you want to
optimize your company page for searches
so it really does come down to
how many people are following you but
when you say when we say optimize your
company page just make sure it's
complete with some compelling content
and then increase the number of
followers you have so the great thing
about linkedin that i like the most is
that you know you can you know simply
look at other people if i go back to say
the home page you can actually see who's
following what and you know linkedin
does give you um opportunities to
connect with people okay so if i go to
you if you go to your profile you'll be
able to see
other people that have viewed your
particular page and you can connect with
them okay or connect with people who are
like-minded or similar or connected to
people that you know so linkedin does a
good job of presenting other people you
can connect with so it makes it easier
for you to increase the number of
followers so having an engaging profile
personal profile you know having an
engaging company page making sure both
your personal and the company page have
all the content necessary have all of it
completed and then increasing followers
posting unique content i mean that's
really the key to linkedin now again
with linkedin you can use different
media you can use videos slideshare
presentation images and you can boost
content as i mentioned before you can
boost content on linkedin so if you want
to get that content in front of eyeballs
you can do that so let's take a look at
an example of a campaign and what you
could do on linkedin in terms of
sponsored content so if you go to
linkedin's campaign manager i mean you
have an opportunity to put your ad in
front of a particular audience so it
really depends again on who you're
trying to target just like facebook
which slants more towards personal
linkedin is going to slam it more
towards business so with linkedin you
have an opportunity to target a
particular industry a particular company
a particular job title okay so you could
target everything business related on
linkedin so you can go ahead and create
an ad the ads have imagery to support
the ad and so basically when you set up
your ad you set up your target you can
choose your placement you're going to be
able to see you know who it is you're
actually targeting and you can go ahead
and great thing about linkedin is you
have different ad formats and again you
can get really creative with who you
want to target and just like facebook
you know linkedin has you know some
metrics that you can measure and figure
out how your particular campaign
performs by impressions by click click
through rate even conversions cost per
conversions and how many leads so
linkedin has built-in platform for
measuring campaign success and so the
differentiation between facebook and
linkedin is really just the type of
demographics that you have to choose
from you know with linkedin you do have
you know different options available
based on business like your job title or
job level or industry or vertical so you
have a lot of examples available a lot
of options available to you on linkedin
in terms of advertising okay let's talk
about youtube now so youtube has 1.9
billion active users if it was a search
engine it'd be the second most popular
search engine the highest number of
monthly active users in decreasing order
starts at the united states brazil
russia japan and india all big markets
all like to use youtube but youtube's
popular across the world just like
facebook where the app is popular the
app on for youtube is very popular so 70
of all views are generated from mobile
so with youtube being a video platform
you
definitely need videos now there's a lot
of industries on youtube a lot of
industries um in some of the most
successful brands on youtube you know
range from logo to coca-cola you know
pretty much to every brand if you're a
brand you want to be on youtube because
of the massive reach that youtube has to
offer coupled with video and how great
video is in terms of engagement it's
like just a great combination okay so
some best practices here for youtube you
want to optimize your video for seo to
get views and so we have a video that
we've created at simplylearn how to rank
youtube videos
so if you watch that video you'll get
some really good tips and strategies
about how to you know optimize your
video for youtube the very least you
want to make sure that you're using
write the right keywords in the title
description and hashtags so that's a
start when we talk about optimizing your
videos you want to upload regularly and
fix the schedule for your videos because
if you're starting to get followers on
youtube or subscribers they're going to
expect you to produce more video
especially if you're producing engaging
unique relevant content for that target
audience so we're not saying you have to
have a video once a day or once a week
start small and build up and get on a
regular schedule and then you can
organize your videos in the playlist so
you know if we look at simply learn you
know simply learn does a good job of
organizing their videos into a playlist
so all you have to do is go to i'm a
founder and ceo simply learns uh youtube
channel and you can see how it's broken
down into playlist now youtube also has
the ability because it is global you do
have the ability to provide translations
so if your target audience is from
another country it probably wouldn't be
a bad idea
like facebook and instagram or like
linkedin you can advertise on youtube
you would just need to do that through
google ads so with google ads you're
going to say google i want to advertise
on youtube and you have plenty of
available options to available to you
anything from you know pre-roll to
showing up in the middle of a video to
showing up you know before or excuse me
at the end of a video all the way to
native content marketing where you know
your ad is showing up next to a video so
you've plenty of options for advertising
on youtube and then just like on
instagram there are influencers on
youtube you know feel free to reach out
to these influencers and see if you can
collaborate in some way where maybe you
post their video on your channel they
post your video on their channel and
vice versa so you want to be able to
maybe collaborate somehow to get some
views on your video okay let's talk
about twitter now so twitter is a micro
blogging platform and so when i say
micro blogging i mean limited in
characters limited in how much you can
actually post but it's very popular it
has 326 million active users per month
and it does tend to slant a lot towards
millennials a lot of young people use
twitter and a lot of people use it to
get their news so no longer are the days
of grabbing that newspaper no longer the
days of going maybe to a media news site
online you can quickly go to twitter and
get all your news right there in a feed
an easy feed let's take a peek at
twitter here you know i can get
everything from you know somebody
posting something specific about their
dog you know all the way to a particular
job you know all the way to industry
news you know all the way to
basically an advertisement all the way
to a specific news article so it's all
here on twitter in your feed so twitter
does offer videos so videos do work well
so if i go back here you can see you
know here's a video of antonia brown
he's posting a video of his news
conference and another promotional video
so industries that capitalize on twitter
as you can guess if a lot of people go
there from their news you'll probably
see a lot of news in media and
entertainment on twitter so that doesn't
necessarily mean that you can't use
twitter for your brand it really comes
down to target audience some of the most
influential brands are slanted more
towards you know news and media but you
know you got cosmetics you got gaming
companies you got everybody's on twitter
okay it just comes down to does this
platform have your target audience and
given the nature of twitter you know how
can you get your particular brand
product or service out there in so many
characters okay some other advantages
and
best practices you can use on twitter so
i would recommend implementing twitter
cards and really all twitter cards does
is allow you to attach rich photos or
videos and different media experiences
to tweets so when you can attach you
know rich media like videos and images
to tweets it can help drive traffic and
engagement to your website all it's
going to take is just a few lines of
markup to your web page and then users
who tweet links to your content will
have a quote unquote card added to the
tweet that's visible to their followers
so that's how it works i would certainly
look to get twitter cards implemented if
you are going to use twitter as your
platform or choice for social media
marketing so it does enhance the
experience for the end user and because
allows you as an advertiser or as
somebody leveraging social media to
really enhance your tweet and it just
provides a better experience for the end
user who's looking at your tweet and so
like linkedin you can really take a look
at
who's trending what's trending on
twitter so twitter makes it easy for you
to you know follow so here they'll list
a who to follow so these who to follow
are similar to what you've been posting
or similar to your industry and then
here you can look at trends you can look
at what hashtags are trending and so if
you click on a particular hashtag you
can you know follow a particular
you know person who or an organization
who tweeted something
so you always are reminded in twitter
who to follow and so it makes it easier
for you to pick and choose who to follow
and build up your following fairly
quickly because twitter actually
provides you with opportunities on who
to follow just like linkedin just like
youtube just like instagram there are
influencers out there people who have a
large number of followers who tweet on a
regular basis who tweet original content
who get high engagement these are
influencers and these are the people you
want to engage with so look for those
people on twitter follow them i mean the
rule of thumb is if you follow someone
on twitter you know generally they're
going to follow you back so if you can
engage and follow influencers you have
an opportunity to see not only what
they're tweeting but the ability to
communicate with them and engage with
them as an influencer so maybe they can
retweet one of your tweets and get that
tweet out in front of their followers so
you can advertise on twitter and the
unique thing about advertising on
twitter you can you know promote your
tweet just like you promote a post on
facebook or instagram or linkedin but
more so i think than any other platform
is the use of hashtags and so use
appropriate relevant hashtags i always
tend to use a unique hashtag but also
depends on what you're tweeting about if
there's something that's trending and
again twitter will tell you what's
trending in terms of hashtags if it's
something you're tweeting about then go
ahead and use that hashtag as well you
can have multiple hashtags in a
particular tweet and so don't be afraid
to use a unique hashtag along with a
hashtag that's trending because the
whole idea is you want your tweet to get
noticed and then you can use tweet chat
or some there's some other tools out
there that are available to allow you to
find people to follow and these people
might be
interested in your product or service
because you know they could fit your
target audience or you can connect with
like-minded folks who are in the same
industry or have similar products or
interests so tweet chat's available for
that reason and you want to take
advantage of these tools because again
with twitter it's easy to build a
following but you want to build a
following
that is going to engage with your tweets
so let's talk about what tools are
available for social media marketing so
when we talk about all these platforms
available to us okay we talked about
facebook and instagram and we talked
about linkedin and twitter and youtube i
mean those are popular platforms but at
the beginning of the session i mentioned
there's hundreds of social media
platforms out there and if you're
posting content on a number of them you
want to be able to organize that content
you want to be able to organize it and
schedule it you know where it makes
sense and when it makes sense you want
to stay organized and so there are tools
available to help you stay organized
tools like hootsuite buffer or sprout
social okay some of these tools are
available you know at a cost of a free
trial or at a low cost per month so
regardless of whether using a free
version of one of these tools or another
tool not listed or you're actually
paying for it it's worth the investment
if you're going to partake in social
media marketing and even if you're on
one platform it's still worth it to have
a social media tool available to help
you schedule and not only do these
social media tools help you schedule
they do a lot of other things too for
example they help you measure the
engagement of your post so let's take an
example of one of them like sprout
social so if i go to sprout social here
i can see for a particular company i'm
able to see you know how my post and get
were engaged okay so i can see daily
engagements on particular platforms i
can also you know schedule my post so i
can go ahead and pick a time and date to
schedule them and so i can go ahead and
post something and put it in a queue to
be published for example tomorrow or
next week or whatever the case may be so
these tools do a lot for you i mean they
help you discover new followers they
give you in-depth reports they help you
stay organized and so
to me it's worth the investment to look
at one of the tools listed here you know
these are some of the more popular ones
to maybe even a free version but
regardless of how much you pay and what
tool you're using it's still worth the
investment just to make sure you're
scheduling your post at the appropriate
time so you're not posting something
back to back as an example and you're
able to measure accordingly so it's nice
to be able to go into a tool like sprout
social go to reports and
measure
you know in one place you know how
twitter is performing or how facebook's
performing or how linkedin's performing
and so that's what a lot of these tools
provide is nice reporting options and
nice
scheduling options so
you can find more content you can create
by using these tools again you can
schedule efficiently analyze them and
you can use insights to improve your
campaign so a lot of these tools give
you nice insights to how the post was
actually engaged and you want to be able
to leverage that and some of these tools
if not all of them have social listening
and social listening is monitoring
what's being posted out there so what
else is posted you can take a look at
and if it's something interesting or
relevant you can go ahead and follow or
take part in that conversation okay so
that's what social listening allows you
to do and a lot of these platforms have
that as a feature so let's take a look
at tips to be a good social media
marketer so some of the important things
you should take care of are
set up a social media marketing plan
when i say set up a social media
marketing plan there's some questions
you want to be able to ask okay what
platforms am i going to use what's my
objective on each platform in fact in
before you choose the platform you want
to figure out what your objective is in
terms of social media so your objective
could be different on each platform it
could be brand awareness on facebook and
it could be promoting a particular
product on twitter your objective is
going to be on each platform you want to
be able to choose your kpis and align
your kpis with each platform meaning
what metrics are important to your
business goals and you want to be able
to figure out okay what kind of content
am i going to post on these social media
platforms so you want to get organized
and put a plan in place and then you
want to create informative shareable
actionable and relevant content and what
i mean by all that is you want to create
unique content that doesn't mean you
can't leverage what other people are
doing meaning you know if i'm you know
in the shoe business i can certainly go
to nike or adidas or puma or reebok and
see what kind of post they're putting
out and then i could take their cue and
do something similar but i want it to be
unique to me and i wanted to be unique
to my brand and i want to be able to
keep my content visual meaning i want to
be able to use as many photos and videos
as i can that's available to me because
remember videos generate better
engagement i want to be active and
responsive with my customer base meaning
the whole point of social media is to
engage and people are going to respond
they're going to comment they're going
to take part in what you post and so
whatever they do you want to be able to
respond accordingly whether that's
positive or negative and then you want
to measure metrics like conversion rates
and click-through rates so that goes
back to putting a plan in place figure
out what your metrics are and then when
you're posting on a particular platform
you want to be able to lean on those
metrics to make sure you're achieving
your goals so you want to have those
metrics in place beforehand and then you
want to be able to use those metrics
moving forward as you post the whole
idea is if you're measuring what you
post you're obviously going to want to
lean more towards what's working versus
what's not working in a world where
a lot of competing different products
satisfy the same requirement you have a
lot of advertisers who want you to try
their product and then you have other
advertisers who want you to try their
product try my product try my product
try my product try no try my product my
product's the best no no no no my
product's the best try my product well i
want you to forget all that and try my
product forget about those other
advertisers try my product well there's
only one way you can prove your product
is better than the rest and that's with
powerful advertising and one of the best
ways to advertise on the internet is via
social media and through the largest
social media platform in the world and
that's facebook so today we're going to
talk about facebook ads tutorial and i'm
excited to teach this class my name is
rob sanders i'm with simply learn and
today we are going to talk about all the
different ads that facebook has to offer
so introduced back in 2007
the facebook ads platform has grown
tremendously over the last few years
almost four billion dollars of revenue
in one year so what does that mean that
means there's a lot of advertisers why
is there a lot of advertisers because a
lot of people use facebook it's a
popular platform so not only is it
popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on facebook you have the
opportunity to
share your product and your brand with
users who you think are going to buy
your product or associate with your
brand and on facebook you can do that a
number of different ways specifically in
somebody's news feed and specifically
that person's news feed that again is
interested potentially interested in
your brand your product so there's a lot
of ways to advertise and a lot of
reasons why you want to advertise so i
just mentioned one of the reasons hey
it's an opportunity for you to reach out
to people who are targeted who are
specific to
your product and your brand so not only
that but you combine that target
audience with the amount of time that
people spend on facebook okay people
spend a lot of time on facebook in fact
not only do people spend a lot of time
on facebook there's a lot of people on
facebook in fact 2.27 billion in the
third quarter of 2018 and so when we say
spend a lot of time we mean going to
that facebook profile at least once a
day okay so a lot of eyeballs throughout
the day checking their news feed on
facebook facebook also enables you the
advertiser to find the perfect audience
and so that's the great combination a
lot of people on facebook and targeted
audience so it's a platform that allows
you to put your product in front of
people based on specific interests
specific demographics specific location
so you're really really putting your
product out in front of the right people
at the right time and so the other
positive and pro about facebook is it's
lesser spend greater reach what do we
mean by that well traditionally facebook
is a little bit cheaper than other
online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your your advertisement in
somebody's news feed it's going to add
value it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility if friends and
family members of a person on facebook
are associated with your brand so it has
the opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody who is on facebook
active on facebook and is your targeted
demographic and the great thing about
facebook is it also has other features
those are advertising features such as
retargeting so you could target people
who've already expressed an interest in
your services product but if they didn't
go through
the conversion process meaning they
didn't go all the way through and and
buy your product you can certainly reach
out to them again just like your
traditional retargeting options on say
google or some other advertising
platform facebook works the same way we
want to be able to reach out to people
who aren't fully committed at that point
in time but we can reach out to them at
another point in time and so facebook's
advertising platform allows us to do
that so it's a great feature that we
could take advantage of that we'll talk
about more throughout this session and
then it helps increase revenue sales and
leads and and that's primarily what most
advertisers are after you know more
revenue more sales more leads so
facebook allows us to educate our
audience again a targeted audience about
a specific product we have to offer so
the more our audience knows about our
product especially if their friends and
family members and colleagues are using
the product then the more likely they're
going to purchase so if you go back to
the other feature higher revenue less
spend this is the primary reason because
you have a chance to influence somebody
who's very targeted who's very active on
the platform and who may have
like-minded people in their life
associating with your brand and product
so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad in the
single image ad are just single image
advertisements that have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own facebook
feed if you look so in fact i'll just
jump over to my facebook feed right now
and if i go there what do i see i see a
single image ad here and it's from
shopify partners so become a shopify
partner at e-commerce to your list of
qualifications so shopify must be
you know a brand that is trying to woo
my business okay so they know that
somebody that i'm associated with or
maybe i fit their demographic so they're
targeting my news feed with a single
image ad so that's what a single image
ad looks like it's simply just one
single image with some description and
the great thing about this single image
if you haven't noticed is the pixels are
pretty large it's 1200 by 628 so it kind
of stands out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the newsfeed so again
if i go back to my newsfeed here you can
see it just really stands out within the
news feed so i can't miss it if i'm a
targeted part of their targeted audience
it's hard for me to
you know not see this ad interact in
some way especially again if i know
somebody in my network on facebook or
either that be a friend or family member
is associated with that product okay in
addition to the single image ads
facebook also has multi-product ads or
also known as carousel ads and so what
the carousel ads do is allow you in
carousel form allow you to rotate
different ads with different messaging
and different call to action and so here
you can see
simply learn has a example of a carousel
ad where they're showcasing their
different courses so this allows users
to view a range of all your different
products and services if you have
multiple products and services to offer
then the carousel ads would be a good
option for you so in addition to the
carousel ads and single image ads it
gets a little bit more sophisticated in
terms of technology where facebook
allows us to offer up video ads and so
video ads are
interactive it's a good way to really
showcase your product your brand your
service and the great thing about the
video ads is they can go from just a few
seconds all the way up to
you know two minutes or excuse me all
the way up to 120 minutes and so you can
really really put a lot of time and
effort into the video ads to really put
your brand out there and so the one
thing about video is it is interactive
most people engage with video and they
tend to get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other forms of ads so the
video ads are really a popular way for
you as an advertiser to put your brand
or product out there so you can put your
brand and product out there in not just
a few seconds but you know really tell a
nice complete story to get the
engagement to get the person to take the
action you want them to do so that's why
video ads have become very popular
because they tend to get more engagement
more interaction than your traditional
single image ad or say your carousel ad
so facebook also allows us to
advertise something called lead ads and
what lead ads allow us to do is obtain
user details okay so we can acquire or
get an email address or phone number
from somebody who's interested in our
product or service and that person
doesn't even have to leave facebook so
if you look here in the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead ad is
that it can sync up with any crm or most
of your popular crms i should say for
example salesforce is a good example of
a crm where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the form itself
the interaction stays right in facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery so it
allows you to really
put your best images out there with a
really strong call to action just like
you see here with the simply learn
example okay so they're showcasing you
know they're different classes and then
they have the get started today call to
action to really punctuate the slideshow
ad so what's interesting is you can
really gauge a person's interest by
throwing different products or images
out there you know you can really
immerse a user's experience here by
showing different different images and
then the last type of ad on facebook is
called the collection ad and so these
ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so
if you're an advertiser
who wants to advertise several products
at once then this could be a great
option for you the collection ad so here
you can see the simply learn example
here they're showing you know not only
you know some some good slide shows and
imagery with some good messaging below
that
so before we get into the steps for
creating an ad on facebook let's talk
about some of the important changes that
have happened on facebook recently in
light of data sharing so
really what facebook's done is they've
made an important change on how user
data is being used for advertising and
so
what facebook's done is they removed
something called a partner category and
that was an ad targeting program which
the targeting option was based on data
provided by a third-party partner so if
you're an advertiser you had a third
party partner that provided some
targeted options to you that was known
as a partner category and in summary
facebook has removed that program and so
now the only way you can gain user
information
is if they provide that voluntary like
the lead ad for example now you have to
get the data directly from the third
party now so you can't have that third
party give you that targeting option
anymore you can certainly again capture
the data yourself by relying on the
capture landing pages as an example or
the lead ads and you can certainly still
outsource your advertising to lead gen
agencies and media buying companies okay
but the partner category has more or
less
gone away
okay so now let's get into
how to create a facebook ad so what are
the steps so the first thing you'll have
to do is set up a campaign so
when you're setting up a campaign you
have to select
what kind of spending you want to do for
your advertisement and what you want to
achieve okay so you have to in other
words identify the goal okay so with
facebook you have two opportunities at
hand here you can jump into an auction
just like google what you're going to do
is your ads going to enter into an
auction and so this is where you can
decide how you want to spend your money
to achieve your goals by choosing an
appropriate bid strategy for the auction
so
in the auction you're competing with
other advertisers another option is you
could do reach and frequency and so with
reach and frequency you'll be able to
advertise to your brand's audience
with a fixed cost so
reach and frequency allows you as the
advertiser to better predict the
delivery cost and reach of your branding
campaigns so with auction you have more
choice you have flexibility of
scalability but not a lot of
predictability okay because again you're
going into an option and your auction is
going to be competing against other
advertisers so it's this option is
available to all advertisers and you can
have pricing that you can change during
the auction price process so
that's the
unpredictability part is the pricing so
pricing can fluctuate during the auction
because you have different advertisers
who are trying to achieve the most
prominence for their ad with reach and
frequency
you'll be able to plan and set up your
campaigns
and
actually set it up so it's more
predictable on how the delivery is going
to be done
with reach and frequency so
more predictability when reaching
frequency because you could set
everything up in your campaign okay so
again with the reach and frequency
you'll be able to advertise with a fixed
cost auction you're not necessarily
going with a fixed cost you're going
with more scalability flexibility on
cost that can change okay so once you
choose your objective for your
advertisement then you need to choose
the type of advertisement you want to do
and it's based on your objectives so
what's your objective is it's awareness
to drive awareness is it to
drive consideration or is it to
drive a conversion so these are the
three objectives uh available to you for
your advertising you want to choose one
of those objectives so let's take a look
at each of these objectives available to
you okay so let's start out with
awareness so awareness can help with
creating an interest for your product or
or your service so when we say awareness
we're thinking maybe brand awareness or
product awareness to get out there in
front of people okay so with
consideration it's a little bit
different than awareness but not so
different in that we're really aiming to
get people
to think more about our product and
service and
have them take the next step so with
awareness you're introducing your
product and service with consideration
you're getting people to take the next
step and start looking for information
about the product or service you're
advertising and then conversion is kind
of that final step if you're really
after conversion you really
want that person to make the decision
okay so they're either going to buy
or use your product or service okay and
so that's the conversion objective so
you have to choose one of these three
objectives here is it going to be
awareness is it going to be
consideration or is it going to be
conversion and so let's go back to
awareness okay so if we look at
awareness under awareness we have brand
awareness and we have reach okay so we
look at brand awareness really what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
increase awareness about our brand or
the product in our brand so
these types of objectives i mean meaning
awareness don't really emphasize
interaction okay you're not really
trying to get somebody to purchase or or
buy something or opt in to a newsletter
really your goal as an advertiser with
brand awareness is to get your product
out there so people are aware that it
exists okay let alone forget about
buying it or opting into a newsletter
you really your goal with awareness
and brand awareness is to get people to
see that you're existing your product
exists your service exists it's
available and really the aim is to
create high brand recall
amongst users rather than focusing on
generating revenue so when we say you
know high brand recall what we mean is
hey if your brand is out there and you
are
really pushing it out there amongst a
large targeted demographic audience then
the next time that audience sees your
brand they're going to be able to
associate with it it's not going to be
foreign to them or the first time
they've ever seen it you really want
them to recall hey i know that brand
i've seen that brand before okay that's
kind of the reaction you want to get
from a brand awareness hey that's a cool
looking logo or man that product looked
interesting now i'm going to take the
next step so that's what brand awareness
really needs to do it needs to create
that recall for that for your audience
okay so
let's take a look now at reach so with
reach reach ensures that
our advertisement is seen by the maximum
number of people within our target
audience and budget so with reach we're
really trying to reach or get our ad out
there to as many people as possible
given who we're trying to target and
given the amount of money we have to
spend so it helps to target a smaller
audience to visit your website watch
your video or even convert on your
website okay so that's with reach we're
just really trying to get it out there
okay so let's move on to
consideration so we talked about
awareness we talked about brand
awareness and reach
with consideration
we have you know people who are willing
to take that next step okay so if we're
targeting a specific demographic and
we're looking at consideration we really
want them to do something with our ad we
don't want them just recall it or see it
for the first time we want them to take
that next step and so with consideration
we have traffic so if we have an ad you
know the least we want somebody to do
who's seen our brand before is at least
click on our ad okay so we want people
to
you know click on our ad
and go to our website really that's on a
goal of consideration is hey i know that
brand i've seen that brand before let me
click on this and see what they have to
offer so this might involve them
listening to a podcast or reading an
article or being introduced to an app so
really you're setting the stage for
further down the funnel by
further introducing them to something
that's on your website so you really
want them to take that next baby step
the next baby step is clicking on the ad
go into your site and further educating
themselves about your particular product
or service so facebook shows these
advertisements to people within your
target audience based on their past
behavior okay so that's a great thing
about facebook it's you can really
really get targeted here with your
audience okay so engagement so we talk
about traffic we're going to talk about
engagement so these types of ads are
useful when we want users to engage more
with our ad for example we can you know
really have an advertisement or post
that will allow people to like it they
can respond or even take advantage of an
offer so that's what we mean by
engagement we really want people to
react positively within facebook about
our ad or our post okay so it can help
with building engagement an engagement
audience for your facebook page that can
be used for future advertising campaigns
so
we're really getting people to
take that next step and what's that next
step if they don't go to our website
they can like what we have to say and
then we can have app installs so that's
another option to us for consideration
so app installs are great if we want to
send users to an app store for example
so they can download our app so if we're
really really pushing an app that we
just developed then an app installed
could be a good opportunity under
consideration to allow that user to take
the next step
and download your app so that that at a
later stage they can go and interact
with the app we have video views so
video views are are good advertisements
when you're promoting your product or
service and you really want a high
number of views so remember early on we
were talking about the types of ads
available on facebook we talked about
video views how they get 10 to 30
percent more
engagement well that's really what we
want videos to do under consideration we
really want people to understand what
we're trying to do and really engage
with our product and so they could turn
around and like it they could turn
around and um push it out to their
friends so video you we know is high
engaging with an audience and so having
a video allows you to really allow that
video to potentially go viral okay so
video views help users engage and
enables the creation of an audience
which can be used for future
advertisements okay so highly engageable
you know interactive allows people to
you know really really take that next
step with your product or service by
really getting to know what you're all
about okay then we have lead generation
so lead generation is interesting
because remember those leads that we
mentioned in the when we're talking
about the type of ads that facebook has
to offer well lead ads or you know if
you have a lead generation type ad
really what you could do is you can just
collect the information so really
somebody's interested in your product or
service right away then you can generate
a lead ad and allow them to say hey you
know what i'm interested i'm going to
sign up for your newsletter or yes i'm
interested in your product or your
future any future giveaway or promotion
you have to offer here here's my email
address here's my name here's my phone
number so lead ads are great for
consideration because somebody knows
your ad they've likely engaged with you
they like what you have to say and
they're willing to take that next step
and you can integrate your lead ads with
third-party apps that's tied to your crm
so for example salesforce lead ads can
sync up right with salesforce and then
you can then follow up with that user at
a later point so that's consideration so
we have a lot of good options available
to us under consideration you know we
could drive traffic
video views app installs just regular
engagement you know and then we got
legion so we got a lot of opportunities
for consideration if you're really
trying to target people who are already
familiar with your brand or product or
service and then last but certainly not
least we have messaging so with messages
you know these ads aim to convert a
user's interest in a product to a
successful sale or conversion so it
targets people who are more likely to
respond through messenger so facebook
messenger is a service that is
integrated nicely in with facebook and
so with facebook messenger you know you
can communicate with that person
directly just through messenger okay so
it could be a chat bot or it can be a
rep who can act as customer support or
provide more information about the
product or service so you can use
messenger to your advantage you can talk
right away to somebody who is really
interested in considering your product
or service so this is kind of the
capstone of consideration because it
takes into account one of facebook's
most popular features which is messenger
and allows you as an advertiser to use
that feature to engage with your
targeted audience directly let's turn
our attention to the last objective
which is conversion so under conversions
we have conversions product catalog
sales and store visits so for
conversions really this is the end of
the funnel this is really the part of
the funnel where we want people to take
action so
ads related to the objective of
conversions really aims to increase you
know whatever the goal is of your
website so if it means signups or
registrations for your services or sales
or downloads or any desired action on
your website then that's the conversion
okay so that's what we're aiming to
achieve when we are tying our ads to
conversions okay so you have conversions
and you have your pure product product
catalog sales so for product catalog
sales these could be ads to help promote
your ecommerce store or other products
in your store portfolio you know so
think of amazon think about all the
products they have on their website you
know they are probably likely going to
choose you know product catalog sales
because it really will help really push
traffic to the store and really get
somebody to convert either in a for a
particular product or get them to look
at other product categories and buy
something there so
really really product catalog sales are
really great for future campaigns when
you're really looking for sales and then
we have store visits and so store visits
really help direct traffic to your
location and really helps deliver ads
based on your users current location
okay so if we really want to get
somebody to the store if you have a
brick and mortar store for example and
then you can use store visits as your
objective under conversions to really
drive traffic to that location so that's
what store visits are we really want
people to you know take that next step
get to your store and check out your
store and purchase so that's what store
visits are under the conversions
objective so within each of these
advertisement objectives we can create
split tests also known as a b testing
and the reason why we call it a b
testing because what you're doing is
you're testing one variable from the
other so really you have two
advertisements that really are the same
except the only difference is there's
one thing that's altered from the other
so in this example we have a
with one promotion and then we have b
which is the same audience same
everything except a different promotion
so you're really changing one variable
when you do a split test and so that's
available to facebook just like any
other type of advertising let's say you
do you know search advertising on google
split testing's available let's say you
do email marketing split testing is
available with subject clients
facebook's no different it allows split
testing or allows you to use two
versions of the same ad i'm able to
change one of those parameters so you
can see really what ads performs best
that's the whole idea behind a split
test okay so if it's the original sales
sale of 25 off then hey so be it you
know it works because you tested it
against another variation and then the
great thing about testing it never ends
so if 25 off works over say 2 000
off then you try something else to see
if that will increase sales that's the
whole idea behind testing is you only
want you always want to see what works
okay so really what it comes down to is
it can be really it could be a
promotional offer or it could be
something as simple as changing the call
to action you know a different color on
the call to action it could be anything
you want to test as long as you're able
to you know figure out what works and
then apply what works so you can
continue to improve your advertising
that's really the whole idea behind a b
testing okay so it really is identifying
an element you want to test and then
really once you identify that element
and you test it and you know it wins
then you can move on other things to
figure out what else works so if you
tested the promotion then go on to the
cta so
you could test things like
colors and call to actions and imaging
and messaging and
positioning and you could play around
with your target audience and test a
segment of a target on ends against
another so
there's lots of things you could test
when you a b test the most important
thing to note though when you a b test
is you always want to keep in mind what
metric you want to measure the test up
against so some of the metrics you could
use are click-through rate which is ctr
cost per click cpc you can use
conversion rate also known as cr or just
clicks the whole idea is when you do a
test and you're testing a promotional
offer you're testing even the call to
action you need to measure that up
against a metric so that metric is
what's going to determine the winner and
so
it doesn't have to be overly complicated
it can be as simple as testing you know
one call to action against another and
determining which one gets more clicks
and if one gets more clicks than the
other then hey you know you have a
winner okay let's go through the steps
of creating a new campaign on facebook
using facebook's ads manager so you're
gonna log into facebook.com
ads manager and you're just going to
click on the create new campaign button
and when you do that you're going to see
a screen that looks just like this and
you're going to go through a series of
steps so as we presented earlier the
first step is always choosing your
objective so we have awareness
consideration and conversion so recall
that awareness was getting your brand
out there to people who never seen your
brand or product or service before so
it's a matter of trying to reach as many
people as you can to get your brand out
there and so you have brand awareness or
you have reach remember one is
controlled when it's uncontrolled okay
so reach is a little bit more control
because you can set your budget okay and
you can control your budget a little bit
better so brand awareness is just
getting it out there having facebook
plop it in front of the ad in front of
as many people as possible uh with reach
you are trying to maximize how many
people you show your ad to but it is a
little bit more controlled against the
budget okay either way choosing
awareness is going to set the objective
of trying to maximize your exposure for
your brand your product or your service
okay if somebody has already seen your
brand or somebody's already familiar
with your product or your services then
you may want to choose the objective of
consideration and so these are people
who again are already familiar who you
want to take that next step remember
facebook is an environment where you're
targeting a specific audience so you're
targeting people you know have likely
seen your brand product or service so
you want to take that next step that's
what you want them to do okay so here
under consideration we have traffic
engagement app installs video views lead
gen or messages all of these choices are
getting somebody to do something for you
for example app installs you want them
to install your app or engagement you
want them to like or share your post
video views watching your video or
messaging you want them to interact with
you via facebook's messenger
uh feature so all of these are
interactions of some sort where
somebody's taking that next step they've
seen your brand they're interested but
you they're not ready quite ready to
purchase yet okay so that's what
consideration is then you have
conversion this is people in the funnel
who you know or think you know want to
convert and when i say think you know
meaning you know you're really targeting
people who you've targeted before
who
maybe has purchased from you before or
is exactly the type of audience you're
looking to purchase okay so you have
conversions you have catalog sales and
you have store traffic meaning driving
foot traffic to a store okay so these
are people further down the funnel who
you don't necessarily want to take a
smaller action like just share your
facebook post or provide their email
address and name okay so you want them
to purchase so these are three marketing
objectives you're going to choose from
okay so we're just gonna choose
conversions for the sake of this example
and then when we go to choose
conversions remember we can create a a b
split test okay so that's a choice you
should always choose because you always
want to be testing something okay in
this case we might want to test the ad
we might want to test say the call to
action because we're looking for
conversions so it could be as simple as
having one ad with a buy more and the
other way that says hey check out our
website so you have that option to a b
split test and then you have budget
optimization which basically allows you
to
set your budget evenly across your
different ads okay and so what
facebook's going to do is basically make
sure that the best performing ad is
going to be seen more often so that's
budget optimization you're maximizing
your budget towards an ad or ads
that
you want to be able to have more control
over in terms of what's working and
what's not working versus not selecting
this option your ads are just going to
randomly show and there's not going to
be any necessary control over how much
spend each ad gets so that's the first
step in creating your campaign it's
always choosing your objective with a
few options built in
so the next step in the process
is ad set
okay and as you can see here before you
even get to ad set what
facebook is prompting us to do is look
at basically how the a b test is going
to work so
here they're explaining how an a b split
test works okay so
basically what an a b split test does is
serve up 50 50. the original versus a
variation of the original okay so that's
more or less how an a b split test works
and so facebook is doing us some good by
showing us this messaging okay because
that's what we chose now
notice we chose conversions objective
okay so what we're going to be required
to do is put a conversion pixel on our
website so that facebook can actually
track conversions and so what we want
people to do is
purchase and so what we need to do then
is
add a facebook pixel to our website so
that facebook can actually track how
many people purchase from your campaign
so this is very important and so if
you're driving traffic to your website
and you want them to convert then you
need to make sure all the tracking's in
place
so the next step in setting up your ads
is setting up an offer so if you have an
offer that you want to provide go ahead
and select
on because the default is set to off
okay what you could do is you can
associate it with
your particular
company page
on facebook and then you're gonna create
your offer so i'm gonna put my offer
title i'm gonna put a little bit more
details in there i can put an end date
when the offer expires in a specific
time so
based on what you put this is what
people is going to see with the ad and
here you have the redemption section
where you can have people redeem the
offer online or online and in store so
if it's online you need to provide
facebook with the url
where people can go and redeem that that
promotion that offer and then you have a
chance an opportunity to add a
particular code so you don't necessarily
have to have a code with your offer it
could be a one-time code or it can be a
unique code okay or unique codes okay
and then you have an advanced option
here and this advanced option is pretty
important because if you're
setting up an offer and you only want a
specific number of people to see that
offer then and you don't want them to
share that offer then what you could do
is hide the share option so that way
people won't be able to share the
promotion with friends or family or
whatnot now they could still copy and
paste the link of the offer but they
won't be able to easily do it with the
share option
and here you can put some terms and
conditions
so that's the offer okay and it's pretty
intuitive in the wizard
my recommendation is you should always
put out an offer to get people to
you know again your objective is to get
people to convert so an offer always
helps incentivize conversions
okay here we have our variable because
we're testing we're split testing okay
so
here we're choosing what we want to
split test if we choose creative
basically what we're doing is we're
telling facebook we want to test are
creative or at and so now what we're
going to do is we're going to select the
audience and so we can choose a custom
audience a look-alike or all so here you
can see we have a look alike and a
lookalike basically is basically what
facebook does is they're trying to
find people who are very similar to your
customers okay so that's who you want to
target people who look like your
customers on facebook okay so you could
choose a look-alike audience you could
choose a custom audience if you already
have one
so we're going to create a new custom
audience here
and
basically what we want them to do is
website traffic
and we're just going to call it website
traffic and basically it's going to be
all website visitors
okay so we're going to create this
audience here
so we've done that and basically now
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to tell facebook okay if our audience is
all website visitors where are those
visitors going to come from so we want
to choose a location so it could be
everyone in a particular location
everyone who lives in a particular
location or recently in the location or
traveling in a location okay so here you
can see we have it set to united states
but we can always change that so you can
really pick and choose areas or cities
and even exclude areas
you can even upload locations in bulk so
if you have a specific set of locations
you can upload that after you choose
your location you're then going to
choose your age so
here you have
if you look all the way down to 13 years
of age and then your range goes all the
way up to 65 years of age
then we have our gender we can choose
both men and women or just men and just
women and then we can target a specific
language if we want to target spanish
people or people who speak spanish then
we can choose spanish notice we can add
multiple languages
okay so if we want to do some specific
targeting for example we can do interest
or specific behavior so if i click
suggestions then for example facebook's
gonna offer us up some suggestions so if
we want to target people who have an
interest in foreign language or charity
and causes or mindfulness or it could be
specific job titles okay so we can get
really detailed with our targeting we
also have connections
so who do we want to target so are these
people who like our page who are friends
of people who like our page we can also
exclude people who like our pitch okay
so remember your advertising is tied to
a facebook page however you could still
drive that traffic to your website but
what facebook does is once you connect
your ad or your campaign to a facebook
page then they have an idea of the
profile then they have an idea of what
type of community you have on facebook
okay so that really helps them offer you
more detailed targeting in the form of
connections okay so when we're done we
could save the audience
so i'm just gonna name it uh
english and spanish click save okay now
i have my audience saved and the
important thing here is that this
audience is saved we can use it at a
later date or if we're setting up a new
campaign we can pull from the same
audience under use a saved audience
so if i just type in english in spanish
you'll see my audience here okay and we
can always edit it if we need to
okay so next is the placements section
so here placements is where we want to
show our ads okay so we want to be able
to place our ads in the proper placement
and so what facebook does is they
actually recommend you do an auto
placement and so facebook will based on
your audience show your ad in different
spots or different placements throughout
facebook
based on the people you're trying to
target the audience okay so in this case
we're targeting both spanish and english
okay and we're targeting 13 to 65 year
olds who live in the united states and
so what facebook's going to do then
because we have automatic placement set
up is they're going to be able to place
our ads based on our target audience so
this is an option i always recommend you
do and facebook recommends as well if
you're specific about where you want
your ad to be placed then you can just
select edit placements and notice when
you select edit placements here you have
different options not only on facebook
but on instagram as well okay and
facebook's network and in facebook
messenger so you have all these
different options available to you if
you really want your
your ad placed in a specific position so
here if i just scroll over here i can
see what it looks like in a feed in
stream video
i can scroll down to instagram that's
what it looks like in a feed on
instagram okay uh you have instagram
stories if i want to go and advertise on
facebook messenger then i have some
options here
in
messenger inbox or sponsored messages
okay so you have a lot of options
available under edit placements meaning
picking your placement specifically but
again i recommend as does facebook just
go with the recommended placements for
now unless you're really clear and you
really understand how
facebook works and where these
placements are actually going to be but
remember if you choose edit placements
and place it in a specific position
let's just say on messenger inbox
remember your audience may not be there
so going with the automatic placements
you know is a way for facebook to help
you get your ad in front of the right
audience
here the next section delivery
optimization okay how much of our ads
are optimized and delivered so
remember we chose conversions here so
we're going to optimize our ads for
conversions
so what facebook's going to do is take
into account each conversion that each
ad is getting and they're going to show
that ad that's getting more conversions
more often than the ads that aren't
getting as many conversions
okay so they're optimizing the ad
delivery based on
how many conversions each ad gets and
there's an option in here as well so
you can put a cost control in place so
you have an average cost per purchase
okay so facebook will aim to get the
most purchases and spend your entire
budget okay if you put in an average
cost per purchase so for example if i'm
selling t-shirts i may not want my
average cost per purchase to be
twenty dollars because i'm not going to
make any money so i'm probably going to
choose maybe two three four even as high
as five dollars on a cost per purchase
because i want to make sure i'm not
spending a lot of money just to get a
purchase so you have that option
available to you to put in as a cost
control
and here we have a conversion window
and so what this conversion window is
going to do is
you know help
facebook
optimize your ads a little bit better
based on the number of conversions that
happen in this window
okay so you have some other options in
here you want to do standard delivery
ad scheduling you can run your ads on a
schedule or you can run them all the
time
okay
and then moving down to the next option
in our ad set
is we have split test and
split test budget and schedule so
we have the opportunity to put a budget
in place for ads okay and we can
schedule the
the a b test to start running
immediately if we want to or we can have
the a b test run at a specific date and
we can have it run for a specific period
of time so this goes all the way back to
the first option where we chose a b
split test on step one so we have a
series of options available to us for
the split test
okay once we have all our options in
place okay we're gonna click continue
and then the final step is actually
setting up our ads okay so
what we're gonna do is we're going to
name our ad in this case add a okay it's
going to be tied to a facebook page
it's going to be tied to an instagram
account
and then we can choose the format of our
ad so remember we have a lot of
different options available to us on
facebook we have the carousel which
allows us to have
multiple images scrolling horizontally
we can have that single image ad we can
have a video we can have a collection of
images
so we have a lot of options available to
us
and then what we could do is we can link
up our ad to a specific page okay now
before we do that we want to be able to
upload our images okay so we're going to
manually choose images videos and links
okay
and then we're going to add some text to
support that image
okay and so when we add text in for our
ad we have the option of setting up a
headline
actually it's not an option it's
actually mandatory the description is
actually optional okay but my
recommendation is you want to add a
headline that's going to grab attention
and you want to add a description to
support that headline so i always
recommend
putting in a description and then once
you do that you're going to add your
destination url
and then you're going to be able to
preview your ad okay so
if we have an image here okay we can
just say hey this
come
check out
our new product and so as i add
this information i'll be able to view it
on the right side okay so it looks like
facebook at this point is not able to
view the image but
normally you're able to see a preview in
this case it's on the mobile news feed
so if we drop down we can see desktop
right column okay so we need to really
choose our images so we're going to
change an image here let's see if i can
choose another image
okay i'm going to choose an image here
and so now i can see the image
now i could see the headline um and and
then i could see what it looks like just
by changing the placement okay so if i
want to choose facebook stories whoops
that's not available
if i go to
for example instant articles okay
here i can see
what my ad looks like on instant
articles
so it wasn't available on certain
placements because of the type of ad we
chose but the point being when you set
up your ad and you choose your image and
you write your headline and put your
destination url in then you'll be able
to preview it on certain placements
depending on what type of ads you chose
okay once you're once you're set up and
remember we're setting up a b testing so
that was add one now we want to test the
second ad or the variation and so
basically what we want to do is choose
the same type of format then what we
want to do is pick a variation what is
that variation going to be it could be
maybe just a different headline okay or
it could be a different url
you need to decide what it is you're
going to test
once you decide what you test you're
going to add that to variation b
once you add that the variation b then
you have both ads set up
once you confirm facebook is going to
confirm for you whether the ads meet
their criteria okay and if it doesn't in
this case you could see we have some
errors
then we need to go back and fix them so
i'm going to go back and choose single
image ad
okay so now
i can just choose my one image
so i can browse a library of images i
already have
now here's my single image ad
i'm going to add some text in there
a website url
a headline
remember you want it to be catchy okay
you can change the call to action here
okay you can add multiple languages so
you have a lot of options depending on
the type of format you choose
so remember we chose a b test so
we're going to
set up both ads add a and add b okay and
when we do that again we can have
facebook review it once they review it
we they can confirm this you can see we
still have some errors on add a so let's
go ahead and fix that i'm going to
choose single image because that's what
add b is i'm going to browse my library
maybe i'll just test a different image
i'm going to click continue
and so basically keep everything the
same what i'll test is maybe the image
so you have to go into an a b test
knowing what it is you want to test
ahead of time okay once you do that
you're going to go ahead and continue to
add b and then once you do that um here
let's go ahead and fix this error here
um
the link field so let's just go ahead
and put a link in there
continue to add b
once i confirm then i have two ads
ready to go on specific placements or
excuse me automatic placements in this
option is that's the option we chose and
basically the ads are set to
optimization against conversions we have
a set budget and we're going to be able
to then once our ads go live is look at
some reports to see how they're
performing so that's the steps in
setting up a campaign
on facebook you're choosing your
objective okay then you're setting up
your ad set okay and then once you set
up your ad set with your target audience
then you're actually going through the
motions in this case we set up two ads
because we chose a b testing okay
and if you didn't choose a b testing
then you would just choose to set up the
first ad and once you do that you
confirm and voila your campaign is set
up based on these three steps choose
from over 300 in-demand skills and get
access to 1 000 plus hours of video
content for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more okay so let's
uh review with some do's and don'ts of
facebook so we mentioned the types of ad
that facebook has we mentioned how to
set up a facebook ad itself and choosing
the right
objectives and so some of the dues
involved are what just what i mentioned
we always want to do a b testing on our
ads whether that's again just changing
out the color we're changing out an
image you always want to do a b testing
because facebook has you know carousel
ads and because they have you know ads
that can rotate and you can use even
video with your ads you always want to
take advantage of what's given to you
and so facebook allows you to do it do
it so if you have the opportunity to
have video ad then use the video ad
highly recommend it remember video ads
have higher engagement so definite do is
use engaging videos and imagery so you
don't necessarily have to use a static
ad or image ad you can use the carousel
for example or the presentation mode
where you can show multiple images to
really showcase your product and service
so with all the advertising that you do
you always want to align your messaging
so
use a message that will stay with the
audience okay so use something that's
going to be able to trigger remember it
depends on the funnel and where you're
at so if your awareness or consideration
or conversion that has to align with
your messaging so if you're you know
targeting ads you know when you want
people to convert then your message is
going to be as such you're going to talk
to people as if you want them to convert
as if they're ready to convert and you
want to keep your message consistent and
simple so remember the ads are available
to you and you have so many different
features available to you within those
ads but that doesn't mean you gotta
convolute it with messaging so keep your
message
consistent and simple if it's brand
awareness you know definitely keep your
message simple so that people can
understand exactly what it is your
product or service is all about then you
want to alter your reach so that the ads
are shown to the appropriate audience
okay so you always want to keep in mind
who you're trying to target okay so you
don't want to target somebody who's not
in your demographic so alter your reach
so that the ads are shown to the
appropriate audience remember you have
you know reach available to you and
reach allows you to really pick and
choose exactly who you're targeting to
and how often remember you want to reach
as many people as possible but you don't
want to reach the wrong people some of
the don'ts to stay some things you want
to stay away from is you don't want to
put all your money on one campaign so
you want to separate out your budget
allocate your budget across different
campaigns and i would even take that a
step further and you know put different
types of ads in different campaigns just
to see what works so again it depends on
where you're at in the funnel if it's
just brand awareness okay maybe create a
campaign for that if it's consideration
create a campaign for that because in
consideration you might have lead ads in
there say with the awareness campaign
you may just have a single image ad okay
just to introduce your product to
somebody with a simple message so
you want to
you know definitely think about how you
want to separate out your campaigns but
don't be afraid to separate your
campaigns by the type of ads
don't put too much information in the
ads remember keep it consistent and keep
it simple that's the best thing i can
say and remember a lot of these ads are
image based so images tell a thousand
words they tell a thousand stories a
video will do the job if you have to say
too much so if you're saying too much
think about a video but if you're using
an image let the image tell the story
okay don't forget to proofread your ads
i can't stress that enough remember if
you're an awareness campaign this is the
first time somebody's seen your product
or service so you definitely want to get
the messaging not only correct meaning
consistent and simple but grammatically
correct you don't want to be so active
on your facebook page so you know when i
say being don't be so active on your
facebook page really it depends on where
you're at you're trying to introduce a
product or service so that doesn't mean
that you need to go out and tell
everybody to start buying your product
remember these people may not even know
who you are what product and service you
offer so you want to be able to approach
your audience on your facebook page in a
manner which is suitable for your
audience and then have an image that
doesn't correspond to the product being
advertised so you you want to be able to
you know have an image that does
correspond so if you're targeting a
specific audience with a specific
product then make sure the image on your
facebook page aligns with that okay
don't be inconsistent don't confuse the
audience you know be consistent with
your imagery as well as your messaging
okay so those are some of the don'ts you
things you want to stay away from when
you're advertising today we're going to
cover a number of tips to help you gain
a better advantage on advertising on
facebook so let's get right to it with
tip number one and with tip number one
not all advertisements need to sell
something so remember you have different
objectives on facebook you can advertise
an event you can promote a customer
story you can send traffic to your
website or you can get them to download
an app so it all goes back to your
objective so if we go to facebook and i
want to create an ad remember my first
option is to create an objective so you
have awareness you have consideration
you have conversion so depending on what
you want somebody to do that's the
objective you're going to choose so just
keep that in mind when you're setting up
your campaign on facebook you need to
align your objective with what you want
people to do so tip number two we want
to use facebook messenger for
advertising so facebook messenger is a
feature that can be used with
advertising on facebook and it's a good
tool it's a good practice because it
allows you to as the advertiser to
commute with individuals directly so
it's a feature that you should take
advantage of because it allows you to
quickly engage with your target audience
so that's the beauty of leveraging
facebook messenger with your advertising
the communication tools available and
for you to engage with your target
audience so it's great for
not only interacting but taking care of
any other objections that they have as
an as an audience or prospective client
so you can answer any concerns they have
right away so it's a lot more personal
and interactive than other forms of
advertising because you're directly
communicating with your audience tip
three use video advertisements i can't
stress this enough video is very
engaging in fact it's not only engaging
but it's very easy to use so if we go to
facebook really facebook is telling us
for video all we need to do is have
basically a phone handy and an facebook
all you need is a mobile camera so with
facebook videos it's really very easy to
create you just gotta be creative that's
really the key to videos you know
they're gonna be engaging to the end
user say something do something that's
gonna really grab their attention and
get them to do what you want them to do
so these are just some of the examples
you can see on facebook and you can see
how creative advertisers are getting you
know clear call to action great video or
great imagery good promotional use so
there's a lot you can do with video and
really make it interactive so i can't
stress video enough as an option for
facebook it really is one of the better
features of facebook advertising and
really very limited use of resources all
you need is that web camera an app and
the ability to upload that video that's
really it for video advertisements so
keep in mind and the reason why i'm
harping on those video ads is they tend
to outperform your traditional
facebook image ads and other formats
like the carousel or the presentation
mode so there's other types of formats
on facebook video tends to give it that
extra edge because it's very interactive
and in the form of interactivity comes
engagement so in this example you know
people are going to react they're going
to comment they're going to share the
video and that's what you want as an
advertiser you want to grab as much
reach as possible towards your target
audience and so video will help you do
that it'll help you not only engage with
the person but allow that video to be
shared and expand your reach towards
your target audience so remember video
can range from a few seconds all the way
up to 120 minutes so you're really gonna
get more views regardless of how long
the video is because it's just gonna be
so interactive so just keep that in mind
it doesn't have to be full on 120
minutes it could be you know anywhere
from one to five minutes you know to me
that's probably a good range but just
know that you have that lead way if you
wanted to so remember video ads always
perform better than single image ads or
other type of image ad formats on
facebook and they also perform better
when they have subtitle support so just
keep that in mind as well because you
may have you know individuals watching
the video from you know different
countries speaking different languages
say tip four when you're placing your
advertisement where you place your
advertising will play an important role
in deciding how many people come across
it so facebook offers a number of
different options to choose from so
remember you got the news feed you got
instant articles right column you've got
suggested videos so you get a lot of
options at your disposal there's lots of
other options too so you can have
facebook actually automatically place
your ads or you can specifically tell
facebook where you want to place your
ads and that's all part of the facebook
setup so if we go to facebook and then
we go to create your campaign so if we
close ad sets here is where we're going
to be able to choose our placement if we
click on choose placement we'll be able
to
you know be able to allow facebook to
place it or we can edit the placement
specifically so just keep that in mind
you have a lot of different options here
again feeds and stuff articles in-stream
videos got rycom even have instagram so
you have a lot of options available to
you so my recommendation and facebook's
recommendation is always go with the
auto placement but you could
specifically choose your placement if
you want to when you're setting up your
campaign so start the advertising on the
news feed could be recommended the news
feed is where you're probably going to
get your most eyeballs most users spend
most of their time there and it has the
highest chance of grabbing their
attention so the newsfeed could be a
good place to start again you can have
it at auto placement and your ads may be
there as well or you can specifically
choose just the news feed or other
placements so tip four just be careful
where you place your ad it's really
important you want to place your ad
where you're going to get eyeballs so
tip 5 facebook ads also offer you the
option to advertise on instagram so you
have that option available to you as i
mentioned in tip 4 you have the option
to advertise the stories carousel ads
photo ads and video ads so again that's
all part of the ad setup when you go to
choose your placements here you got
instagram feed you get instagram stories
and again with both of those placements
on instagram you can work with several
different types of ads including that
carousel ad including that video ad so
just keep that in mind that instagram is
an option for you take advantage of it
there's a lot more eyeballs on instagram
these days and it plays off nicely with
what you're trying to do with facebook
so go ahead and give it a try okay so
let's take a quick break from the first
few tips we went over and let's take a
look at an ad so it's an ad break time
so let's take a look at this and this is
by new scientist and so what makes this
ad so great well there's been a lot of
shake up in the world today about fake
news you know what is fake news so new
scientist is actually playing off of
that they're mentioning hey fake news
not in our world so they're actually
playing off of that that term fake news
and so that's an attention grabber so i
think that's what makes this look so
good but this is a single image ad and
you can see here they're promoting this
ad with a promotion so try 12 weeks for
just 36 euros okay so they have a
promotion in there so and you notice
they the image of the you know the
magazine they're also displaying that
hey you can look at this digitally on a
laptop a tablet or a mobile phone so you
have other options as well so they show
you that in the image which is placed on
the right side of their messaging so for
me this is a good ad because of the
placement of the image the type of image
they're using the play on fake news and
the promotion that they're offering up
so this is really a good ad it's very
eye-catching and hopefully the
promotion's good enough to get you to
sign up okay so tip number six so tip
number six we want to continuously do a
b testing you want to always have this
option going for you you want to be able
to test variation a versus variation b
because you want to be able to find out
what works and what doesn't work with
your audience and on top of that it
helps you really put your best foot
forward by showing your best ad so by
doing a b testing you're getting
feedback from the audience and turning
that feedback into positive returns so
you're then turning your ad that does
work well in front of an audience and
you're going to continue to do that so a
b testing is always a good option so
remember when you're setting up your ad
in facebook go ahead and choose to have
your a b test set up and when you do
that you choose that option you're going
to be able to then go in and choose what
it is you want to test with that a and
then with add b so you're going to again
align your test with a facebook page
you're going to choose an ad format once
you choose your ad format then you're
going to be able to go ahead and you
know put your ad in there and then
you're going to choose your call to
action so the whole idea behind an a b
test is you want to be able to find what
it is you want to test is that going to
be the
call to action is it going to be the
messaging is it going to be the ad
format so there are lots of things you
can test with facebook on a b testing so
it's all part of the ad setup so things
you can change again are the color of
the elements imaging text the call to
action the position of the ad there's
lots of things you could test that's all
part of the facebook setup so the thing
is you want to continuously test that's
the key continuously test certain
elements of an ad so testing can be done
initially on broader elements and then
smaller finer details like statements in
your ad copy so my advice is when you're
actually setting this up on facebook you
know think ahead think what it is you
want to choose to test my advice is
maybe start out with a call to action so
if you're in facebook itself you know
you have an opportunity to test
different call to action try that that's
an easy way to test and then you know
when you test the call to action once
you find out what works and doesn't work
then you can move on to something more
sophisticated like maybe the image type
or maybe trying different types of
imagery or ad types like the carousel
versus single image so start small start
easy and then work your way up tip
number seven so we want to choose an
appropriate call to action in your
advertisements that will attract
potential customers so what do we mean
well you have different call to actions
available to you you want to choose one
that aligns with your ad so for example
the simply learn ad about hey learn how
seo works search engine optimization so
if you're trying to get somebody to you
know learn or take one of your courses
you're not asking them to actually shop
now you really want them to sign up so
that's the key we want them to sign up
so use a call to action that makes sense
tip number eight choose the right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean so for this you can
consider you know website visits
interest it all depends on your
objective okay what is it you want
people to do if it's you know customers
in the buying process then that's our
objectives to get conversions then we
want to move somebody over to a product
page and get them to purchase you know
if it's focusing on just website visits
then maybe it's the objective of
consideration maybe you just want to get
people to your website to learn more
about your product so that's the whole
idea behind you know choosing uh the
right you know objective uh because you
want to align the objective with your ad
okay so tip number nine create
look-alike audiences and i'd like
lookalike audience because what facebook
does is they create an audience that's
similar to the audience you're already
advertising to or customer base you
already have so in other words facebook
already has an idea of who your audience
is you can also you know provide them
with additional information like an
email list to give them a better sense
of who your audience is and then what
facebook does is they take that
information and they'll put your ad in
front of an audience that looks just
like the audience you already have
that's why they call it a look-alike
audience so it's a great feature by
facebook it really allows you to reach a
target audience an audience is very
similar to the audience you currently
have one example provide facebook with
an email list with that email list
they're going to be able to map that
email list and be able to identify an
audience that you could target so that's
the whole idea behind lookalike audience
it's a great feature by facebook
definitely recommend taking advantage of
that why because it will increase the
number of people who will find your
advertisement relevant remember you're
targeting people who are similar to your
actual audience to your the people who
are already connected with your brand or
already liking your page so if they're
similar to those people then the chances
of them engaging with you are going to
be greater so look alike audiences tend
to perform well because you're targeting
an audience that's very similar to your
actual audience tip number 10 so use the
golden point rule on your ad creator so
what do we mean by golden point rule
well let's take this ad here as an
example so what we want to do is we want
to divide the creative into nine equally
sized boxes so what we want to do is
draw two horizontal lines and two
vertical lines just like a tic tac toe
box and so ideally what we want to do is
place the main subject of your ad in the
cross sections of the drawn lines and so
what that does is encourages the user to
place their focus on those points the
lines are just simply there is a
guidance to help you position your
messaging so that's the golden point
rule really is we want to be able to
position our messaging accordingly so
time for another ad break so let's take
a look at another ad here on facebook
and this one's by blue apron and so of
all the tips we've talked about
this particular ad takes into account a
lot of them okay so this is again
they're using multiple images in this ad
here so again what they're doing
promotion they're offering up a 30 off
promotion here and what they're asking
you to do is sign up to get that 30 off
so you could see the call to action we
already mentioned that on one of our
tips the call to action matches the ad
so they're asking to sign up they're
using really good imagery here and
they're supporting that with
you know some good copy and text so this
is what makes this ad so good i mean who
doesn't like good looking food or tasty
food and healthy food okay so they're
definitely taking advantage of the
imagery with a promotion and with a good
call to action and so remember we want
to a b test so blue apron is likely
testing this ad so what they could do
with this is test different imagery or
they could test a different promotion so
there's a lot they can do here on the a
b testing side so
for me if i were to test this yeah i
would probably be testing the imagery
because we want to be able to see what
images get people to sign up
alternatively we can also test the offer
as well what offer is going to get
somebody to click on that sign up button
so ideally there's a lot to do here from
the a b test standpoint and the way they
structure this ad it makes it very easy
to test so that's what makes this ad
really good is shows good imagery has a
good promotion and aligns the cta tip
number 11 so we want to place the
product in the right hand of your
creative so the right side should
contain our product imagery so why is
that why because there's been a study
called the perceived product heaviness
and package evaluation and that states
that depending on where a product is
placed users would react differently to
it and so the study found that users
tend to react more positively when the
product is placed on the right side of
the ad creative so here you can see
countdown to black friday this is an
amazon related ad and you can see the
product is basically a letterbox which
is placed on the right side so it's a
black friday ad they didn't place the
image on the left side they placed on
the right side because people tend to
react positively when the product image
is on the right side so keep that in
mind when you're placing your imagery
try to place it on the right side tip
number 12 don't use images that have
more than 20
text okay so you want to use images that
are clean remember that blue apron image
we looked at and that was a very clean
image of food no text overlaying the
image so we want to try and stay away
from images that have text on the
overlay okay so there's no limit to how
much text you can add to your creative
but you know facebook and myself
recommend hey the lesser text you have
the more likely it is for your ad to
have its desired impact meaning
somebody's gonna click on that ad okay
so keep that in mind let the image do
the talking for you you don't
necessarily need to overwhelm the image
with words or messages tip number 13 so
we want to use an ad creative that's
attention grabbing and is relevant for
your business so again going back to
that blue apron ad hey who doesn't like
good looking food good looking healthy
food green food well switching gears
we're looking at a nike ad who doesn't
like a good looking shoe here this is a
good running shoe and nike is definitely
taking advantage of the opportunity to
place the shoe against a nice looking
background so here the image on the left
you got a nice mob looking color the
shoe on the right
on a nice red background to kind of
really play into the color of the shoe
and so that's attention grabbing so the
colors kind of match and go with one
another and it tends to grab your
attention so nike's doing a good job
here of just not showing an image of a
shoe really what they're doing is put
the shoe as the central focal point and
supporting that with additional color
and they're really putting the messaging
kind of as the background behind the
shoe so they're making it as
attention-grabbing as possible here so
nike's done a good job with this ad you
know me personally i'm not the biggest
nike fan when it comes to shoes but hey
this ad definitely grabbed my attention
because now i could see you know this
shoe is really popping to me we don't
want to use clip art in your ad creative
okay and don't use low resolution
pixelated images as well we want to use
high quality imagery so and use images
that are well lit you know natural
lighting always tends to work well as as
well so when you're doing a placement
for product whether that be food or shoe
you can see here in this plated example
they're putting it on the right image of
putting it in a natural environment on a
table on a plate with some paper next to
it you know and then you can see from
the one on the left it's of a person
holding a box with the image of plated
on it and so to me that's not stock
imagery or clip art you know that's an
actual person holding the product so
it's real life you want to make it as
real life as possible and as clear and
quality as possible so when you create
attention grabbing ads you show images
of people benefiting from your product
instead of just having the product
itself so that's always a good idea in
the case of coca-cola you know these
people are enjoying their bottle of
coca-cola well going back to the nike ad
you know they could have had a person
wearing that shoe or you know running
with that shoe that could have been an
alternative for them as well so the
whole idea is just make sure your ads
are attention getting and they grab your
attention and if you're going to use
people make sure the person's enjoying
it just like on the previous image the
person holding the box we could see
she's got a smile on her face and she is
enjoying holding that box so to me you
want to use people with the images to
the best of your ability and that means
use that person who's enjoying it so
that's really going to put the product
in the forefront okay tip 14 don't
hesitate to experiment with your
advertisements creative or its copy okay
so what do we mean by that really we
want to be refreshing our text we want
to be refreshing our images okay so
if you're going to place an ad on
facebook don't let that be the only ad
okay if you're using a single image ad
you know feel free to change out that
single image from time to time
especially if a lot of people have seen
that ad so
if you're using reach as your objective
and you're trying to reach as many
people as possible just keep in mind
that if that ad is reaching the same
people over and over again it's going to
get stale and you want to be able to
update that ad so feel free to change
out the imagery changing out the text is
just as easy okay so feel free to play
around with the text even if you're not
doing a b testing you can always change
out the text just to see hey if changing
out the text actually gets you better
engagement or meets your goals tip 15
plan your campaigns for the holiday
season okay so can't state this enough
you know towards you know october
november december there tends to be a
lot of holidays you know across multiple
religions okay so it's really the time
of year where people are in full ad mode
and audiences are in full watch mode so
advertisers are really pushing ads that
time of year especially christmas you
know and people are accepting of that
because they're used to it so you want
to be able to plan accordingly so if
you're doing your ads you can easily
engage with your audience if you're
aligning your ad with that time of year
so during christmas most people are in
the mood for shopping so it's a time of
year where you can really really really
take advantage of increasing your sales
increasing your conversions so you want
to plan accordingly and so if you're
planning you know months in advance you
don't have to do a full year but you
know for me if i'm thinking i'm going to
do a lot of advertising during the
holiday season i'm probably going to go
out maybe once summer ends probably
august beginning of september beginning
of september
seasons change a little i might start
thinking about the holiday season and
when you can plan appropriately you can
come out with really good ads you can
think about what you want to say and so
in this case you know target this
particular ad is really promoting black
friday so black friday is the day after
thanksgiving in the united states and so
here they're letting you know black
friday's here and there's deals to be
had so planning in advance gives you an
opportunity to really really tweak your
messaging and come up with some good
creative ideas so let's take another
break and let's look at another
good looking ad this example we're gonna
look at dell okay so dell i've seen
their ads all over facebook they do a
lot of different advertising types
between videos carousels and this is a
single image ad they're really trying to
do is get you over to the storefront so
you can buy one of these good looking
you know dell computers okay so
you know here again they're promoting
their latest computer the dell inspirion
3000 series all in one desktop so to
them anytime they create a new product
they're going to go ahead and put out a
new ad for that product and here they're
putting a little bit of a different
twist on it if you notice the ad itself
is just the image of the product there's
really no promotion here they're letting
the product image speak for itself
they're really showing you hey look how
good this computer looks you know this
is our new model and you know we gotta
shop now ctas if you're interested go
ahead and click on that shop now so
they're really putting the effort into
the image itself you know they're not
offering any promotion you know no
discounts you know what you see is what
you get with the image and you click on
it you're going to go right to their
storefront so dell does a good job of
really you know cranking out their new
products whenever they go to market so
tip 16 shorten the amount of time
between retargeting your audience so
target people have visited your website
within the span of a month or two weeks
so retargeting is reaching out to people
who you've already engaged with so if
somebody has seen your ad or somebody's
went to your website somebody's even
purchased from you before you have the
opportunity to reach back out to that
person so how often you reach out to
that person or how long between their
initial engagement and when you retarget
them really does depend on what it is
you're selling so if you're selling a
pair of shoes if you're nike then
chances are somebody's looking for a
pair of shoes it's not going to be a
long purchase window meaning they're not
going to wait two three months so
if i'm nike and somebody's seen my ad
i'm probably going to target that person
in a short period of time for
retargeting so it really depends on your
product but you don't want to wait too
long between the time they've been
initially engaged and the time you
retarget so it really depends on your
product you know again if you're selling
merchandise you know retail it's
probably going to be a smaller time
frame if you're dell computers you know
that's a bigger purchase somebody's
going to take their time so you know you
want to target people
you know for their dell computer
probably you know over a longer period
of time okay so just keep the product in
mind you don't want to wait too long you
don't want to keep it too short so you
want to find that nice balance of when
you could retarget someone okay tip
number 17 keep altering the hook of your
ad copy what do we mean by altering the
hook so here you can see a couple of
different options option one you know
we're talking about hey if you're
interested in getting some dmca
certification you know this is what you
need to do option two a little bit
different of a hook hey start your
journey to get your dmc ca certification
so you know just altering the way you're
trying to talk to somebody is really
what we're after here on tip number 17.
you have an ad especially the text
remember we always want to refresh that
copy but if you're testing it try
different hooks try different ways to
talk to people okay it always works well
when you can have different types of
messaging because people react to
different messaging so an effective
strategy would be to create multiple ads
with different hooks and see what
performs best so this is an option for a
b testing okay you have an option to add
messaging go ahead and talk one way in
one option and then you know tweak that
messaging tweak that hook a bit in
option b and see what resonates with
people so that's a good option for a b
testing is always you know look at the
way you're going to try and you know get
somebody to convert tip number 18 okay
respond to lead add responses as soon as
possible so remember one of your ad
formats is a lead ad okay so if you have
a lead ad basically what you're asking
somebody to do is add their name their
phone number and their email if you get
that information don't sit on it react
to it just like the messaging the
facebook messenger how it's almost
instantaneous think of the lead ads the
same way okay you have somebody who's
engaging with your ad by providing
information you don't want to sit on it
you want to respond as soon as possible
in fact you know when you do engage that
person let them know you're available on
facebook messenger so they can actually
then reach out to you via facebook
messenger just to expedite the
communication but when you get that
valuable information from the customer
you know respond as soon as possible
it's good customer service because the
longer you take to respond the less
likely the customer will want to
continue interacting with you so there's
no real good rule of thumb here except
for do it as soon as possible okay tip
number 19 add scarcity to your
advertisements so what do we mean by
that well in this example we could see
the top 100 registrations get free
access so by putting this into your ad
copy we're hoping your prospects are
more inclined to buy your product due to
that fear that they're not going to be
one of the first 100 registrations okay
so it allows you to really put some
sense of urgency
in the ad to get somebody to react so
that's what we mean by you know scarcity
okay so by doing so it could affect the
long-term credibility you know we don't
want to come across as fear-mongering by
any means but hey if your promotion is
the first 100 registrations get free
access then why not you know go ahead
and put it in there some other examples
could be you know only three days left
to register or
first 50 get 50 off or you know hurry
now there's only two days left so
there's other language you can put to
play around with the language but if you
only have
certain slots available or certain
amount of days left there's nothing
wrong with putting that in the ad copy
to get people to react and so that's the
whole idea behind you know the scarcity
is you want to be able to let people
know hey there's a limited edition going
on here if you're interested go ahead
and take advantage tip number 20 keep
track of your ad relevance scores so
your ads do get scored so the score
ranges from 1 to 10 okay so what that
score does is it's an indicator to
signify the quality and engagement
levels so you know if your score is
between 1 and 6 then the ad isn't
reaching the relevant audience and your
audience isn't reacting to it however if
your
relevance score is between seven and ten
then your ads are reaching the
appropriate audience and you're getting
a lot of interaction so keep an eye on
that you know the lower the number that
means hey we're not get our ads not
getting to the right audience and if
it's not getting to the right audience
our audience isn't gonna react to it so
it all starts with making sure you're
reaching your audience with your ad when
your ad is reaching your audience and
you're doing a b testing your audience
is gonna react to one of those two ads
so that's always going to help your
relevant score so keep an eye on that
relevant score okay so let's take
another break here and let's take a look
at an ad here by blue bottle coffee okay
so i'm a big coffee drinker myself i
frequent blue bottle in san francisco a
lot and so here this is a nice image a
nice close-up image of coffee and i
really like this notice there's really
no call to action here okay so they're
putting their website url the domain
bluebottlecoffee.com
they're saying hey we source great
coffees we roast them to perfection and
get them to you fresh so i can vouch for
that really putting their brand out
there okay so this is more of a brand
awareness type ad that's their objective
their objective is if you're going to
drink coffee at some other location or
with some other brand hey take a look at
ours you know we got good coffee too we
roast them pretty good and and we make
sure that you get them fresh that's what
they're trying to do they're trying to
introduce their brand to you so this is
a good example of a brand awareness ad
single image ad they're definitely
making use of the added the image itself
you know with a nice close-up shot of
that roasted coffee so that's what makes
this ad so special brand awareness you
know the image is telling us hey this
coffee looks pretty pretty good it looks
nice and roasted it looks pretty fresh
and
maybe i'll give blue bottle coffee a try
so that's why they're putting their
domain there okay so it's a good brand
awareness ad and the hope is to convert
some people over to their brand okay so
tip number 21 include emojis in your ad
copy okay so emojis we know are popular
you use them in text use them on social
media
i mean there's hundreds of emojis
nowadays that you could pick and choose
from they are really specific and so
here you can see in the case of simply
learn hey if you're taking a digital
marketing course for simply learn it
doesn't hurt to have some emojis support
that that message so you always get the
thumbs up to get emoji you know the
image of the graduation and that's a
good emoji so you know you always want
to align you know really fun relevant
emojis with your messaging it kind of
just helps it stick out a bit and people
resonate with emojis and so it doesn't
hurt to add those emojis in your ad copy
and especially if your competition is
not using emojis you want every
advantage you can to have your ad stick
out so emojis is a good way to get your
ad to stick out tip number 22 use utm
parameters to your ad which can feed
into your google analytics account and
provide tracking information so i can't
stress this enough if you're using
google analytics to track your campaigns
then you want to use utm parameters so
what do we mean by utm parameters well
let me show you an example so all you
need to do is type in utm tracking or
url builder in google and then you're
going to actually get to this page here
so what this does this is a tool to help
you create utm tracking so if we're
simply learn and we want to advertise
and drive the audience to a specific
page in this case artificial
intelligence masters program page so
this is going to be the url but we want
to append that url with some utm
tracking parameters our campaign source
parameter we're going to put facebook
because that's the source that we're
advertising the medium in which we're
driving that traffic to the page from
facebook is cpc which stands for cost
per click and then we're just going to
put campaign name ai engineer to
identify
what it is that campaign is related to
so notice that the only required
parameter is campaign source in this
case we're going gonna put facebook but
we can also use campaign content if we
want to differentiate the different ads
that we have so you can use campaign
content parameter as well you don't have
to the only required parameters campaign
source my recommendation
go all lowercase okay and then when
you're done you have a url that you can
use in your advertising so when somebody
actually goes to that url notice the url
includes the utm tracking and then
analytics is going to be able to pick up
that campaign from where facebook the
medium is going to be cpc and the
campaign in this case is going to be ai
engineer and that's what you're going to
look for in google analytics so it helps
you track your ads more closely because
if you don't use utm tracking for
example on facebook then analytics might
you know interpret that traffic coming
from that ad as you know organic social
so we want to be able to identify
specifically the campaign you're running
by putting in different variables for
those parameters so that's what utm
tracking is you want to use it for all
your facebook advertising okay so it
really helps you you know in analytics
identify how your campaign's performing
not only is it driving traffic but is
the campaign converting for you so if
you're trying to get somebody to sign up
for a class then analytics is going to
help us measure those conversions but
with utm tracking we can bridge the gap
between how many people facebook
delivered or drove to our site from the
ad and how many of those people actually
converted so utm parameters help bridge
that gap tip 23 use exclusion marketing
to improve your facebook return on
investment by not including people who
have already taken the action desired by
you okay so this is a very key feature
here so if we've already advertised and
people have reacted to our ad and has
subscribed they have subscribed then we
don't want to target that person again
so that's what exclusion marketing is we
want to be able to
you know target people that we're really
after so if you know somebody's looked
at our ad and did not convert or did not
go to our website or to not download
something or whatever it is we wanted
them to do then those are the people we
wanted to focus in on okay so in this
case exclusion marketing we're going to
exclude people
who have subscribed in this case we're
going to retarget people meaning
advertise again to people who have not
subscribed so that's what the exclusion
marketing feature does it helps you
really hone in on where you're targeting
and retargeting so that way you're not
hitting the same people over again and
that's only going to lead to poor
performance tip 24
track the right metrics for your
business so keep your eye on important
metrics what are those metrics you know
those are going to be kpis kpis are key
performance indicators and kpis
differentiate from metrics because kpis
are related to business goals so track
the right metrics for your business what
are the right metrics for your business
more than likely it's going to be
conversions or conversion rate but you
could be running a brand awareness
campaign just like blue bottle coffee
did and so if you're running a brand
awareness campaign then maybe your kpi
or metric is going to be a click okay or
click-through rate how many people are
actually reacting to our ad okay so you
always want to align the right metric
with your business okay it's just very
important that you're measuring against
the right metric if you're not then it's
going to be misaligned in terms of how
you judge the campaign performance
another set of metrics could be reach
and frequency so reach and frequency
allow us to measure how many people saw
the ad and post engagement can determine
how many users are reacting to your ads
cpc helps us determine the cost
effectiveness or how much we're paying
for every click you could see that
information in your facebook ad manager
for example if i go to facebook's ads
manager here i'm looking at some some
ads that we're running here what can i
see i can see my reach how many people
i'm actually reaching the frequency in
which they're seeing my ad notice i can
see my relevancy score i can also see my
cost per result i can see the total
clicks so i have a whole set of metrics
available to me really what i want to do
is pick and choose the metrics that are
most important to the ad i'm running
okay so if it's reach am i reaching the
full amount of people possible if i'm
running a brand awareness campaign or it
could be some other metric like
conversion so we want to be able to
align the right metric with the right ad
tip 25 take advantage of facebook's
location tracking tool for your
advertisements so facebook allows us to
advertise up to 25 countries with
different states provinces cities
districts and zip codes so we can really
hone in location wise on where we want
to target so facebook allows us to do
that so basically it could be somebody
in a particular area or people who have
been recently been there or traveling to
that location or actually live there so
really could hone in on a specific
location based on certain set of
criteria so with this you could take
your marketing to the next level by
approaching your competitors customers
by offering them better discounts so
that's the whole idea targeting your
advertising on a specific location and
then knowing that your competitors are
there you can really put out some really
good ads with some really good offers to
really convert some of those people in
that audience okay let's take a a look
at another ad okay so grammarly this is
an ad that they've uh put out there and
again you notice there's no real true
call to action associated with the
single image ad here it's all about
messaging here they're saying hey
download it free today okay and so it's
a browser extension that they're
promoting and really they're trying to
get you to identify or identify with
this particular brand that offers a
specific product so they do have a
promotion in there it's brand awareness
hey your life is about to change i mean
the messaging is pretty you know matter
of fact they're trying to get you to hey
i need this in my browser as an
extension so for me this ad is all about
the messaging here okay so with
grammarly you know if you're in gmail
you're in word you're in outlook they
got you covered by using their browser
expansion it's free and by using it it's
going to make your life a lot easier so
for me the ad works from a messaging
standpoint not really big on the imagery
but it's really about this is who we are
and
we can really rock your world if you use
this browser extension so they're really
putting a lot of emphasis on the
messaging so for me anytime somebody
says my life's about to change they've
got my attention how to rank youtube
videos today so it's simply learn we
take our videos on youtube very
seriously meaning that when we create
videos we want people to see them
because we know we make good videos and
we know we have good content and we know
that our audience is going to enjoy it
and so we want our audience to see the
videos that we're creating and so we're
going to give you some tips and tricks
and methodology and ideas on how to get
your videos to rank on youtube so at
simply learn if i go to
youtube and i just type in machine
learning you can see where right here is
the first organic video on youtube for
machine learning if i jump over to
google and i type in machine learning
basics you can see where number we're
number one for machine learning basics
under videos if i click on all we're
also ranked here as well under the video
section on organic search results
another example data science for
beginners we ranked number one for that
if i look at another keyword data
science interview question okay we'll
rank number two for that so we're
ranking for a lot of videos and why are
we ranking for a lot of different
content and videos on google search and
on youtube well we put a lot of work in
behind the scenes of creating the video
and that's what we want to show you so
part of that has a lot to do with you
know how our audience engages and sees
our video so for example we're looking
at a machine learning basics video here
and we can see that it has over 221
thousand subscribers for this video 234
000 views we've had over 2 000 people
like the video and we have had over 270
plus comment on the video so when we get
our videos to rank then we can see
there's a lot of engagement and so
that's the whole idea is when you do a
video and you want to show up on youtube
you want people to enjoy you want people
to share you want people to like it you
want people to comment on that and
that's part of the whole ecosystem of
youtube it's you know we're going to
show you behind the scenes of what it
takes to get your videos to rank and
then we're going to show you some of the
metrics involved with some of these
videos to help you stay ranking so
without further ado let's go into
how to get your videos to rank on
youtube so we're going to talk about
keyword research for youtube we're going
to talk about some ways to create high
quality videos so the importance of user
engagement just as i showed you with the
machine learning basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're going to
get into how to promote your content and
then we're going to just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
center our keywords just like our
website we want to center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on youtube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states youtube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
google so
youtube is pretty popular majority
people use youtube search every day to
watch videos on a number of different
topics so they can find these videos in
google but because youtube's so powerful
and so popular people go directly right
into youtube for their searches and so
the whole idea behind youtube being the
second most well-known search engine is
centered around keywords so if you have
the right keywords for your video then
the chances of you ranking higher
increases on youtube so we're gonna
share with you a few easy ways to do
keyword research this is the most
important step in getting your videos to
rank on youtube just like for those of
you who watched any of the seo videos we
produced at simplylearn you know that
keyword research is so essential to
getting your web pages to rank on google
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important for your videos as is for
your web pages so we're going to go into
a few things to do here to find the
right keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other factors involved in
google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
first thing is search suggest so youtube
has a feature called autocomplete so if
you've done any searches on google it's
very similar if you're typing something
in to youtube search then youtube is
going to suggest other related popular
keywords so let's take a look at that if
we go back to youtube for a second and i
just type in machine learning youtube is
going to populate on the autocomplete in
the search bar some other popular
keywords that we can potentially use or
in this case if i choose you know
machine learning tutorial i'm gonna see
a video about machine learning tutorial
so here you can see simply learns ranked
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know youtube
just like on google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing a
video on machine learning then you know
we have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are our popular keywords
these are keywords that people are using
to search on youtube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitor's youtube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to youtube so if i go
to type in simply learn here's our
channel page just by clicking on simply
learn i click on videos ever wonder if
there's so now i can see all the ever
wonder if there's an easier way go back
so here i can see all the videos sort by
most popular once they do that then i
can choose a video this is the most
popular video right now for simply learn
if i click on that video it's
automatically going to start playing but
what i could do is simply just look at
you know the content and description so
just by clicking show more i can see all
the content that align with this video
that's one way to do it is simply by
looking at your competitors now what you
could also do is look at the tags
associated with the particular video and
so what you want to do is you want to
look at the html and so that means
looking at the page source so just like
web pages what youtube does is they look
at meta tags so if you call from seo in
order to get your pages to rank you need
to have a title tag and a meta tag
description so videos are no different
what we're doing
for youtube is aligning certain keywords
with the video so if you take a look and
do a search for keywords by viewing the
page source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example i go back to
youtube and i look at the page source of
a video let's just say this video here
facebook's ad tutorial i'm going to pull
up the page source and all i need to do
is control f and type in keywords and
now for that facebook video i can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords were aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that youtube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas these most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see facebook marketing facebook ad
strategy facebook ads for beginners so
forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right clicking view page source do a
control f for keywords and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you can see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
channel and is also ranking on youtube
and on google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at uh
some other ideas here so you can install
plugins and there are plenty of plugins
available on the chrome browser that
will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples of vid iq and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if i go
back here and i look at a video on
youtube let's just say the machine
learning basics video i have vid iq
installed on my chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid iq is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video they're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with facebook
some engagement metrics really what i'm
interested in is those keywords so if i
scroll down a bit here i can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning basics video so vid iq is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated i can also see where they
rank so for machine learning basics this
particular video ranks number one if i
go down i could see what is machine
learning and how does it work i can see
it's ranked number two here i could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so i can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
i can also see some channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place i want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you
to really get an understanding of what
keywords to use at the particular video
so autocomplete you can look at the page
source of a competitor's video or you
can use a chrome extension in this case
i'm using vid iq to give me some
information about the video tags for a
particular video so according to an
industry study using keywords and video
tags will help you rank well on youtube
so you have to use keywords and video
tags if you want your video to rank
there's been a lot of studies youtube is
so popular and videos are so prominent
in today's world where if you have
videos and you're going to upload them
to youtube then associate the right
keywords with those videos so some
important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on youtube or google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in chrome in my example i use
vid iq that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what google is
going to do and youtube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition are
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the contents
about and then the secondary keywords
that support the primary so if you have
a machine learning video you could
choose your primary keyword as in this
case the machine learning basics video
so well chosen keywords help you rank
well on youtube just like the machine
learning basics so if i go back to our
video our machine learning basics video
if i just type in machine learning
basics i'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if i click on it i'm going to
go to youtube and so here i can see this
keyword we know humans learn from their
is well aligned because
it's in the title it's in the copy and
it's a line is a keyword tag with the
video so we know that that keyword has
good volume low competition is relevant
because that's what the video is about
the basics of machine learning it's an
introduction to machine learning so
instead of honing in on just
introduction
machine learning primary keyword is
machine learning basics and then we
supported that video with those
secondary keywords what is machine
learning because somebody who doesn't
know machine learning is probably going
to type in that keyword and then
introduction of machine learning is a
good secondary keyword because it's
explaining the basics of what machine
learning is all about so primary keyword
machine learning basic secondary
keywords what is machine learning and
introduction to machine learning so
that's the whole idea behind choosing
keywords you want that keyword that
really is going to define the content
and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
google shows on the video results page
so what i mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on youtube it's
also to be found on google so if i go
back to google and i just type in data
science for beginners and i type in
videos then you can see we're ranked
number one so even if you're not looking
at the videos clicking on the videos
link on google search you can always
just when you do a search what google's
going to do is also put in the videos
here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall
for data science for beginners but we're
ranked number one in the videos category
and so if somebody's looking for a video
that's important and you can see here
that these first two are ads so what
google is doing is they're saying hey
this is so relevant this particular
video for the keyword query data science
for beginners that we're going to show
it above the organic listings even
though it's a video so the whole idea is
to be found on youtube and google
because you're increasing your
visibility you're increasing your
chances of getting found on both search
platforms so according to backlinko
google ranks videos with keywords like
how to tutorials so you know a lot of
the videos that you find on youtube are
going to be instructional based and so
what google's doing is they're saying
hey if somebody types in how-to or
tutorial or an introduction to anything
that's going to signal to google that
it's instructional it's going to help
you rank so when you search for machine
learning tutorial or how to become a
machine learning engineer you're going
to get results related to that because
if you look at these examples we have
machine learning tutorial in our title
or how to become a machine learning
engineer so keep that in mind if you're
creating a video and it's educational in
nature you know use those key terms like
how to and tutorials in the video title
because that will help you rank so let's
move over now to video titles so we want
to use our target keyword in the title
of the video and again we want to make
sure if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title youtube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really google and youtube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
high click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video titles what's
going to show up in search so if i go
back to you know search here we could
see you know data science tutorial data
science for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey i don't have
time to watch a video i only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great i'm going to click on
the video and now i have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click-through rate up
remember click-through rate is clicks
divided by impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up in
the search results on youtube or google
so we want to keep our click-through
rate high and in order to do that we
want to be able to write some really
good title tags for our video so use
catchy words like a number or how to or
what is because that's going to resonate
with people when they're searching now
for the description what we want to do
is we want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if i go back to
my video here machine learning basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if i look at the description
of the video here i can see this machine
learning basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5 000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if i go back to my video i click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if i go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if i go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's
aligned with that hashtag and then
there's target keywords and lsi keywords
latent semantic indexing keywords we
want to be able to use those keywords as
target keywords with our video so if you
recall the example i gave a few minutes
ago we used the facebook ads tutorial as
our example here i could see all the
target keywords associated with that
particular video so don't be afraid to
use those lsi related keywords meaning
keywords that are related to the content
use them as target keywords with the
video so between your lsi keywords
target keywords and then using our
primary and secondary keyword in the
title tag using our primary and
secondary keyword in the description and
then using hashtags in the description
the combination of all of that if we
chose the right keyword then we should
find that our video will eventually rank
on youtube so just doing these small
tidbits with our keywords really help
get our video to rank so at the end of
the day we want to be able to use the
tools available to us youtube itself by
looking at our competitors those
extensions like vid iq the autocomplete
to really find our good keywords and
then incorporating those keywords into
you know the title tag the description
as target keywords hashtags we should
really be off and running with our video
on youtube let's turn our attention to
creating high quality videos and some of
the best practices around that so along
with everything we mentioned about
choosing the right keywords we always
need to keep in mind that the videos we
create need to be of high quality so the
content itself in addition to the
keywords this is a primary factor in
ranking so in order to have keywords we
need to have content and in order to
rank we need to have you know good
content so let's talk a little bit about
creating content and what's involved
with that and what we really mean by
high quality videos so if you have a
video content that is not informative or
irrelevant to the topic it won't rank so
that's just common sense so you need to
create content that's aligned with the
topic obviously and then that way you
have keywords that are in line with the
content so but if you have content it
really isn't aligned with the topic then
you're not going to rank no matter how
much you've optimized that video so just
keep that in mind so there's a couple of
things we want to look at here so high
quality content is determined by
really two metrics so we're not sure
about how good our content is and how
good of high quality video we created we
want to look at audience retention and
user engagement so audience retention is
simply the percentage length of your
video that the audience has watched it's
the percentage your audience has watched
so focusing on audience retention is
important for people who want their
videos to rank high so if you want to
rank you need to optimize for the
keywords but got to keep in mind content
so content is related to audience
retention and user engagement so
audience retention percentage length
your video of your video that the
audience has watched and for example it
can be both absolute in minutes or
percentages so audience retention can be
the average view duration or percentage
of the audience that watched then we
have user engagement so yours engagement
viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long the second
video is seven minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40 of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that reason is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to
watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so we talk about watch time so if one
video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recommendation is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay is really
with an outline starting out with an
optimist no videos are no different than
say a presentation if you've done a
powerpoint presentation you always want
to start out doing an outline and then
we want to upload high resolution videos
high resolution we don't want to create
videos that you know are small
resolution like say you know 400 by 400
resolution or something you know
something really small we want to create
something a very high res so according
to back or link oaks more than 50 of
videos on the first page of youtube are
high definition so
high definition videos of higher quality
are going to be shown on the first page
of youtube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos are examples of
creating high quality videos we also
want to make sure that content is
relevant to the title so if we're
talking about machine learning basics
you know obviously the content is going
to be about you know intro to machine
learning or what is machine learning and
then the title should reflect that
content so aligning the title sets the
expectation for the end user so when
they see a title what is machine
learning then when they watch the video
they're expecting to learn about machine
learning and what it is so if it meets
expectations then the chances are that
person who's watching the video is going
to watch it longer and that means it's
going to fulfill the viewers
requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day the
user is going to watch it and the more
they watch it the higher the engagement
the higher the engagement the better
chance you have to rank some other tips
that you could use to
create high quality videos so we want to
be able to you know use examples to
clarify our content so you know don't be
afraid to go into another screen like i
am i want to i'm talking about videos
jump into the machine learning basics
video which i've done throughout this
session i can simply do that by keeping
the user engaged here this video is
about machine learning basics well the
titles online with the video we made
sure that we have a nice description
about what the video is about and we're
aligning the expectations so not only
that i'm showing you example within the
video itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like shutterstock
or flat icon i mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to
use high quality images in your video
give more information to your audience
giving maximum relevant information can
help gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know the examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from youtube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on youtube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
i'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what i'm trying to say or
what the viewers trying to to understand
when they're watching the video so
watching and listening are two of the
components and you want to make sure
both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles
for your video so transcripts is just
more content that's aligned with the
video and the search engines will be
able to pick up that content and help
your video rank so to me that's a key
component to creating a good video is
having the necessary content to go along
with the video that outline i referenced
earlier in terms of organization you
always want to have a content outline so
what topics are you going to cover in
the video that's why you need the
outline to point that out confirm that
before you actually start creating the
video they focus on the initial 15
seconds so that's key you know
somebody's going to click the play
button of your video and if you don't
catch them in the first 15 seconds then
they're likely going to pause the video
or just go ahead and close it out
altogether so you want to be able to
capture somebody's attention right off
the bat and even before they click on
that play button you want to make sure
again you're exceeding expectations that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds it basically needs
to be catchy but also setting the
expectation of what the user is
expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in youtube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention or relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example i can see you know
43 44
watch the video for at least two minutes
here i can see 28.6
watch it for six minutes plus so that's
the audience retention it gives us an
idea in terms of percentage how many
people or percentage of people watch the
video at what length so that's audience
retention so we want to keep that number
high at the very initial stage of the
video and we want to keep it high
throughout and that's why you always
want to create high quality content
using those examples using imagery
making it organized content not pausing
you know going from one point to the
other those are all
best practices to keep the viewer
engaged and then we want to add
resources from well-known sites so
throughout this video we've used
backlinko there are other sources we've
used so if you have a source go ahead
and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or youtube can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically
it allows your audience to stay within
one video without having any
interruptions involved and so going back
to the did you know audience retention
report helps you analyze how well your
videos are engaging to the audience so
what do we mean by that well if i go
back again to my audience retention
report how engaging was it well i could
see 42 percent 43
watched it on average of 3 minutes and
21 seconds so to me that's pretty good
of course we always want a 100 of the
video the video is seven minutes long if
almost half of our audience saw over
half of the video then i would say
that's pretty good people were engaged
so audience retention just is a good
report to start looking at to help you
understand how engaging is my video and
if your video is not engaging you know
you can always go back and edit it or
fix it or tweak it so remember the
average view duration for all videos and
top performing videos listed by all time
we can look at that information as well
in addition we can look at demographics
so we can get an overview of the age
gender and location okay we can look at
playback locations report and what the
playback locations report does is it
helps us determine the platforms where
our videos are being streamed from
within youtube look at the traffic
sources where did the viewers come from
devices did they look on mobile or
tablet and so if there's any doubts you
know if you have any questions please
drop a comment below but especially if
you have any doubts on the metrics so if
we go back into youtube we can look at
analytics and if we're looking at
analytics we can see more and then this
is going to show us everything we need
to see from device type so if i click on
more i can see my playback location so
this will show me where the video was
watched it was on a watch page or a
channel page i could see the traffic
sources i could see the gender and age
so if i click on the viewer age report i
can see the percentage of views by age
so i can get a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know okay so
it's all within youtube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to youtube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to youtube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at youtube analytics
so let's talk about the importance of
user engagement so engagement is as we
mentioned important because basically we
can't rank without engagement our videos
won't rank unless we have engagement so
that's why it's important so engagement
is somebody liking the video commenting
sharing it or subscribing each one of
these is important to ranking so yes you
need to line keywords yes you need to
have high quality content so when you do
both of those and you upload your video
then it's up to the viewer and so
the hard work that you put out for the
video is hopefully going to pay
dividends with engagement so you want
people to do one of these for okay so
let's talk about
what that means so how do i get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to word stream if your
content is entertaining then over three
quarters of the users are going to share
it so that's part of keeping uh users
engaged is keeping it entertaining is
part of getting a high quality video so
remember on the high quality video when
we say entertaining the audio portion
has a lot to do with it examples has a
lot to do with it quality of the video
itself has a lot to do with it so a lot
of components so all those components on
a high quality video are going to lead
to engagement so parts of what you could
do in your videos is conduct a quiz so
meaning the quiz itself is a way to keep
people engaged in your video so that'll
also help you get some more comments so
according to backlinku video comments
help in ranking your video higher so
just as i mentioned in the last segment
about
youtube analytics and all the different
reports available on youtube hey if you
have questions on those just go ahead
and add a comment so that's a way to
entice your users or your viewers to add
comments is if they have questions
because you know with videos you're not
going to be able to cover every detail
or every minute detail about a
particular topic you can only cover in
some cases the topic at a high level so
users are going to have comments or
questions naturally and so the comments
section is a good way to remind viewers
hey if you have a question or comment go
ahead and put in the comments section
because that will lend to engagement as
well so we want to add sources from high
quality websites that'll help with
engagement okay use humor in your video
we want to be able to
basically you know make it human-based
we don't want to be robots so we want to
be able to sound like you know we know
we're talking about but at the same time
talk to the viewer not necessarily at
the viewer or looking the other way and
just going through the motions so adding
humor adding personality never hurts at
the end of the day we are all human
adding that clear call to action at the
end of the video will also
lead to engagement so if we win the
video with hey
leave your comments on this video or hey
feel free to share this video with
colleagues who are interested then
that's a call to action that's likely
going to lead to more engagement reply
to your comments as well so if you have
comments we always want to reply to them
likely those comments are going to be
questions because again as i mentioned
even in this video about how to rank
your videos on youtube okay there's a
lot of information and a lot of
information sometimes doesn't get
covered in its entirety and so we want
to make sure that if we miss something
because we're only human that we're able
to respond in the form of an answer to a
question that somebody leaves in the
comments section so more comments also
lead to higher rankings because it's
engagement so when you're getting high
engagement and your video starts to rank
well you know you're going to start
feeling really good and what is that
going to do look at that feel good it's
gonna lead to confidence which in turn
is gonna probably lead to more videos
and that's exactly what we do at simply
learn i mean we're in the education
business but we're in it to not only
educate but making sure that our videos
are shown to as many people as possible
so that we can educate as many people as
possible so it's all it's contagious so
getting ranked feels good and then once
you get ranked then you know you
probably have good engagement okay let's
talk about how to promote your content
so once you've done all the hard work
getting your video done high quality
content optimize with keywords and then
publish to youtube we want to let
everybody in the world know about it
right so we want to promote it we've
done all the work we want to promote it
now so is it necessary to promote it i
would say yes because once your video is
published you want to reach out you want
to reach out to your audience not
necessarily on youtube but on different
platforms so if you're active on
facebook or twitter that's an
opportunity for you to post or tweet
something about the new video so when we
say different platforms i am talking
about you know social media platforms so
it depends on what you're active on so
if you're active on facebook yeah go
ahead and post some you're active on
twitter go ahead and tweet something it
could be you know on linkedin group if
you're part of a linkedin group about
you know machine learning then go ahead
and post something to that group to
promote the video so that's going to
help drive traffic to the video and then
help with engagement so we want to
engage with our audience on those social
media sites so it really depends on what
you're active on so if you have a large
following on twitter then go ahead and
you know share that youtube video link
on twitter with the tweet that's going
to drive traffic from twitter to youtube
remember you know you're going to be
able to see audience engagement or
retention by getting people to watch the
video so you're going to be able to see
right away by promoting the video and
driving traffic to the video how
engaging it is remember the more people
you have watch the video the more
engaging it becomes the better it's
going to rain so it's an ecosystem and
promoting your content is part of that
ecosystem so it all starts with social
media if you're active on whatever
platform that is go ahead and promote it
so you can also look at you know
content-based social media sites or
social media content based platforms
like reddit or flickr for example so you
can participate in a forum discussion on
reddit so in this example here it's
about machine learning so we want to be
able to post something about machine
learning with the link to our video so
we can also go to content-based sites
that are q a
related like cora for example core is a
really good site where you know if you
go there post information about machine
learning or the basics of machine
learning with the link back to the video
it's going to help because not only is
it going to drive traffic but it's going
to signal to google hey
a lot of traffic coming from quora this
is going to bode well for this video in
terms of ranking so here's an example
you know if you find a question that you
can post on core then you're going to
get people to click on your video and
respond accordingly on quora or you can
act as the person responding to a
question that's already there so
somebody already asked a question about
what is machine learning you can respond
with your video as the answer so you can
just simply embed your video url as part
of your answer that'll help drive
traffic so you can also create your own
blog and embed your videos so in the
case of machine learning here we have an
example machine learning what is it and
why it matters so this goes nicely with
the video so here you could see the
person the author of this blog went
ahead and embedded the relevant video in
the blog post so they play off one
another nicely you can also opt in for
influencer marketing meaning hey you can
reach out to somebody in this example
here you know kd nuggets posted
information about machine learning so in
this case why choose machine learning as
a career well they got information and
then what did they do they went ahead
and embedded the video about machine
learning basics and so working with you
know influencers in a particular
category or topic will help drive
traffic to the video you can also create
a youtube playlist so playlists tend to
rank high in youtube searches so if you
find yourself doing a lot of videos
we'll go ahead and you know go to
your channel and simply on your channel
you can go ahead and create playlists so
when you create playlists basically what
you're doing is you're organizing the
content into different playlists no
different than say the music you have
set up on your you know your iphone or
ipad or or ipod whatever it is you're
using so you're just creating different
videos in a particular category and it
youtube likes it it's organized it's
gonna help you get your videos found
quicker and easier on youtube itself by
putting your videos in a playlist so
here you could see we have entire
playlists on machine learning trending
technologies cloud computing big data
digital marketing project management's a
lot of different playlists very
organized if somebody goes to the
channel they're going to be able to go
to the playlist that's interesting to
them and see all the videos there so it
allows not only the end user to find
what they're looking for but it's good
for youtube because youtube likes those
playlists so we want to engage our
audience by posting your video link on a
community page so you can do that within
youtube and you can prefer to link your
youtube channel in your email so you can
also do that so for example if i go back
to youtube and i'm looking at a youtube
video you know i can always click share
so here i'm gonna get a
particular url that's associated with
the video and i can just embed that so i
can embed the whole thing in my email i
can embed it on a web page or a blog
post so just by clicking share i can
also immediately share it onto the
social media platforms that we mentioned
facebook linkedin reddit okay tumblr so
there's a lot of ways to
embed the video not just that on blog
posts or influencer blog posts but in
our email and on social media as well so
here's an example of what we can do with
the youtube discussion so we can also
bookmark the video on a popular
bookmarking site you know like stumbled
upon or read it or
you know there's lots of other ones out
there so there's plenty of sites that
you'll be able to go to and bookmark
that content so that people can find it
and you can always opt for backlinks so
that means that hey
if there's a blogger out there that
blogs about machine learning you can
always
you know ask that blogger to create a
link back to the video and you could
reciprocate do the same thing so that
helps increase the authority of the
video so a lot of things you could do to
promote your video so let's do a quick
review on everything we talked about in
terms of ranking your video on youtube
it all starts with the keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are relevant to the video so we can use
tools to choose our keywords but
remember we want to choose keywords that
have high volume and low competition and
so where can we go to choose those
keywords well we can use the
autocomplete on youtube we could check
out our own competitors videos or you
know we could use vid iq or tubebuddy or
any of these extensions in chrome to
help us look at the keywords that are
tagged with a particular video so
remember we want to have a primary
keyword that's aligned with the content
then we want to choose lsi keywords as
our secondary keyword or keywords that
are related to the primary keyword so we
want to create high retention videos
meaning that first 15 seconds are the
most important but throughout the video
we want to use examples we want to keep
it interacting by adding quizzes imagery
good audio good video quality so we want
to focus on the user experience and we
also want to optimize our video content
what does that mean well those keywords
that we chose we want to use them in the
title we want to use them in the
description we want to use them as
hashtags we want to use them and tag
them with the video themselves so we can
add keywords to our meta tag okay we
don't want to overdo it but we want to
add a handful of keywords that is are
associated with the video so we want to
be able to write eye catchy video titles
and descriptions so remember use some of
those key phrases like a number
or a question like what is machine
learning so we want to use relevant meta
tags for the videos and we want to use
popular youtube tags so we want to be
able to tag our videos appropriately to
watch the length of your meta tags so
there are lengths involved remember
keywords at the beginning of the title
target keywords in the title description
and tags we want to use interesting
thumbnails to increase our click-through
rate ensure that thumbnails are relevant
meaning when i say thumbnails i mean the
actual title tag itself or the meta
description we want to use high-res
videos we want to create you know videos
with good high audio quality don't be
afraid to put in video effects like some
animation don't be afraid to use
examples and then you know obviously
look at the draft of the video before
you publish it so does your video follow
an outline is it organized so these are
all the things to take into account and
there's there's plenty more you can do
you know you remember once you create
and optimize that video you want to
promote it you want to make sure that
you're sharing it on social media you
create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating this playlist and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your youtube video ranked today
we're going to talk about how to
increase youtube subscribers so with
youtube
it's all about subscribers the number of
subscribers you have on youtube it's
just one of the key metrics to measure
success so gaining more subscribers can
help you achieve more view counts on
your youtube videos so it's all about
how to get subscribers and today we're
going to talk about how to get more
subscribers and before we begin let's
just show you what we did at simply
learn so if we look at the past 365 days
on our youtube channel you can see we
started here back in uh if we look back
at march 9 2018 we had 208 and you can
see just over the course of the year it
kept creeping up creeping up creeping up
and creeping up we've gained you know a
significant number of subscribers over
the last year and what's our secret well
it's posting videos so you can see we've
posted a number of videos over the
course of the year and then our
subscribers have gone basically 165
over the last year so you can see it's
part of it is about posting videos
because when you post videos you have
people who can watch those videos when
you have people watch those videos you
can have engagement and then when you
have engagement you have shares and
people who like it and then other people
will see it so it's kind of a halo
effect so to speak so getting
subscribers it takes a lot more than
just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about some tips to help
you increase the subscriptions so let's
start out with some of those tips we're
going to start with creating engagement
informative content so engaging in
informative content that's where we're
going to start talking today about how
to increase subscriptions then we're
going to talk about publishing videos
frequently so simply learn you can see
the past 365 days we were consistent in
publishing videos consistently
throughout the month and the weeks so
another tip we're going to talk about is
how to optimize your youtube videos so
there's a lot that goes into
optimization but this is a key key tip
to pay attention to because when it
comes to posting publishing videos on
youtube you need to align certain things
like keywords and content and metadata
so optimize on our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the youtube
channel so there's some tips and tricks
here you want to do to optimize your
youtube channel producing high quality
videos we're going to talk about that
adding a subscriber watermark to your
videos okay that's another tip we're
going to mention today engage with our
audience okay that's what we want to do
we want to engage with our audience
that's a really key tip we're saving the
best for last promote your videos in
different platforms so all of these tips
we're going to talk about today so let's
get started and talk about create
engaging informative content so that's
the first place we want to start okay so
create engaging and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our channel we have to create highly
engaged and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not going to
watch the video and then the
engagement's not going to be high and
they're not going to share the video and
they're not going to tell their friends
or like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you gotta create it so it's
engaging and informative so how do you
do that well let's talk about that so
the first thing is you have to know your
audio okay so when you create a video
who you're creating the video for i mean
that's where it all starts so when
you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world now we know on youtube there's a
lot of cute videos about kittens and
jokes and you know people playing games
and you know everybody likes positive
things on youtube but you know when
we're talking about a specific topic you
know we really have to hone in on a
target audience and so if you know who
your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the mass general
population because it's not going to be
engaging and informative so that's the
first place to start then you want to
engage that audience with relevant
content so if you know your audience and
depending on the topic you want to make
sure that whatever the topic is the
content matches the topic don't veer off
course if you veer off course you're not
going to engage your viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason the reason is the
topic okay so if they're your target
audience and they want to watch the
video that's a specific topic then the
content has to align so plan your video
script so if you know who your audience
is and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out so what i normally do is
you know have an outline and then once i
have the outline then i go ahead and
create my slides if i will or my topics
points i want to talk about and then i
write out those points i want to make
sure i get all my points in and that's
what you should be doing you want to
plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
okay you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to overload the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information back off a little
use the information to create another
video so it's all about knowing your
audience so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of this session i showed you
an example of simply learned subscribers
over the past 365 days and so that's
what we want to do we want to be clear
but use examples to punctuate the
content or the point we're trying to get
across so we want to include sources
from high quality sites so if you're
going to use examples make sure they're
from relevant high quality sites and
what i mean high quality meaning does
your audience know who that source is or
that site if it's really specific and
your audience may not know then it's
probably not high quality so just keep
that in mind always play to your
audience so you want to start your video
with an interesting hook so again i go
back to this example if you're still
watching this then the hook worked we
showed you our subscriptions we showed
you how we grew over the course of a
year you could see our growth and part
of it was posting a lot of videos with
relevant and informative content and so
you see how we did it so you're paying
attention you want to know how to do it
and so part of what we did is exactly
what i'm telling you now we know who our
audience is we plan out our scripts we
use good examples and we start our
videos with interesting hooks now when
we do our videos we also create original
content so that goes back to planning
your script okay you always want to you
know come across as original and
informative when you do that you're
going to be engaging but if you're
leveraging somebody else's content then
the engaging part may not resonate
because it's not your content to begin
with so always always always use
original content okay so keep the
content flow organized so again that
goes back to an outline you know feel
free to change up the outline so the
flow makes sense add visuals to your
content and make it appealing always
include images to me if you can use
images in your videos and play off the
video or the images then it's just gonna
flow and make it a little bit more
engaging and appealing meaning the
content so visuals help guide and aid in
the points you're trying to make so
don't make it so text heavy you know
accentuate it balance it with some
images use simple language and crisp
sentences meaning don't choose jargon
don't come across and talk above your
audience you always want to talk to your
audience and talk in a language that
they're going to understand so it goes
back to point one if you know who your
audience is you're talking to them as if
they're right in front of you and not
you're above them or they're below you
you wanna talk at them so add cards end
screens and pattern interrupts to engage
your audience and so youtube cards are
just interactive panels that slide in
and out when a video is playing so it
encourages
interaction by the viewer okay so you
can add up to five cards which include
images text or clickable links so feel
free to play around with some of these
features that youtube has to offer to
make your content more engaging so tip
two publish videos frequently so
creating and uploading videos
consistently will help you increase your
youtube subscribers so suppose you
haven't published videos for more than
say a month or two months it's likely
that that audience not gonna subscribe
to your channel so think about youtube
videos as a popular tv program that
comes on once a week when a new episode
comes on based on the regular schedule
it's consistency and that consistency is
what helps your users stay engaged so
for example if i go back to our youtube
channel you know what helped us gain
subscribers was our consistency in
publishing videos you could see we were
consistent publishing a couple of videos
a week every couple of weeks and so this
helps users stay engaged they know when
the video is coming out they know that
simply learn is good for two three four
videos a month and the great thing about
publishing videos is that when somebody
does subscribe to your channel they're
going to get a notification or youtube
has an option where they can get a
notification via email so i subscribe to
simplylearn's channel i subscribe to
other channels like google analytics for
example so anytime google analytics
publishes a video i get an email that
says hey google analytics youtube
channel just published a video and the
great thing is i'm checking my email and
i'm getting this notification in gmail
so guess what i can watch the video
right then and there just by clicking on
the link in the email i don't even have
to go to the channel but knowing that if
you publish consistently and somebody
does get the email once a week then it's
more likely they're going to engage
especially if the content is original
engaging and informative so frequent
video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to social
media examiner youtube channels that
publish videos more than once a week are
performing much better so if you can
afford to publish more videos more than
once a week the chances of you gaining
subscribers quicker are going to be
greater so keeping a fixed frequency can
help you quickly gain more subscribers
posting videos is like almost like
blogging i always say start small if you
could do one blog post a month and then
once you get in a routine then you can
ramp up the frequencies so from one blog
post you could do two a month then four
times a month and once a week or twice a
week same with the youtube videos you
want to get into a rhythm you know start
with once a month and ramp it up okay
then you'll find that the more you ramp
it up the more subscribers you're gonna
get so tip three optimize your youtube
videos so optimizing your videos will
help your content rank higher on youtube
so this is a give must it's not a given
it's a must you must optimize your
videos if you want people to see them of
course if you don't optimize people
aren't going to see them then people
aren't going to engage and then not
subscribe so it's just kind of a
snowball effect so this is an important
tip so i mentioned it at the beginning
when we were going over all the items
we're going to discuss this is the one
item that is a must and a given to some
degree because if you don't optimize
your videos they're just not going to be
found so you need that audience to watch
your video so audiences who tend to
interact more with your content have
more chance to subscribe to your channel
but they're not going to subscribe if
they don't even watch your video so
there is a snowball effect in play here
if we don't optimize your videos so okay
rob what are some of the tips to
optimize your youtube video well let's
go through some of those tips so to
ensure your videos reaches the relevant
audience on youtube you need to optimize
the title description in the video tag
okay rob what do you mean by title
description and video tag so let's take
a look at that so when you actually
create your youtube video you're going
to have an opportunity to put in a title
you're going to have an opportunity to
put in a description and you're going to
have an opportunity to add text so those
are the three key areas okay so once you
put in that what it looks like on the
front end is this so if i go back to
youtube and here you can see another
video that we did about a month ago you
could see what is seo so if that's our
topic that's our title uh or of the
content of the video then the title of
the video is going to be what is seo and
you can see we also added in some other
content for the title so what is seo and
how does it work seo tutorial for
beginners and then our brand name so we
have some content to work with for the
title okay and then the description we
have a lot of characters to work with
descriptions so use as much as you can
here to describe what the video is about
here you can see we did that and so it's
always good to include this information
okay and then you can see we have tags
up here seo seo tutorial for beginners
digital marketing so we put in the
necessary information here on this video
to help us rank because if we don't
optimize it we're not going to rank and
so you can see we just put a lot of
relevant content around the description
around the title and around those tags
by doing so we're able to optimize this
video and get found so that's just an
example three of the things you can do
to help optimize your youtube video so
if you want to watch more on how to
optimize meta tags then i suggest maybe
watching the other video we did on the
subject how to rank youtube videos so
this goes into more detail about how to
optimize the title the meta description
and the meta tags but those are three
quick fields or areas that you can use
to optimize your video so just something
to keep in mind write a long description
with keywords time stamps and links so
what i mean by time stamps for time
stamp an audience can choose the section
of the video that they want to look for
and then links prefer to include
relevant links of your other videos so
those are just some additional tips to
help keep your content engaging so
remember when your content is engaging
then people are going to like it people
are going to share it and watch it later
so upload a captivating thumbnail okay
so you want to include a thumbnail
that's going to grab people's attention
you want to upload a transcript of the
video so that goes back to when you're
creating your content when you write
your original content you want to keep a
transcript of the content of the video
so that you can upload that as well and
then add a start screen and end screen
to your youtube videos so that way you
know when somebody plays the video
they're going to see it what it looks
like up front and then we finish it
they're going to see an end screen at
the end and so you just don't want to
keep it dark and black and
non-descriptive so according to
backlinko using an exact keyword in your
video title can help you with rankings
so high ranking more views more views
more subscribers so that's what i've
been saying all along you need to get
these videos optimized so again use an
exact keyword in your video title so
let's go back again to that video i just
showed you a couple minutes ago what is
seo so here we started out with a
question what is seo that's the name of
the title that's one our exact title of
the video that's our exact keyword okay
so what is seo and how does it work and
then seo tutorial for beginners so what
is seo is our exact keyword and that's
part of the video that's the content of
the video that's in the title and we use
it throughout the description as well so
using that exact keyword in your video
title can help with the ranking so
whatever your topic is your title of the
video or the topic of the video included
in the title so backlinko also mentions
that there is a moderate correlation
between a channel's total subscribers
and rankings and so for some of you this
may be common sense it's just like
organic search if you're not ranking
you're not going to get traffic on
youtube if you're not ranking you're not
going to get eyeballs on your videos and
you're not going to get subscribers so
higher rankings can help you to get more
subscribers but you can't get those
rankings unless you optimize and so
again just for the sake of simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title matches the title of the
video itself when you're publishing your
description use all the amount of
content available to you so you can see
it this entire description has a lot of
content maximize the content and then
use tags using those three fields those
three areas can help you optimize your
video and gain the necessary ranking you
need to get viewers which you'll turn
into subscribers so tip four optimize
your youtube channel so we just talked
about optimizing our videos now we're
going to turn our attention to our
youtube channel so one of the easiest
ways to ask your views to subscribe to
your channel is really by creating a
good not even a good a great youtube
channel trailer you also want to add
channel keywords a description and some
good artwork and then having sections
and playlists to keep your videos
organized these are all good tips to
creating a good youtube channel so let's
talk about some of these these tips here
so we want to give your audience a
preview what your channel is offering so
this is by hooking your audience with a
trailer so you can create a trailer to
you know just give your audience an idea
of who you are as a brand what kind of
videos you're going to be posting and
give them a kind of a taste of what the
future videos are going to be like okay
you can even tell them your release
schedule in the trailer so you can start
out by saying hey hey guys we're new to
this we're going to be posting one video
a month but as we get rolling maybe two
per month and you know one per week you
know just being honest and open and
talking into your audience and get them
excited about future videos that's what
the trailer is all about so you also
want to keep it that the channel
description short interesting so in your
channel you want to have a description
of what the channel is all about what
kind of videos you're going to be
posting so in addition to the trailer
you want to write something short and
interesting then we want to use keywords
in our channel descriptions just like in
the videos with what is seo we included
what is seo in the title we included you
know what is seo in the description and
so we want to be true to what our
channel is so pick keywords not only
include those keywords in the videos but
include them in the channel description
pay attention to the first 100 to 150
characters of your channel description
because that's what's shown next your
channel on the search results so for
example here you can see we have a
description here simply learn is one of
the world's leading certification
training providers we partner with
companies and individuals to address and
so you could see those characters
100-150 are what shows up in the channel
description when somebody's trying to
understand hey simply learn just
uploaded this video who is simply learn
so you want to write short interesting
channel description so that when
somebody's first introduced to your
video they could see what your brand's
all about so and your description with
an appropriate call to action so short
interesting good call to action at the
end of the video a good call to action
would be hey check out our next video or
check out our latest video something
that's going to gauge somebody and get
them to watch one of your videos so you
want to pick interesting channel art so
let's turn our attention to the simply
learn channel page and here you can see
we recently
had reached a milestone so recently
reached the 200 000 k subscribers so 200
000 subscribers is a big achievement for
simply learn we went ahead and updated
our channel art and i'm sure we will
reach 500k we'll update the artwork then
too but the point is you want to keep
your channel art kind of interesting hip
and cool and feel free to change it out
every once in a while so you have that
option in youtube to do i mean it's very
simple so here you can see simply learns
channel we go home get all our videos
listed here we got the about us you know
something very short interesting about
us here's our call to action for more
information visit simply learn so you
want to make sure when you create your
channel get some good artwork in there
put your description and play and create
your first videos and get them posted up
there and optimize them accordingly okay
so some other tips to go with that
channel art and description is a profile
picture relevant to your brand so you
always want to maybe put
the company logo up there okay so here
you can see we have the company logo at
accurate relevant channel keywords so if
we go back to who we are who are we
we're the world's leading certification
training provider okay that's who we are
okay we partner with companies and
individuals so we're all about training
and training is one of our keywords so
you could see at simply learn we provide
online training and machine learning aws
amazon web services devops big data
digital marketing project management a
lot of different topics so make sure
that's included in the channel
description feature the playlist on your
home page so if we go back to the home
page we can see here we have our
channels so you can see we have ai
machine learning trending technologies
cloud computing tutorials dev op
tutorials popular videos big data we
have a lot of different channels so you
want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the home page of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but i
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlist titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and descriptions so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our titles because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos in a
playlist so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that we're maybe putting
the freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the latest in that particular
playlist so they're seeing the most
recent first but you can rearrange your
videos any way you want feel free to
play around with it of course you can
also take the video that's the most
popular and put that up front so people
could see that first vice versa you
could take a video that maybe hasn't
gotten a lot of views or isn't ranked
particularly high maybe put that video
up so it can get some views and some
shares and likes so how you rearrange
your videos is totally up to you just
have some rationale behind that so
choose a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video so for example if i go
back to our youtube page you can see the
top performing videos here you know for
example this one we got a nice thumbnail
here what is machine learning so if i
click on that
most popular videos so 3 000 likes on
this video a lot of views 250 000 plus
views so have a thumbnail to go along
with that particular video so according
to backlinko youtube seo ranking factor
study discovered that channel keywords
have a small yet significant correlation
with higher youtube search rankings so
channel keywords so when you're
optimizing your channel and you want to
include keywords start with your
description so if i go back to our
channel if i go back about us make sure
your description has those relevant
keywords in it that's where it all
starts so in case you have any doubts if
you're not sure about everything we
talked about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to every comment
that gets posted
on our videos so if you're not sure how
to go about optimizing your channel when
you say align keywords with the channel
what does that really mean so if you
want some clarity on that go ahead and
drop us a channel if you're not sure
about the trailer video drop us a
comment we're more than happy to expand
upon the explanation of how to best
optimize your channel okay tip number
five produce high quality videos so we
need to get in the habit of producing
high quality videos because viewers
don't prefer to watch videos that have
poor audio and video quality it's just
that simple you need to know what it
takes to produce high quality videos if
you don't you're just going to discredit
you're not going to come across as
relevant you know i'm going to come
across as qualified professional there's
a lot of things attached to poor quality
videos so we need to
create high quality videos for the end
user so let's talk about some ways in
which you can create high quality videos
and so the first is to avoid any noise
in the background so you want to have a
nice quiet atmosphere no distractions so
people can hear you clearly and only you
clearly you want to use good audio
recording equipment there's plenty of
options available on the internet
usually i would recommend going with
something paid not overly expensive
because you get what you pay for so if
you use something free it might not be
of good quality and you might not have
all the features and bells and whistles
with a free option so you know use good
audio recording equipment again it can
be online or it could be some software
just make sure that you're able to
produce good high quality video and
audio so when you do purchase that audio
recording equipment you want to have
something similar to an input volume
meter that way you can see
whether your audio is coming across or
not so if you're not seeing green lights
then your audio is not coming across if
it's red it might be distorted and so
you want something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good quality audio you want to create
your videos in 10 80 pixel size okay
that's hd and so you want to have at
least minimum 1080. so anything less
than that it's probably gonna come
across as not so good maybe staticky
blurry
not professional not high def so you
want to create a high def video and 1080
is about the minimum you want to go and
then you want to plan your video script
before filming so it goes back to some
of the other points i made earlier you
always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
fly then you want to use good lighting
for video recording so you don't want to
be in a dark place you want some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people could see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professional so if you
can you know shoot a high def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and see the video
as good quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so use slow
motion and jump cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video you know using slow motion and
jump cuts are some of the features you
can use to accentuate your points and
then set up a green background for
recording again this is for you know
making sure that the video part of it
comes across in good quality and
stabilize your video recordings with a
tripod that way you're not moving your
video camera all around and and again
it's coming across as shaky and poor
quality shoot horizontal videos you
don't want to go vertical it tends to
cut the screen so you want to stay
horizontal so that people can see
everything that should be included in
the video okay you want to capture a
wider shot using a clip-on lens again a
good feature a good tip to use use that
wider shot okay so you could do that
using a clip-on lens and then choose
good video editing software i can't
state this enough because you're putting
all this time and effort into a video
you need to be able to edit it to cut
out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say or maybe some poor
quality or or you know you just want to
have a smooth professional output for
your video and so you gotta have good
video editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
i would go with something low-cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high def good quality video and
at the very least review your work
before publishing i just said it a
minute ago i'll say it again you want to
be able to have a really professional
video and high def when you have a good
professional video and high def with
good audio horizontal shots you know
nice green background image nice well
lit it's gonna come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are gonna
take you seriously they're gonna see you
as a professional and then share or
subscribe and like and then they're
gonna watch more videos and and that's
how you start to build up a reputation
as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos so you want to review your work
because if you don't you put all that
effort into it and then you're going to
realize hey your video is low quality
and then you're going to have to do it
all over again so follow these tips get
a high quality video and you should be
on your way to ranking in fact according
to backlinko youtube preferably ranks hd
videos so you got to have that 1080 uh
pixel size that way you know your video
is gonna come across crisp and clear and
youtube prefers that tip six add a
subscriber watermark to your videos so
this is a great feature in youtube so
it's a feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your channel the watermark can be
whatever you want but normally it's
going to be some type of logo or brand
and a call to action and so how do you
add a watermark to your video well you
log into your youtube account it's it's
pretty simple at the top right corner
you're going to select your creator
studio icon and then you're going to go
to channel select branding and then add
a watermark to your video so if we look
at that in youtube so here creator
studio on the left side navigation i'm
just going to click channel then i'm
going to click branding and then once
you click branding you have the ability
to add your watermark and then you can
add it to the entire video at the end of
the video and specific start time and
then just click update and that's pretty
much it so you want to be able to add
this so that you can brand your videos
with an image and then add that cta so
this is a good good feature for youtube
it allows you to be consistent with all
your videos by branding and adding that
call to action tip seven engage with
your audience so you want to be able to
interact with your audience as much as
possible just because the video and you
can't see people doesn't mean you can't
engage with them so when you interact
with your viewers especially when you
interact with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
service is how you really want to look
at this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey a thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of your busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you could thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information because if
they watch the whole video they're
already engaged and they're probably
going to want to learn more so you
always want to follow up to thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with youtube there's a
comment section and you always want to
encourage comments so comments can be in
the form of feedback so as you're
watching this video feel free to leave
feedback on other ways to engage with
your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers on youtube so
we're always looking for those ideas we
want to keep it engaging so somebody may
have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback is always going to be positive
some of the feedback could be less than
positive or even negative there could be
mistakes so the idea behind getting
feedback is you want to look at it you
want to read it and you want to react to
it you want to react to it positively in
the form of you know what thank you for
the feedback and looking at the feedback
weighing it and incorporating the
feedback so you don't always want to
make the same mistake twice in a video
so if there's something definitely wrong
with the video that we're doing for
example and somebody looked at it and
gave us feedback on it we'd certainly
definitely take a deep look into that
and try not to do the same mistake twice
because likely that user is going to
watch the video again so you always want
to learn from your mistakes and you want
to turn those mistakes or turn those
comments into future videos okay so
create videos based on your commenter's
request the audience is giving us
feedback we should take that as positive
and sometimes that's creative sometimes
those ideas for more videos okay you
always want to ask questions to your
audience and reward excellent commenters
so we try to ask questions in our videos
and when users respond with the answer
if there's an excellent comment or
excellent answer you know we can reward
them you know reward them in the form of
say some type of gift card or gift
certificate or promotion or something
there's always some way to incentivize
somebody who provides excellent feedback
you can always give emoji hearts there's
so many emojis out there that you can
use emojis just to engage with your
audience based on the feedback that
they're giving the point is if your
audience has taken the time to give
feedback you always want to respond to
it and you want to respond to a positive
so emojis tend to have a positive
connotation to them and so responding
with an emoji especially to a favorite
comment goes a long way so you can
reward your community both on and off
youtube for their engagement and support
and that's just being creative you can
reward in many ways many ways not
necessarily monetarily but by
recognition you could do promotions you
could do something fun there's always
ways to reward and prefer to host live
streams and interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
youtube has them other platforms like
facebook have them instagram so you can
certainly reach out to your audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience right there in
the flesh so when you can have an
opportunity to talk to your audience and
engage with them that's always going to
work because they can see personality
they can see what you're all about and
there's two-way conversation and so that
will lend to more of a you know
relationship so to speak with your
audience so you want to create videos
for subscribers his subscribers can get
impressed when a channel dedicates a
video for them so you know take the time
out to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most likely going to engage with you
okay they're your loyal fan fanbase so
if you create something for them that's
a form of a reward so you can captivate
your viewers by uploading interesting
youtube stories as well you can also
hear from your audience and get their
videos and use their videos and upload
them to your channel so according to
backlinko video comments have a very
strong correlation with rankings so as
you create a video feel free to talk to
your audience and ask them hey if you
have any comments feel free to put them
in the comment section right below this
video i see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and i'm going to ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see about rewarding
the audience or engaging with the
audience feel free to comment we'd love
to get your suggestions because if you
can engage with the audience even more
then that's only going to net positive
results not only in rankings but with
your subscriber base so comments are the
way to go solicit comments respond to
the comments reward the comments tip
number eight promote your videos on
different platforms so promoting your
videos on different platforms has been
around for many years it's a good
strategy once you create your video on
youtube you want people to see it you
want to get it out there so if you want
to increase your youtube subscribers
this is a strategy you have to perform
so let's take a look at all the ways you
can use and leverage different platforms
to increase your subscribers so before
you do that you want to research
discover how and
you can use different platforms so the
first thing you want to do is look at
the platforms you're already using if
you're using facebook and instagram
that's probably a good place to start
but there's other platforms you can also
leverage and we're going to talk about
those so social media most companies
most individuals are on in some form or
fashion amongst the most popular like
facebook and instagram so you can start
there so with facebook you can post
something include the link of your
youtube video with facebook if you're a
business you have a business page you're
communicating with your community and
that's a great way to get started by
promoting your youtube video you can
also do the same on twitter or instagram
or whatever platform you're on go ahead
and post something or tweet something
and include that link to youtube you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions so there's plenty of forums
and blogs out there where you can
participate in discussion and include a
link to the youtube video if it's
relevant and natural so for example here
there's a blog about machine learning
you can include if you have a video
about machine learning in the response
to that conversation in this example
we've done that on reddit you can list
your video in relevant and reputable
directories there's plenty of
directories out there there's plenty of
video directories okay that you can just
go ahead and publish your video on you
can use testimonial link building okay
so somebody can provide a testimonial
include the link of your video you can
opt for influencer marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here tessgenics okay there's a article
here about you know certificate of
achievements okay for aws so if you
scroll down we could see our video is
included here in this particular web
page so this is a high quality web page
okay that's generating a backlink for us
not only is it generating a backlink
it's also generating traffic and
awareness for the video go ahead and
find out if there's any websites that
are relevant to your video topic and see
if you can collaborate with them on
producing a web page to include that
video you can also take advantage of
email marketing by adding your youtube
link in the email signature for example
it's a simple email any email client
like gmail or yahoo or even hotmail or
outlook is going to have an ability to
or give you the ability to add a
signature in the signature you could
simply just include a link to the video
or to your youtube channel it doesn't
have to be do a specific video but it's
a way to get people to your youtube page
or to that video so the whole idea is
more eyeballs more potential subscribers
engage your audience by posting your
video links on community pages so for
example you know we're promoting
something here on a community page and
that's going to get some additional
traffic over to us you can always
bookmark your videos on bookmarking
sites like stumbledupon.com again this
is free very little time to do this but
it's a chance for you to get the video
out there and even generate a backlink
you can collaborate with other youtube
channels this is always a good strategy
if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on youtube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily a competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their channel
and you can take their video and put it
on your channel in a particular playlist
okay so that's a way to collaborate with
other youtube channels is swap videos
you could join high pr qa sites and post
answers to the questions related to your
video like core is always a good example
or e-hop okay so core there's always a
question being posted and if you have
the answer to that question in the form
of your video then go ahead and post a
response with a link to the video on
youtube it's a great way to get the
video noticed and it's relevant and
natural okay you can embed videos in
your blog post so if you're using a
platform like wordpress for example very
easy to go ahead and just take that
video you can even just put the link in
the blog post i like this option i think
blog posts are always good because you
don't have to be text heavy with a blog
post you want to create a blog post
that's nice and balanced with an image
and text but if you put a video to
support your blog post that goes even
further and blog posts themselves can be
engaging and interactive with your
audience so having a video in your blog
post always goes well in my opinion okay
so you can promote other videos in your
end screen for example at the end of
your video you can always promote
something related like we've done here
in this example so lots of ideas get
your video out there use them in email
use them in your blog post go to free
bookmarking sites like stumbleupon you
know collaborate with other people on
youtube you know go to core respond to a
question use social media to your
advantage there's lots of opportunities
to get your video out there the more you
can get your video out there the more
traffic you're gonna get the more
traffic you get to the video the more
subscribers you're going to get so
that's how the game is played in order
to get your video out there but these
are relatively you know low time
consuming ideas to get your video if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so with twitter it's all about tweets
it's actually a verb now uh when you do
something on twitter you actually tweet
and there are a lot of people out there
tweeting in fact twitter has over 1.3
billion accounts so
a lot of tweets going on in the world of
twitter so as of the third quarter in
2018 last year twitter had 326 million
global monthly active users okay so
active meaning every day using the
platform on a daily basis so a lot of
people using twitter it's very easy to
use as you'll find out and what you're
going to find out today is how to
increase followers on your twitter
account so they can see more of your
tweets okay a little bit more about
twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information being
disseminated across the platform so
tweets with videos so twitter does a lot
of videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so
if you watched our youtube videos and
some of the other videos we had out
there regarding facebook or instagram
you'll know that videos do perform
better twitter is no exception so if you
have a video even if it's done on
youtube or if it's not unpublished on
youtube use it with twitter you're gonna
get more engagement so twitter has 75
percent of its users use the platform
for news okay so people go to twitter to
get their news that's where they go they
don't go to
a regular website content based website
they get their news via twitter it's
just very easy to digest because it's so
few characters 75
of b2b businesses market on twitter so
not only is it a b2c or business to
consumer platform it's a b2b business to
business platform so a lot of businesses
are on twitter
basically promoting either a product
service or trying to establish
themselves in the industry using the
platform so let's take a look at twitter
and let's take a look at some of the
ways in which you can increase your
followers it all starts with your
profile you always want to make sure you
have a complete profile your name
obviously the twitter platform that you
have is going to have a handle okay in
this example here it's a totally real
person at totally real person is the
twitter handle and that's what you're
going to want to use to disseminate your
twitter profile to others so you want to
make sure that you have a good image you
have a real name and a good handle that
people can associate with and remember
so you want to be able to set up this
profile with a keyword friendly bio okay
a link to your website and a picture
that represents your brand always helps
so make sure it's complete you can even
take a step further by customizing the
color scheme of your profile you can add
a header image that sticks to your theme
that will help your profile stand out
and so let's take a look at an example
here so if i go to twitter here if we go
to simply learn twitter account okay
their handle is simply at simply learn
okay they've customized the header they
use their logo now if you're an
individual you probably want to use a
nice profile pic here where they're
based a little bit about them so just a
you know customized complete profile
goes a long way you don't have to go
overboard with an elaborate design so to
speak but just make it stand out make it
associate with who you are as a person
and a brand those are best practices in
getting that profile up and running you
don't want to use something bland and
generic you know take the extra step
create something unique make sure your
profile is unique you have a good image
okay make sure it's complete with you
know telling people who you are and what
you're all about that's really the first
step on really any social media platform
so
you want to promote your twitter profile
to drive users from other social media
platforms so when you actually get that
twitter account set up and you actually
do have your handle go ahead and share
it that's the first step in getting
followers if you're already on facebook
if you're already on instagram then use
those platforms to announce that you're
on twitter you can also take that a step
further and you know send out an email
to friends or family or like i said if
you're on facebook go ahead and set up a
post say hey guys i'm on twitter you
know come follow me so you could also
use business cards advertisements
marketing materials events to put that
twitter profile on okay so it doesn't
have to be within the social media
sphere it could be even on your website
it can be even in email so you can
basically promote that profile again you
want to make that profile that handle
easy to remember so totally real person
is the profile on this example we're
going to use that profile everywhere we
can whether that be offline or online
you don't don't be afraid to use it on a
business card especially if it's easy i
can just simply go to twitter and type
in that handle so you want to stay
active on twitter with regular retweets
replies and favorites and that's just
it's just so easy to retweet and reply
and add favorites so let's take a look
at that on twitter so you could just
simply i'm logged in as me and if i want
to retweet something that simply learn
did i can just simply click on the
retweet button and i can add a comment
if i want to and then i'm going to
retweet that simple so now
that tweet is going to show up on my
profile my handle and i could simply
like it if i scroll down here okay top
10 it trends shaping 2019 notice a
simple tweet supported with an image so
i'm just gonna like that so i can even
comment on it i can click on the comment
and click a reply here okay and that's
gonna show up in this tweet here just
like if i click on this i'll be able to
see what other people have written and
so it's that simple if i want i can just
click on the email button it's even send
a message to somebody right from that
tweet the point is i can do everything i
need to do right in the platform but to
get started if you don't have any tweets
you know go and find other companies
similar to you look at their tweeting
and you can always retweet that that's a
good way to get going with tweets that's
what i started doing when i started on
twitter in 2008 i didn't know what to
write particularly and i didn't know how
to write it particularly well so i
looked at what other people wrote and
and tweeted and just retweeted those
that's a good way to get your twitter
account started okay so engaging with
users is a great way to get more
followers so on simplylearn i retweeted
one of their tweets i liked another one
of their tweets and it's probably gonna
get their attention somebody at simply
learn is gonna say okay rob sanders
went ahead and liked us and you know
what we're gonna go follow this guy he
seems to be
somebody who's an audience member who
likes what we have to do likes what we
have to say like what we're tweeting
let's go ahead and follow him and so
that's a good way to get going with your
twitter account is to really start
retweeting and liking other tweets from
other users so you can find an
appropriate time to post your tweets to
increase exposure retweets and followers
and you want to do this you could do it
within twitter or as i'll mention later
you can do it in a social media platform
like sprout social or hootsuite or later
or buffer and there's plenty of social
media platforms out there for you to
schedule tweets point is you want to be
able to schedule those tweets
when it's the appropriate time so you
don't want to do it in the middle of the
evening because what's going to happen
is
likely by the morning other tweets are
going to bury your tweet so you want to
be able to find the appropriate time to
post your tweets so according to a
survey conducted by hubspot the best
time to post is between 12 and 3 p.m and
why is that well most people are usually
on lunch checking their phones yes
twitter has an app and in fact most
people use the app just like on
instagram just like on youtube the app
is very popular on twitter so it's very
easy for somebody to check tweets
especially during the lunch hour and
then from five to six pm that that in
between time when when people are
wrapping up work or heading home okay so
weekdays have shown to have the maximum
amount of engagement so during the week
when people are working highly engaged
with whatever they're doing depending on
what industry you're in they're likely
going to
check the twitter and react during those
times okay so that was a survey
conducted by hubspot but really what you
want to do is you want to be able to use
one of these social media platforms like
a hootsuite or later and find out
exactly when are people engaging with
your tweets when what time of the day
what day of the week are you getting the
most retweets or the most likes okay
that's what you want to do so you can
use this as a starting point as a best
practice but eventually you're going to
have to cater to your audience based on
when you're getting your tweets engaged
so you want to increase followers by
following more people it's that simple
and so it really is that simple let me
rephrase that so it really is that
simple so if i go back to twitter you
know twitter's always going to recommend
somebody for me to follow and normally
those are people that are similar as
myself okay so they're not just going to
choose random people they're going to
choose people who are following people
you're following so there's going to be
a connection to some degree or they
could be people who use similar hashtags
tweeting the same content so you want to
go ahead and
follow people the rule of thumb on
twitter is if you follow somebody on
twitter chances are they're going to
follow you back you know i was once told
when i was using twitter that hey you
want to give somebody about three days
to follow you back so that's always what
the rule i stuck to you know wait about
three days start following people
you can see here 833 people that or
accounts twitter accounts that simply
learns following and over 10
900 followers to simply learn's twitter
account so for me i don't mind having a
nice balance myself i have just as many
followers as i do following and that's a
good thing so because you want to be
able to keep up with what people are
tweeting and so you can retweet at the
same time you want to be following
people as well because they're going to
follow you back okay and that's how you
can build up your twitter followers by
following people and it's as simple as
clicking on a follow link so the key
here is to follow people who follow your
content people who are followers of your
followers and you can use twitter's who
to follow list and upload your email
contacts to twitter okay since they know
you they're more likely to follow you
back okay so you can use twitter's who
to follow list and so if we go back to
twitter here's the who to follow list
and so this is what twitter is going to
recommend but you can click on this link
here find people you know okay so if i
click on find people i know then i can
upload my contacts from outlook or gmail
and they're gonna find people who are
already on twitter based on who i'm
connected with so generally that's how
it works that's a quick way to get more
followers is to connect with people you
know by the way i'm gonna follow simply
learn because i wasn't following them
prior so now i just clicked on the
follow button now i am following so now
i'm gonna see simply learns tweets in my
feed so let's take a second to look at a
brand okay so it's time for brand watch
let's have a look at some of the best
tweets of 2018. now remember there are a
lot of active users millions of active
users that's a lot of tweets so what we
did was we scoured twitter from 2018 and
we went ahead and picked out some tweets
that we thought were pretty good and so
the first one is wendy's now i don't
know if any of you have actually eaten
at wendy's i used to eat at wendy's a
while ago i know their frosties are
pretty good so
what they've done is they incorporated
that frosty as part of a giveaway okay
so basically they're saying hey grab
yourself a free frosty with any purchase
in our app so they're encouraging people
to use our app and then they're
following that up by saying hey and then
join us on twitch from two to five
eastern as we unlock all that frosty
goodness so they're promoting something
that's going to happen on a specific
point in time this is last january
they're encouraging people to use their
app and they're using that frosty as
kind of a carrot if you will okay it's a
catch it's a giveaway so they were able
to you know basically wrap a bunch of
things into one so get encourage people
to take part and i'm sure a lot of
people went ahead and took part of this
but we could definitely see that 206
retweeted this tweet 302 basically
commented on it and over 3 000 liked the
tweet so the tweet was good and it
basically engaged with users who doesn't
like a free giveaway especially free
frosty so that's why this particular
tweet really does some justice for the
target audience their audience they're
they're giving something away to their
audience just by allowing them to you
know user app okay so this tweet
combines a lot into one and i like it
apparently a lot more people than i did
3000 plus also like this tweet and so
moving on to how to increase your
followers on twitter you want to mention
other people in your tweets to increase
engagement so what do we mean by that so
let's look at twitter so go back if we
look at simplylearn just take a look at
some of their tweets what they're doing
if we scroll down here they have
hashtags so they are mentioning specific
hashtags but you can also mention
handles as well so the hashtag is always
going to start with you the pound sign
but if we scroll down here if you use
the at symbol you're actually mentioning
somebody so in this case we're
mentioning matt bailey so matt bailey
says is matt bailey's handle and so if
you get a shout out to somebody they're
gonna pick up on that and then they're
going to probably follow you okay who
doesn't appreciate getting recognized
for something especially something as
small as a tweet okay notice i can go
ahead and click follow if i want to
follow him out bailly but it's not a bad
idea to add people into your tweet and
you simply do that by just using the ad
symbol and using their twitter handle
it's a good way to get recognized by
that twitter follower it also increases
engagement because it's adding validity
to the tweet and it definitely catches
the attention of the person mentioned
remember if you use that person's handle
they're going to see that that you
mention them okay and what it's likely
gonna do is start some type of twitter
relationship okay they're gonna then
follow you you're gonna follow them and
chances of them retweeting you in the
future or mentioning you in the future
is probably going to increase and
overall that increases engagement so
another important thing you want to do
is find and use hashtags that are
relevant to your brand and audience so
this is a must this is mandatory on
twitter you need to use hashtags
twitter's all about hashtags every tweet
that goes out should have a hashtag okay
so what you can do is figure out what
hashtags are trending so here what
twitter does is they trends for you so
these are all specific hashtags that are
trending it's mother's day happy mother
hey sunday morning whatever works for
you these are trends that happen to be
moving meaning a lot of people are using
them clicking on them okay so you can
use a popular hashtag what i would also
recommend is using a unique hashtag the
rule of thumb is usually about two
hashtags in a tweet but that's a rule of
thumb but rules are made to be broken do
what's best for you if you want to
include more than two hashtags go for it
the only thing i'm recommending is
include a hashtag so find out which
trending you could just look right in
twitter or you could just create your
own unique hashtag it works both ways
but when you have a hashtag in your
tweet and somebody clicks on it then
they're going to go to that particular
handle that hashtag and so when they
look at the hashtag you're gonna see all
the tweets with that hashtag in it so
that's the idea behind hashtags you want
to have hashtags okay so if somebody
clicks on a hashtag that you used then
they're likely going to see your tweet
in that hashtag speed okay so that's how
hashtags work you want to use hashtags
okay but you want to use hashtags that
are relevant to your brand and audience
that's really the key so hashtags help
your tweets to be found through twitter
search thus improving your reach and
increase the visibility of your post so
that's another benefit twitter has
search functionality so somebody can
simply go in and start searching on
twitter so if i go back to twitter i can
just do a hashtag
and start typing in something like
spanish and i'm gonna get some of the
most popular spanish hashtags or
hashtags with the word spanish in it and
so this is an idea for me that if i
wanted to use a hashtag with spanish in
it these are some ideas but they're
certainly searchable on twitter okay so
if i just click on spanish okay i'm
gonna be able to see all the hashtags
with the word spanish in the hashtag so
definitely use hashtags it's the most
beneficial feature of twitter bar none
so some reasons why using hashtags also
a good idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team in the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know i work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if i wanted to be just like
simply learn well i could simply just go
to their twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtag see what kind of tweets
they're implementing and see who's
following them so i can simply just
click on the 10
900 followers that they have and what i
could do is i can go through and start
following the people that are following
them so just mimic your competition to
some degree or mimic others in the
industry you know look at what they're
tweeting again start out by retweeting
some of the stuff they're retweeting if
it's good stuff if it's a good tweet
don't be afraid to retweet even your
competitors tweets okay use unique
hashtags use the hashtags they're using
look at who's following their brand so
you can really learn a lot from
others in your industry including your
competition because what works for them
again might work for you especially when
it comes to hashtags or people who's
following them again people who are
following them would likely follow you
if you're in the same industry so it's
as simple as looking at who's following
them and following those same people
remember the rule of thumb is if you're
following somebody they're likely to
follow you back so again you can analyze
things like the number of followers they
have the frequency of their tweets what
their profile looks like how they
respond to the competition of customers
okay what are they tweeting about what
types of content brings them more
engagement meaning of all the tweets
which one is getting the most likes or
retweets get some sense of what they're
doing and again when i say mimic i mean
what i'm saying is pull best practices
from that twitter account this will give
you an idea what you need to do to get
more followers so it's always a good
form of flattery when you can mimic what
somebody else is doing just like every
other social media platform following
twitter influencers who belong in your
industry is always a good idea so if
you're in the food industry and there's
these star chefs out there probably not
a bad idea to follow those star chefs
you know if you're in the technology
industry well probably not a bad idea to
you know follow bill gates or elon musk
or richard branson or somebody else and
that's a big influencer has an influence
on a lot of people okay but make sure
they're in your industry that's the key
if you can make sure they're in your
industry and you follow them chances are
if they look at your twitter account and
see you're posting or maybe retweeting
some of their tweets they're likely to
follow you and if they're following you
your tweets are gonna show up on their
handle on their feed and so don't be
afraid to go out and connect and follow
those influencers it's a good way to
boost up your followers so and this will
help you gain followers since you can
replicate what they've done with their
profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influencers so you're
all of one like mind so to speak okay
influencers might retweet or share your
post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their post so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from simply learn so
if i click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that matt bailey was at so it was a
retweet from matt bailey as a matter of
fact but you can see what simply learns
doing is they're including either a
video or they're including an image in
every tweet and so that's likely to
boost up engagement so according to
buffer which is a another social media
platform adding a relevant high quality
image in your tweets can help you gain
more than 150
engagement okay videos are six times
more likely to be retweeted so if you
have an arsenal video or even one video
don't be afraid to use it my
recommendation is trying to use images
as much as you can in almost every tweet
images go a long way and again it's
going to help improve engagement meaning
more retweets more followers okay more
followers more eyeballs so it's a
snowball effect just by using images
okay so let's take a look at another
brand from 2018 okay pizza always my
good example to use on these webinars i
like pizza here this just says it all
you know they're talking about art and
they're using pizza in the form of art
so they didn't really have to say much
else here this pretty much says it all
and they did get some retweets to get
some just some likes so sometimes you
don't have to say a lot to make your
point sometimes just the image itself
will do the job this was actually not
from 2018 this goes all the way back to
2016. so still holds true if you use an
image that image is going to get
engagement okay so on twitter just like
most other social media platforms you
can promote your tweet so you can use
twitter ads to do that so you can
promote your tweet and what you do by
promoting it is putting it up above so
that most people will be able to see it
okay so see if we can find an example if
i go here i could see this person is
promoting their handle but if i go down
here i can see a promoted tweet by
constant contact so they're promoting
their tweet here so it's not a bad idea
if you have some media budget to go
ahead and either promote your tweet or
advertise on twitter so what that's
going to do their website and so the
whole idea when you advertise on twitter
is really just like any other social
media platform you want to put yourself
in front of the right audience and so
twitter's no exception so with twitter
you could put yourself in front of the
right audience so what you could do is
you could promote a tweet you know do
promoted trends or you could do promoted
accounts so you have a number of
different advertising options on twitter
what we just looked at was
you know looking at promoted accounts
and a promoted tweet so when you do
advertise there are advantages you have
to pay only after achieving your
marketing objective so that's a benefit
of twitter the cost per click it's a
cost per click model so it tends to be
fairly low you could tell your audience
so again you're picking and choosing who
you want your promoted tweet or trend or
account to be in front of and it's
targeting is based on either engagement
or it's based on keywords i.e hashtags
so really you could tailor who you want
your tweet or your handle to be in front
of and so that's the really the benefit
of twitter if you have a lot of active
users on twitter you can really put
yourself in front of those active users
if they're your relevant audience at a
low cost per click so it's definitely
worth the test so you want to offer
twitter support to your users okay so i
can't stress this enough okay so what
you want to do is when users have
questions about your product they're
more likely to tweet you for support
hence they're likely to follow your
account so don't be afraid to use the
messaging option as well so if we go
back to twitter okay chances are
somebody might have a question for you
here you can look at big ads it's great
connecting with ppc experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is they're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
in the form of customer service so don't
be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your twitter
follow account these bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying of twitter
followers you want to build your twitter
following naturally twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of bot accounts that were paid to follow
users were shut down shut down by
twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of okay if you want to
pay for something pay for a promoted
tweet reach out to influencers look at
what your competition is doing use
hashtags okay these are all best
practices and organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve bots
and adding thousands of followers to
your twitter account because chances are
it's just going to lead to no engagement
so create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do retweet
retweet what somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want to tweet
so you want it to be useful and relevant
to your industry okay you want somebody
to engage that's the whole idea behind
twitter the whole idea is if you're
going to tweet something you want to get
somebody to engage with it so use
twitter polls your old recent blog post
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories i mean all of
those are ideas that you can do to put
content out there okay so for me one of
the things i do is i'm definitely one
for industry news so if i'm in the
industry of digital marketing if google
did a recent algorithm update i'm going
to likely tweet about it or retweet it i
also am a blogger so on my particular
website if i blog i'm going to make sure
that blog gets over to twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
twitter account you definitely want to
get that content out there but you want
to make it useful and relevant quality
over quantity because you want people to
engage so bring variety to the type of
content you share so i'm in digital
marketing i deal with pay-per-click seo
but am i going to just do pay-per-click
and seo no i know that analytics i know
that you know google tag manager i know
that av testing all of those are
elements of digital marketing so i'm
going to branch out and talk about some
of those things that support digital
marketing so that's an example of
bringing variety to the type of content
you share so don't just stick to one
thing you know feel free to reach out a
little bit shake things up by sharing
other forms of updates like engaging
quotes and questions these work best
when complemented by an image and an act
as a great discussion starter so good
point here even if you want to branch
out of your industry and just throw in a
nice useful quote it's always a good way
to gain some attention and get some
engagement okay let's look at another
brand and see what they've tweeted about
so we're looking at forester here so
think about emotional qualities and
their implications so here you can see
customers that feel surprised or
grateful or appreciated they're sharing
that insight with you and so this was
interesting when i saw this so what i
did was i simply you see the hashtag
here for digital basically if you wanna
look at this particular study i just
went to twitter and i typed in that
hashtag and now i'm gonna be able to see
you know some of the other studies that
they've done here you can see top ten i
teach friends shaping 2019 so i'm just
following the twitter handle that they
used so forrester does a lot of good
research a lot of good insights and so
what they've done here that makes this
tweet look so good is they've actually
put an image of the results in the tweet
so they used an image to help gain
engagement or increase engagement notice
they also gave a shout out to somebody
as well as use some good hashtagging so
good tweet this was back in 2016 but
again a good use of the image with the
tweet so you want to organize tweet
chats to interact with your users and
bring in new followers so you know you
basically want to be organized when
you're dealing with chats so tweet chats
enable you send out tweets on a
particular topic using a designated
hashtag so during a certain time to
interact with your your followers and
other users so you could do it at a
specific time to really get out a
specific topic but you want to be able
to stay organized so that you know you
what you're chatting about is reaching
the wider audience and you're getting
the right following and the right
engagement okay you can also pin your
best updates and tweets to your profile
so you can just use that pin and what
that's going to do is pin it to the top
and keep it there so that you know
people who go to your twitter handle are
going to be able to see that best tweet
that you've done so what you want to do
here is use the one that's most engaging
so pinning your best update or tweet
meaning the one that's really had a lot
of engagement meaning retweets and
followers and likes you want to do that
you want to pin that to your profile and
that will enable first-time visitors to
see it and if they could see something
that other people engage with and that's
going to encourage them to share and
probably follow you so and and that's
always what you want to do you always
want to put your best foot forward so
pin your best tweet to your profile so i
mentioned this earlier use tools to
schedule when to publish your tweets so
here are some of the most popular
platforms you know i use sprout social
so if we take a look at sprout social
here i'm in sprout social i'm connected
to my twitter account i can simply just
start tweeting about something here so
you can see it's gonna let me know how
many characters i have remaining so to
180 to start out with when i'm done
tweeting notice i can add an emoji i can
upload media i can tag a specific
location okay i can even you know call
out a specific twitter profile now i can
schedule this myself or i can use the
schedule below i can pick and choose a
time to schedule the tweet now again you
want to be able to use the sprout social
whatever social media tool you're using
two
figure out when the best time of day and
the day of the week to actually tweet
when are you getting the best engagement
so ideally that's what you want to do
you want to tweet when you're likely to
get the best engagement when those
eyeballs are actually going to look at
that tweet okay but you also want to
separate out your tweets so they're not
on one on top of another because if you
actually tweet back to back then those
tweets are just going to get buried so
if you spread them out a little bit then
you're likely to maximize your number of
impressions or eyeballs on that tweet so
if you schedule a tweet multiple tweets
in the same day then post them a few
hours apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you in not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just sprout
social hootsuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule posts to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaged
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to fine-tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with wendy's is run
contests or giveaways remember rendy's
gave away that free frosty you don't be
afraid to give away something if it
means more engagement more eyeballs
which could lead to basically future
customers so contest can help increase
your reach and exposure and each new
participant can be considered as a
potential follower so it also gives your
followers an opportunity to tag their
friends who would be interested in
participating so really come up this is
a great way to be creative come up with
a good idea to get your your audience
involved because what's likely going to
happen is your audience is going to
share this contest with others that
aren't following you and so what's going
to happen is when they share it you're
going to get more followers you're going
to get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that uh it's very simple
but when you do then people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if i just go to my website here if i
scroll down we actually have your
twitter embedded on our website as well
because we want you know people to see
what we're tweeting about and you can
see i just retweeted the simply learn
tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
in my feed here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what i retweeted and that's
going to help simply learn out because
simply learn is likely to get some
clicks on this particular tweet from my
website so it's also a good way to keep
your website fresh and updated because
if you're an active twitter user and
you're tweeting a lot then hey that's
gonna show up on your website and it's
gonna show that hey you're fresh you're
engaging you keep up to date it's just
going to make it look good and make your
website feel fresh and not stale so
embedding your twitter updates will help
you add new followers as well because
it's people who are coming to your
website that may not even know you have
a twitter account so you can also do
this in a blog post and a newsletter and
other forms of communication media so it
doesn't necessarily have to be just your
website but i would definitely recommend
it because it will give a boost to your
twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention and this is from playstation
so playstation is mentioning hey we got
a multi-view on apple tv today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have
with playstation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically saying hey look what
happened to us today you know check out
this new feature that got supported on
apple tv so you never know what's gonna
happen with a tweet when you tweet good
things are likely gonna happen whether
that be somebody liking it retweeting it
or somebody adding you as a follower
something good is going to come out of
tweeting twitter is an easy platform to
use and if you take into account all
these best practices you are going to
increase your twitter followers today
we're going to talk about how to
increase instagram followers today's
webinar we're going to have some tips
and best practices for you to take
advantage of to increase instagram
followers so let's get started and talk
a little bit about instagram so
instagram is not really an up-and-coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users in fact 500 million daily
active instagram users 500 million daily
the user base growth of more than 300
year over year so it's growing and
growing and growing it's become more and
more popular ever since it's launched
back in 2010 and then there's more than
100 million photos uploaded daily so
it's a platform where you can upload
photos tag those photos even use and
implement videos and photos have become
very popular with the advent of mobile
technology that the instagram app makes
it easy for you to post your photo so
there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's a
hundred million photos plus uploaded
daily and then there are 400 million
stories posted daily so when you post
something you can create a story out of
it and there's 400 million of those per
day and then there's more than 50
billion photos shared to date so since
2010 platform nat which is now owned by
facebook has become really really
popular a good place for you if you have
your own company if you have your own
brand if you have your own products it's
a good place for you to really showcase
that service that product that brand
because of the user base how easy it is
to use and the wide reach it has for you
in which to tell your story so i
mentioned there are lots of photos
shared today close to seven billion
dollars revenue generated through
instagram mobile so on top of everything
i just said there's a lot of e-commerce
going on here too so instagram is a
platform in which there's e-commerce
integrated within the platform so as a
business who offers up products you can
actually generate revenue for yourself
on the flip side instagram which is
owned by facebook has an opportunity to
sell advertising spaces instagram so
instagram is an ecommerce platform to
say the least in fact instagram is
because it's so popular because it's
part of facebook's advertising platform
they're more than two million
advertisers on instagram so amongst all
those stories videos and photos and
hashtags you'll see some ads and then
because you'll see ads because you'll
see users you're gonna see businesses
it's just good place to really set up
shop and really tell your story through
the world of photos and videos so 25
million plus businesses have already
migrated over to instagram and that's
growing and growing and growing so it's
an opportunity for you to work with
other businesses so the arrow is
definitely pointing up on instagram
there's a lot going on here easy to use
application especially when it comes to
photos and videos so we're gonna go
through some tips and tricks today and
we're gonna talk about everything there
is to know about instagram and how to
increase your followers so let's take a
look at tip one here so because
instagram is an application everything
you do on it is through the application
now you could certainly view a web page
version on it but you really can't do
much out of that so if i go to my
instagram account for example using my
desktop i could see my profile and i can
edit my profile to a degree but
everything you're doing is through the
application so when it comes to that tip
one here is take advantage of your bio
so regardless of what industry you are
you're in who you are you really want to
have a clear and concise and compelling
bio why because this is your
introduction to the world you want
people to know who you are and because
if you don't really become very clear to
people they're not going to follow you
so this is where it all starts you need
to take advantage of your bio have a
clear and concise bio and have a link to
your website or some contact information
so to me this is where it all starts you
gotta have a bio because that's what
people are gonna look at and they're
gonna decide whether to follow you or
not based on primarily that bio that's
where it all starts so make sure you
have a good bio that's tip number one so
you'll have to make sure that your
landing page is also mobile optimized
since most instagram users are on mobile
so if you're going to put a link to your
website and somebody's on the instagram
app and they see your bio and they like
it and you have a link to your website
make sure that lanny page they go to is
mobile optimized so tip number two
everything you do on instagram when it
comes to posting evolves around hashtags
so that's the backbone of the platform
just like most platforms out there
social media platforms like twitter or
facebook pinterest you're gonna have
hashtags accompany those posts so
instagram is no different but in this
case you really really want to take
advantage of the hashtag so hashtags are
there to help users find your content so
you want to start out by using hashtags
that are relevant to your business so if
you're in the food industry you're gonna
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags that describe your brand and
also are being searched on instagram so
what does that mean that means do a
little bit of homework on instagram you
know see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement but it may not help
with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested followers and
sales so here really what i'm trying to
say is look pick and choose your
hashtags carefully because if you use
something broad or something
non-relevant yeah you may get that click
to your instagram page but that doesn't
necessarily mean somebody's going to
follow you or that doesn't mean really
mean somebody's going to be interested
in what you have to offer so if you use
something really popular and broad yes
you're going to get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time so according to sprout
social which is a social media
scheduling platform among other things
so they deal with a lot of people using
their platform and posting content via
their platform they have data and
they're telling us based on the data
they've collected that the best time to
post is between 2 and 3 p.m and the best
day to post is thursday now that may be
all fine and true according to a sprout
social study and so you may want to go
with this 2 to 3 p.m and this is
probably local in case you're wondering
what time zone we're referring to so
this is all local to you so go ahead and
try that out try two to three pm on
thursday the thing is what you're gonna
have to do eventually is figure out what
the best time to post is okay so if
you're pointing out a lot of content and
you're putting out content throughout
the week at certain times of the day or
throughout the day you're gonna have to
determine which time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post at what
point of the day what day of the week
and so you're gonna really have to lean
on a social media platform to help you
determine that because they're gonna
have the data that you need to determine
what the best time of day to post is
okay so we'll talk about social media
platforms here shortly we just know that
when you post post with some rationale
in mind ask yourself before you even
push that publish button or before you
even schedule that post this time a day
in this day of the week makes sense so
you always want to post at the right
time because you could be missing your
audience so remember when you do this
you're going to be working with some
platform and instagram also has some
analytics for business accounts so
instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here so steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people the
more you stand to gain from them so you
could see who your competitors followers
are and you can add them as a follower
just by following them so start engaging
with them if they're liking your
competitor's brand then what the chance
of them liking your brand could be great
so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted engage with them okay it doesn't
take that much time it's a good way to
gain followers so if we're on instagram
we can simply just click on the brand's
followers so here i can see this brand
has 127 followers and here i can see all
the followers and what i could do is
simply just click on one of the
followers and i can go to their profile
and from there i could see
what they've posted in terms of videos
and images and i can like or comment so
just doing something as simple as this
gets you an opportunity to engage with
somebody who can then turn around and
follow you so tip five pay for sponsored
posts and product reviews so a number of
ways you could do this here so pay for a
sponsored post so you could find an
influencer satisfies a couple of
requirements they have large following
and an email address in the profile so
you can connect with them and ask them
for sponsored post pricing so it's as
simple as that as reaching out to
somebody who has a large following okay
so if you do this then it's going to put
you in front of a large number of people
and so by doing this it'll help expose
your brand to that larger audience and
help build your cr credibility because
you're connecting with somebody who has
a large audience as well so do a little
bit of homework find people out there in
your industry who has a large following
and make sure they have that email
address in their profile so you can
contact them and when you contact them
you know ask them for sponsored post
pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shout out so that's
the key so they gotta have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
posts okay you wanna get yourself out
there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location city or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where are you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you so tip seven
use instagram stories to attract
followers and grow your user base a
story's a really big feature on
instagram so what stories could be used
for is just show footage of an
environment so it could be your office
it could be your home it could be you
know the playground it could be the golf
course it could be anywhere that you
want to show vintage of so you want to
post new relevant to your industry so if
you're in the food industry hey why not
go in the back into the kitchen and post
a story about how a particular bread or
cake is made okay show off your product
so if you are in that food industry and
say you're in the pizza making business
perfect opportunity to show people via
an instagram story how to make that
pizza and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use how unique is your
particular product and that's really
what you want to get across when you do
a story you want to show something
unique and relevant that's going to
grasp people's attention you can promote
a company event so if you're celebrating
say 200 000 subscribers create a youtube
video or you can create an instagram
story it works just as well so you can
endorse your company's blog posts you
can post positive user reviews so these
are all features of a story increase
interactivity with polls sliders etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
instagram stories is a really big
feature with instagram check it out you
know you can just do a search for
instagram stories in fact let's get some
of you users involved what best
practices do you have when creating
instagram stories why don't you go ahead
and share your instagram story with us
by putting that instagram story in the
comment section below so we want to get
everybody involved here because there's
thousands upon thousands of great
instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote something to your user base so
always keep that in the back your mind
you know for me i always go back to what
industry are you in if you're in the
food industry hey you know people who
are following you are interested in food
if you're a pizza company you know show
off that pizza if you're a bakery show
off how you make your breads and goods
baked goods whatever it is you have show
it off because if somebody's following
you that's what they're interested in so
tip number eight highlight important
stories so you want to highlight
highlights serve as the easiest way to
create a first impression for a
potential follower so with highlights
can be used to tease what your contents
about create a trailer for what your
brand offers promote and promote your
product highlights are there it's a good
feature it's a first impression for
potential followers so it teases what
the contents about it creates a trailer
so to speak for your brand and promote
your product so use highlights and again
any users out there who have good
examples of highlights go ahead and put
those in the content section or comment
section right below this video so
remember stories have only a 24 hour
life span so highlights can be used to
give them a second wind okay so
highlights serve a purpose it teases
what the contents about it promotes the
product and it really kind of
accentuates that story tip number nine
ask for followers so sometimes people
need a little push before they can
follow you on instagram even if they
enjoy your content so you can ask users
to become your followers in the caption
the comment section even work it into
your content so in other words when
you're posting something don't be afraid
to say hey follow me you know i got some
good stuff here be confident you don't
want to do it for every post of course
but you know pick and choose if you feel
you have a really good post you know
really good image that you think is
going to gain a lot of followers and
engagers then you don't necessarily need
to put a caption in there but if if it
is popular then go ahead and say hey
this is a popular post you know think
about following me or put something in
the comment section you want to do it
kind of succinctly you don't want to be
begging but just work it in to some
degree okay but don't be afraid have
some confidence and asking for followers
so when you do this it's very similar to
how we do it on youtube so you can ask
viewers to subscribe to their channels
at the end of the video so it's if on
youtube basically you're saying hey if
you like what we have go ahead and
subscribe it's no different on instagram
if you have something you've posted just
go and say hey you like this you know go
ahead and follow us it's that simple so
tip number 10 take on the latest trends
to get more followers so align your
content to cater to trendy topics or
hashtags to improve engagement and
discoverability so really what we're
trying to say here is your competitors
follow influencers what are the latest
trends and you can get an idea of the
latest trends by you looking at hashtags
so what hashtags are trending which ones
are people using the most so really what
you want to do is whatever's trending in
your industry you know ride that wave so
to speak now it doesn't have to take on
your entire profile but there's nothing
wrong with one or two posts if
something's really taking on popularity
then go ahead and post about it as well
you know for example in the wine
industry if there's a new wine that
really came out that's really gaining
some popularity go ahead and post about
it with the same hashtag and with the
unique hashtag so don't be afraid to
you know ride the wave of popularity so
to speak because it shows that you know
you know what you're talking about it
adds some credibility and it's going to
get some you know viewers over to your
instagram profile so keep in mind you
need to keep your content relevant
because
if your audience is interested in what
you have to offer then they're going to
be engaged however you know if you're
joining the discussion in a relevant
manner keeping in mind whether your
audience will interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11 run contests
and giveaways and so just like on
youtube just like on facebook i mean
instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
what's an idea of a contest well again
if you're running a pizza parlor you
know you could say hey what's your
favorite pizza or give me your favorite
pizza ideas and you can run a contest
and you know you can have people even
create their own pizza and post an image
of it you can have people create stories
on the best ways in which they create
pizza or their experience in another
pizza parlor there's lots of things you
can do to create a contest and you don't
always have to give something away you
can just do something for fun especially
if you have a lot of followers if you
have a lot of followers then somebody's
going to take part in it so don't be
afraid to run contests just to make it
fun and light it up a little bit so each
tag can bring you a new audience member
who could be a potential follower so
anytime you run a contest people are
gonna tag their friends to let them know
about that contest so those friends are
gonna come over and likely engage so
that's the beauty of running a contest
or giveaway is chances are word's gonna
spread and it's gonna get you some new
followers so that's the the end benefits
so to speak but the real benefit is
keeping your audience engaged so tip
number 12 we want to stay consistent
with post so having a consistent pace
and theme for your post can have a huge
impact to convert visitors so when we
say consistent you know if you're again
that pizza parlor stay within pizza you
could branch out a little maybe and talk
about salads or talk about beverages to
you know as a complimentary factor to
the pizza okay but don't talk about
hamburgers if you're focused in on pizza
so we want to stay consistent with your
theme this method involves less effort
with a faster production of instagram
content so that mean what we're really
trying to say here is focus stay focused
on who you are if you do that if you're
consistent and you're gaining some
followers and that's what people are
coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out then it's gonna muddy the
water suppose so to speak and you're
probably gonna get less engagement so
set a theme on instagram by maintaining
consistency and your personality filters
colors and layout and really what i'm
referring to is post and when you have
post something you're you're really
creating a personality for yourself okay
so if you're in fashion for example and
you're in the genes industry well jeans
jeans jeans right that's your
personality accentuate it with different
outfits related to jeans but you know
when you start talking about dresses and
shoes and and that kind of blurs your
your personality a bit so if you stay
consistent with thin jeans and outfits
that go with jeans then i think people
are gonna start to pick up on that
personality so tip 13 keep track of your
instagram following so you can analyze
the growth of your channel with tools
like social blade that could tell you
how many followers you've lost over time
and how engaged they are okay so you can
use data gather from here and from
instagram business account to diagnose
where you're faltering so let's take a
look at social blade as an example here
so if i go over here i'm going to go to
socialblade here i can enter in
basically any account after a register
and i could see how that account has
performed you know where they rank you
know how many uploads they have what
country they focused on what industry
and the beauty here is i could see and
i'm looking at youtube as an example i
could see you know how my post to
perform well you could do this for
instagram you could do it for facebook
so you can really get an idea of how
your account's performing so
socialblade's a great platform for
measuring and again you do also have
instagram business insights so with
instagram business insights basically
what you're going to do is you're going
to go to your app right and then from
the app you could basically look at your
insights from there so in the app itself
you're going to click on the upper right
three lines and from there you're gonna
see insights and when you go to insights
you're also gonna see you know what your
reach is how many impressions and some
engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're gonna also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the the instagram
insights analytics insights but you can
also see additional information from
socialblade so the key here is when
you're looking at your data you want to
look for patterns and post what posts
receive the most amount of engagement so
if you see something working obviously
replicate it you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use instagram ads so instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with instagram ads you
can run photos you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so we
mention this on other webinars for
facebook advertising it's worth
repeating so if i go back into say
facebook ads manager i can pick and
choose my placements and really what i
want to do is pick and choose for
example instagram and so i have
instagram feed i have instagram stories
so and i could see what the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on instagram so with
instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
carousel to really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
facebook ads manager and it's gonna tell
you you know what your audience size is
your potential reach okay what your
daily results would be so you're gonna
get all that information when you run
your ads on facebook ads manager but
it's a great opportunity for you to
really
push forward if you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust reporting and highly
refined audience retargeting so all of
that is in the facebook ads manager you
can get all the reporting units you need
meaning you know who saw the ad do they
click on it okay you can refine that
target audience you can go back into
facebook ads manager and refine who your
audience is so lots of flexibility here
and advertising on instagram but the key
here is if you want to run advertising
on instagram you know think about what
it is you're trying to promote if you
feel something needs to get promoted
then go ahead and you know you can
either again reach out to somebody and
have them sponsor it or you can run it
as an advertisement so let's move on to
tip 15. so we want to create visually
attractive and eye-catching ads so if
you are gonna run ads you know here's
some things to keep in mind okay you
want to use images that are natural and
seem native okay you don't want to use
any stock photography first off you want
to use something that you've done okay
you want to minimize the amount of text
so let the image do the talking you want
to ensure your caption relates to the
image and resonates with your audience
okay so you have an opportunity to add
some text below the image okay so make
sure it resonates and then of course use
hashtags to show your ads to target your
audience but a wider relevant audience
so hashtags do play a role here as well
so these are some tips if you're going
to create ads you want to take these
into account the whole point of the ad
is to get people over to either web page
or to your profile page okay so that
they can engage and take action so
instagram ads will help showcase your
product service or brand in a way that's
memorable and unique so if you really
want to get your vision your brand your
product out there in front of a lot of
people then advertising on instagram is
a good way to do that so since we've
been talking about pizza throughout this
webinar there's a good instagram a
profile here about pizza you know i'm
getting hungry just looking at this
hopefully this is an example for all veg
and non-veg pizza consumers i mean you
can see this profile here they got the
website
you know they got the handle okay so
they have a lot of followers so you know
if i'm in the pizza industry i can go
ahead and you know click on their
followers and see who who's following
them who they're following so
some really good shots of pizza here it
looks like you know a lot of people
weren't
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
pizza photo so
here you know you could say use daily
pizza as a hashtag for feature okay so
they're even encouraging you to use a
specific hashtag so you can really do a
lot here on instagram this is just a
good example of what you can do and have
fun with you know with an example like
pizza just to give you some ideas so
let's move on to tip 16. take advantage
of instagram tools so you can use
scheduling tools like later hootsuite
and buffer so i can't stress this enough
you know when it comes to
measuring the engagement of your
instagram post you're definitely going
to need a social media tool so you're
also going to need it if you do a lot of
you know posting on instagram so let's
take a look at an example we'll use
later.com so if i go to later here i can
see you know i can use this to
upload my images to my profile so here
you can see it's scheduled throughout
the day of the week so that way we're
not overlapping you know we're
scheduling based on the times of the day
that people are gonna look at this so
you know here i could see you know
particular stories if any stories are
posted okay i can look at it from a
weekly or monthly preview i could see
what's been posted okay and more
importantly as a schedule tool i can
also see the analytics i could see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing i want to be able to see what
posts perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by
location so again i can look at it by
post performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags that this become a
particular company is using on instagram
so here you could see how many posts
with this hashtag you know and what kind
of engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job i like this
platform especially for instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how
particular posts are performing remember
if a post is performing you want to
reuse it at a certain point in time okay
learn from best practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not working then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown here and later.com so
remember these tools place an emphasis
on automation okay enabling you to
automatically post at a scheduled time
so you want to lock it in at a certain
period of time and i have to worry about
it so it allows you to really hone in on
that particular time of the day
and day of the week so that you're
really maximizing your chances of
getting good engagement okay so develop
your own signature styles to set up a
style and content theme so that you're
able to stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just going
back to our pizza example lots of good
photos of pizza and but this is their
style this is who they are you know
they're not a particular brand they're
just you know people who like pizza okay
and they're having fun with it okay so
that's their style you know they're
posting really good shots of all these
different types of pizza different
styles different toppings and just to
give you an idea of how popular pizza is
and what you can do with it okay so
again this is a good basic example um of
what you can do
with something as simple as pizza so
don't be afraid to experiment you know
try something different with your
profile you know do something different
you don't always have to follow what
everybody else is doing that's the great
thing about instagram it allows you to
be free and creative in fact if anybody
has any styles that have worked for them
you know feel free to put something in
the comments section we'd love to hear
your thoughts so tip 18 use user
engagement to your advantage so i just
mentioned that using the later example
so we want to be able to
learn from what's working and not
working so user-generated content shows
off your brand to be authentic and
improves your relationship with your
followers so you know you want to be
unique with the content that you're
posting so
if you do that you're likely to build
that relationship and you know increase
your followers and you want to be able
to see of that user generated content
that ugc which is performing which is
not performing okay so basically your
followers and your audience are telling
you what's working and not working so
take advantage of that remember going
back to hashtags you could set up your
own unique hashtag and ask your users to
post images or videos relating to that
which you can post in your brand's
account so just like the whole pizza
thing they're saying hey look you know
use daily pizza for a feature okay
that's a good example of something you
can do as well so you could set up a
unique hashtag and say hey use this
hashtag and that'll help you gain some
followers that'll help you gain some
notoriety and some visibility on your
platform tip 19 use high quality images
and videos just like on youtube just
like on facebook instagram is no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original i mean again one
more time go back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality i
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all it usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
because it really is going to take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video or
whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos needs to be
fun and informational without causing
the user to lose interest so you know if
you're going to create a video you know
go ahead and you know make you can make
it short make it fun okay you can see
here these guys are just showing you how
pizza is made it doesn't take a long
time they're just going through the
motions they're not boring you with
details they're not talking really quick
and easy just to give you an idea it
doesn't have to be as serious it can be
fun so video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating don't use stock
images on instagram because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side be concise high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you could do that you're likely gonna
hold the user's attention so tip 20
promote your instagram page and other
social media channels so facebook and
instagram are part of the same family so
this seems like a natural but you know
don't be afraid to
promote it on other channels like
pinterest or or youtube the whole idea
is to get users to your instagram page
and encourage them to follow it so you
know you can always put that url in you
know other platforms like youtube
nothing wrong with that at all okay you
can also promote your page offline with
print ads and during other relevant
events and then i would even take this
to further is you'll probably see you
know an instagram
logo on a webpage along with other
social media icons so you always want to
help promote instagram on your web page
as well but you can do it for offline
with print ads so you can simply just
put you know whatever your your slug is
for instagram whatever your id is
whatever you're using on instagram
that's what you can use don't be afraid
to promote it offline or online social
media marketing tools social media
always a great topic to talk about so
we're going to finish up all our digital
marketing tools with social media we
talked about seo paid competition
affiliate email you know web analytics
it's just appropriate to finish up with
social media because social media has so
many tools available so many okay
the first one i can think about here is
hootsuite hootsuite is a great social
media marketing tool to use okay it's a
freemium okay you can set up a free
trial here
you you basically a base account and
then uh you can use hootsuite to do a
lot of things anything from setting up
landing pages to actually publishing
content to listening hootsuite to me is
one of the most powerful social media
marketing tools available you got buffer
buffers a paid version but you can
actually set up a low cost or free
account actually on buffer and then move
to a paid account okay you got tweet
decks been around a long time that is
actually free and i would recommend
tweetdeck and we're gonna take a look at
that here in a couple minutes okay and
then you got sprout social sprout social
is another social marketing platform
similar to hootsuite
do a lot of reporting a lot of
publishing you can a lot of listening
and so we're going to take a look at
sprout chelsea today as well before we
do that
let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be instagram pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you could manage
everything one place then the social
media marketing platforms need to be
able to make it easy for you to add and
manage different accounts okay so a lot
of them have the ability for you to add
you know not just one twitter account
but multiple twitter accounts and not
just one social media platform but
multiple social media platforms and a
good social media marketing so worth its
weight will help you monitor
the results so monitor social media
posts that help drive leads and sales in
other words you're gonna have a lot of
different metrics associated with each
social media marketing platform okay
which one is actually doing its job okay
so you want to be able to easily manage
these platforms applications and
websites very efficiently okay so
instead of having to log into each
platform is log into one place get a
sense of what's been posted what the
engagement is did they purchase etc and
what you want to do is be able to
individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in these social media marketing tools
okay you don't want to send out a
blanket message across different
platforms you want to be able to
go ahead and customize a post depending
on what that post is depending on what
the product is what time of day what
target market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand advocate
who's not a brand advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual post on real-time data so
if for example you post something using
one of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like sprout social and hootsuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are
running
ads on facebook or you're posting on
facebook as an example or any platform
in general that platform's going to have
its own metrics if you will so for
example facebook has something called
facebook insight so you'll be able to
actually see you know what's been posted
based on you know the last seven days in
this example how many page views you're
getting engagements recent posts so just
to let you know
yes you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
facebook ads okay you can go right into
facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sprout social i can set up
these accounts right into sprout social
so i don't have to log in on twitter
individually or facebook individually i
can link them up all within sprout
social and then i can go to reports just
like i can with facebook insights and
then once i'm in facebook excuse me once
i'm in sprout social reporting then i
can go ahead just like i can in facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me i can jump into you know facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so i don't have
to log into facebook directly i can see
you know the impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time i could
see my audience growth i can see my
publishing behavior how often my
publishing i can see the top post
individually i could see impressions by
day you know a lot of this same
material same information is already in
facebook insights so if it's available
on facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know i can go to instagram you
know and look at instagram data or i can
look at twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example sprout social now as i mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose select a profile
write whatever we need to do you can
schedule it for tomorrow at a specific
time and there you go voila scheduled so
this is on twitter okay so you know we
could choose another platform here it's
just that easy to schedule so you want
to be able to schedule accordingly
because again when you schedule
something then you want to look at the
behavior of it so it's just as simple as
going from publishing to reporting and
then based on when something got
published you could see the reaction of
it and react to it so another thing here
that i like about it's about social
hootsuite a lot of these other platforms
do it really well you got listening
tools so you can listen in on
conversations that are being hacked for
example
uh mail delivery you know if we do mail
delivery and twitter search we'll be
able to see what's been tweeted about
mail deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can
refine our search and choose a specific
location or radius to hone in if we're
local okay so this is sprout social's
example of listening here let's take a
look at another example i'm in later.com
so later very similar to sprout social
and that it does a lot of the same
things you can actually schedule
content on a particular platform and one
thing i like about later here you can
actually see it visually you can see a
calendar and what's been scheduled so i
could see today i have scheduled
something scheduled at 1 15
local time and again i have five
profiles set up for this account
so i can pick and choose the profile
that i want to publish to so it just
makes it that much easier and i can
visually see it and that's important so
here i can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if i click
on this image here okay i can get a
sense of when it was used and i can view
it on a calendar i can add label for it
so
that's another benefit to later is that
they have this media library here they
have conversations so i can actually
connect to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being had similar
to the listening tool in sprout social
and they have analytics so you can
actually see
write in later.com how your particular
social media platform is performing so i
can see it here over seven days i can
see the number of followers have
increased i could see the growth rate i
can see the number of impressions that
i've received okay so i want to be able
to see how my particular platform's
performing over a period of time so i
can look at reach the la profile views
website clicks okay so i can get a lot
of good insights here right in the
analytics platform later you can look at
specific post performance so we posted
something i could see basically how many
likes it received how many comments
impressions the reach and then if i
wanted to i can click on details and get
more specific information on it
engagement rate okay discovery actions
comments saves etc so later.com goes
into some nice detail about post
performance they even have date on
hashtags so if you use an hashtag you
can actually see how many times the
hashtags been used or saved how many
impressions it's received okay so they
really go into some nice detail here
about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool i really like i've been using for a
long time and that's tweetdeck so what
tweetdeck does is connect with your
twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here i can see this is my feed here
okay i can see some notifications i can
see specific messages then on this
column i can see activity okay so i can
add different columns here if i wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
could see i can look for what's trending
as an example so i'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now i
can go in and see okay these are all the
different
things that are trending on twitter
so you can actually add a column and pay
attention to something really specific
okay so for example search okay so right
now i have men's health but i could type
in let's just say world cup okay so i
can see the you got the cricket world
cup you got you know the soccer football
world cup going on so you know we could
pick a particular topic to follow if we
wanted to so again here i'm following
men's health so i can now see you know
everything that's been posted on men's
health now if i click on for example one
of these hashtags here that's trending i
can actually see who's tagging or using
that hashtag friday feeling in their
tweets and so the whole idea behind you
know tweet deck it serves up a
interesting overview so to speak of not
only your account but you know a
specific topic or what's trending or you
know other things that are being said so
if you really want to pay attention to
your brand or something really specific
like you know your competitors or a
specific product then you can just do a
search on that and so that's the great
thing about tweak deck it allows you to
kind of just look and listen in on
everything going on in twitter with that
we have reached the end of day three of
our digital marketing week on day four
we are going to learn about email and
content marketing thank you all for
watching this live session i hope it was
useful and informative thanks again and
see you tomorrow
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you